Das war's für heute.
So, easy 60 grind heute.
Noch genau 15%.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das packen.
Ich hoffe mal.
So, jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen weniger Headbang-Musik an.
Sondern irgendwas entspanntes.
Das war's. Ich mach einfach diese Playlist an von gestern.
Übrigens, wenn der Stream wieder ab und zu mal ganz kurz ruckelt, legt das nicht an mir, sondern an.
Drei Mal dürft ihr raten.
Bam!
Wollte ich dir noch mal erwähnen.
Nur weil wir gerade mal dabei waren.
Wegen denen hier ist das Stream jetzt schon ein paar Mal abgekackt.
Wir müssen das mal anders machen.
Moment, Image hinzufügen.
Moment, Moment, das müssen wir anders machen.
So, Moment, Image, 0.3d1, 0.3d2.
Die reiten ja eh noch.
So, jetzt haben wir das Telekom-Logo schön verziert.
So, wir reiten heute mal zu einem anderen Spot.
Ich will mal gucken, wie die XP da ist.
Da hab ich ziemlich viel gegrindet auf 59.
Hier.
Gucken, wie das so ist.
Telekom in 2k17, ja, ist echt so.
Fast schon 2k18, 2k18.
Stream ruckelt, jawoll.
Danke Telekom.
Das macht ihr ganz toll, Telekom.
Das ist das beste.
4k Stream 1, sobald Twitch mal ordentlich Bandbreite erlaubt.
Und nicht nur 6 MBit.
6 MBit ist einfach zu wenig.
Wenn Stream bei allen ruckelt, liegt das an der Telekom.
Das Reitgeräusch ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Ich würde sagen, so ist laut genug.
Die reitet, die Spells sind eh lauter.
Easy clap.
Ah, Pets gefüttert, kann losgehen.
Repariert ist auch alles.
Easy win.
Easy 60.
Am besten sind die, die ihre Wots nur für Subs anbieten.
Ja, das nervt mich auch.
Das ist ein Grund für mich nicht zu subben.
Ich find das auch bescheuert.
Wots sind oftmals so die Quelle, weil man den Streamer nicht allzu gut kennt.
Um sich einfach mal so die letzten paar Broadcasts ein bisschen rein zu gucken.
Sich anzuschauen, will man da follow, will man vielleicht subben.
Aber wenn das halt gar nicht geht.
Ich find's blöd, die Wots Subscriber-only zu machen.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass es letztendlich unterm Strich was bringt.
Ja, und wie das Serious Marks sagt, das könnte ja auch eh jemand das Zeug einfach mitschneiden.
Machen ja ganz viele, ne?
Wenn man mal auf YouTube guckt nach Overwatch Highlights.
Oder da sind ja teilweise ganze 6 Stunden Livestreams von Pros mitgeschnitten und einfach hochgeladen.
Auf Channels, mit denen die halt absolut nichts zu tun haben.
Muss ich mal überlegen, ne?
Streamt einer 6 Stunden, gibt's Schmür.
Irgendeiner schneidet's mit.
Legt auf YouTube hoch und easy Views.
War auf sich auch so.
Ah, ich weiß warum die Musik so laut ist, bei mir und bei euch so leise.
Weil ich's wieder falsch eingestellt hab.
Lol.
Kaum macht man's richtig, schon geht's.
Ich muss das jetzt immer im Chrome Tab, weil OBS, beziehungsweise Shadowplay sonst Musik drin hat.
Muss ich das jetzt immer umschalten im Chrome, dass es die zweite USB Soundcard verwendet.
Sonst geht das nicht.
Wow.
WTF.
Ich werde gehostet.
Krasser Scheiß.
Zielkrampf.
Danke, 110.
110 Viewer.
Jetzt könnt ihr mal den richtigen BDO Noob zugucken, Leute.
Den größten BDO Noob mit der besten Ausrüstung für einen BDO Noob.
Und noch besser, die Ausrüstung hab ich mir nicht mal selbst enchantet.
Wir machen jetzt Writing Stream.
Ja, Marvin, das ist echt ein Problem.
Also ich seh das, wie gesagt, ich seh das bei ganz vielen Overwatch Pros.
Die Stream, teilweise, wenn ihr X2C und sowas anguckt, die Stream hat teilweise irgendwie 8 Stunden gefüllt.
Da gibt es halt auch schon viele Highlights in dem Stream.
Vor allem bei X2C, das ist immer ganz lustig.
Und da hast du Leute, die machen dann X2C Stream Compilation, 10 Minuten, laden das hoch,
kriegen irgendwie 80.000 bis 150.000 Views und laden das halt auf ihrem Channel hoch,
der mit X2C gar nichts zu tun hat.
Da muss man sich schon mal fragen, ist das so in Ordnung, ja?
Also ich bin ja normalerweise, ich mach ja sonst nie so einen großen Akt,
ich mach immer doch hier, rechte, da, Copyright, hier und da und sonst was,
weil es das meistens für den Viewer eigentlich oder generell für uns alle eigentlich nur nerviger macht.
Aber sowas muss ja auch nicht sein, ja?
Valkorion, moin.
Freezie carry Zielkampf, ja so ist es.
Ich streite das ja auch gar nicht ab.
Der Spot sackt immer noch.
Ich streite das ja auch überhaupt nicht ab, dass ich Freezie carried bin.
Und auf der anderen Seite, ich muss Freezie carried sein,
weil ohne den Farmherd hätte ich ja das Game noch nicht mal angefangen.
Ich habe ja eigentlich das Game nur angefangen,
dass ich mal mit dem Farmherd wieder ein bisschen MMO spielen kann.
Die Mops halten viel zu viel aus, da mache ich lieber Easy-Naga-Grind wieder.
Schau ich das mal an.
Die sterben ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja nichts.
Das ist gar nicht, warum ich hier früher so viel rumgekrainert habe.
Aber war es nicht.
Ja, Atio, das stimmt.
Also manche finden das ja auch gut.
Aber bei XQC in dem Fall denke ich mir halt,
dass der Gegend, weil der lädt selber Stream-Highlights hoch bei sich auf dem Channel.
Und dann finde ich es ein bisschen affig,
wenn quasi andere Leute Konkurrenz-Stream-Highlights machen,
obwohl du selbst Stream-Highlights hoch lädst,
die halt mit dir nichts zu tun haben.
Das ist da schon ein bisschen bescheuert.
Mein Pferd beschwert sich, dass es gleich kaputt geht.
Moment, habe ich eigentlich das richtige Zeug an?
Ja.
Oh, ich muss Buff-Food nehmen. Wo habe ich denn aufgehört?
Ähm...
Casting-Speed, das habe ich genommen.
AP plus 5, move und...
Ja, das ist jetzt dran. Okay, gut.
Ja, wenn es jetzt jemand ist, der einfach nur Livestreams macht
und es dem im Prinzip egal ist,
dann habe ich ja auch keinen Schmerz mit,
wenn einer Stream-Compilations oder Stream-Highlights hoch lädt auf YouTube.
Oh, Boss-Baschen.
Aber wenn die Leute halt selbst den Channel haben...
Ja, gut, die Dinge halten immer so viel aus hier. Sackt.
Alter Lan. Sackt.
Ist das eigentlich irgendwie eine schnellere Variante, die zu baschen?
Ich glaube nicht, oder? Oh!
Soll ich nicht einfach so stehen bleiben und mich hinten lassen?
No Damage.
Kann er mal sterben jetzt?
Oho, ein Rosablade. Jawoll, jetzt bin ich klar instant-rich.
Denkst du, dass das heute mit 60 noch was wird?
Äh, ich weiß, ich hoffe. Ich hoffe, also wir haben ja demnächst Nacht.
Easy. RNG.
Hat sich schon gelohnt, hierher zu kommen.
Wobei, ich glaube, wir machen nachher wieder Naga-Kraisel-Grind, wenn es Nacht wird.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen bis kurz bevor es Nacht wird hier.
Dann dürfte ich auch gefüllt sein mit Trash-Loot.
Dann gehen wir das auf den Weg verkaufen, dann mache ich Naga-Kraisel-Grind weiter.
Wie lange spielst du?
Ähm, also angefangen? Ich weiß, hab ich schon angefangen.
Also ich spiele halt kaum.
Ähm, ich glaube, ich hab letztes oder vorletztes Jahr angefangen.
Ein bisschen gespielt, ein halbes Jahr nicht mehr gespielt.
Dann Reroll von Bersi auf Wizard.
Der Bersi war 56 oder so, der hatte nix.
Dann Wizard ein bisschen gespielt, jetzt wieder drei Monate nicht gespielt.
Ich bin eigentlich der übelste Noob in dem Game.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber mein Wizard kann ich die drei Spells drücken, die ich brauche, um die Mobs zu bashen.
Das krieg ich hin. Wizard-Bash krieg ich hin.
Das wär so ein fetter, was wir bashen wieder.
Oh, kann das sein, dass ich mein Pet nicht doch? Ich hab mein Pet beschworen.
Hauptsache ganzes Boss-Gehe-auf-Trieb.
Ja, das ist zwei Sachen zu verdanken.
Einmal übelstes Lack Glück beim Boss-Gehen bekommen.
Ich kann da gleich noch was zu sagen.
Ich wusste, als ich das alles gekriegt hab, gar nicht zu schätzen, wie selten das eigentlich ist.
Da erzähl ich gleich mal, was ich das Viech hier gekillt hab.
Und als nächstes, dass mir das der Farmir und der Frisur alles entchanted hat.
Wenn mir das der Farmir nicht alles entchanted hätte, ich weiß dann nicht mal, wie man ordentlich entchantet.
Also ich weiß prinzipiell, wie es funktioniert.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung, wo da die besten...
Also bei welcher Qualitätsstufe, welche Failstacks, wie man das am besten macht und am optimiertsten.
Letztendlich ist es random, ja.
Aber umso mehr Versuche du rausholen kannst, umso öfters hast du halt die Chance.
Beziehungsweise kannst du halt dein random Lack probieren.
Hätte Fabian mir das nicht entchantet, dann...
Also wohlgemerkt, ich hätte ja ohne ihn auch nie angefangen.
Deswegen.
Ich zeig jetzt, weil ich muss jetzt gleich mal meine Items zeigen.
Und zwar, also übelst, übelst mega Lack, ne?
Wo fange man an?
Ach ja, Helm hab ich, hab ich auch Jaius Helm am Start, liegt in Velia im Vault rum.
Also Jaius Helm hab ich gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus.
Also aus dem Marketplace.
Sogar on stream, einfach reingelackt wieder.
Die Rüstung hab ich aus einem Daily Reward gezogen.
Den haben wir letztens entchantet.
Selbst aus, quasi auch Daily Rewards und Boxen der letzten paar Monate.
Das ist halt, ja halt, random Loot.
Die haben, die Beaks haben wir auch gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus.
Auch on stream, ich glaub beim Friseur auf dem Stream.
Den haben wir auch aus dem Auktionshaus gesniped.
Und, jetzt kommt der Hit.
Äh, den haben wir auch gesniped.
So, und die Maskenschuhe, die hab ich aus der zweiten Questrolle gezogen.
Die ich überhaupt gemacht hab, jemals in BDO.
Ich hab, ich, ich hab einfach mal random, glaub ich, komm hier.
Machst jetzt mal die ganzen Black Spirit Quests.
Und irgendwie in der zweiten Woche oder so, die dritte Rolle.
Also man kriegt ja dann irgendwie immer ein paar Packages zum Aufmachen, wenn man den Boss gekillt hat.
Ähm, hab ich aufgemacht und so, ja, instant Schuhe.
Und ich bin so, nice, so schwer ist das doch gar nicht.
Und ich, wie gesagt, ich wusste das damals so überhaupt nicht zu schätzen, wie selten das eigentlich ist, ja.
Und ich hab so, ja, weiß gar nicht, wo ist das Problem, so schwer ist das doch gar nicht, easy und so.
Ja.
So, und nächsten Monat, wahrscheinlich so am, wahrscheinlich irgendwie so 7. Januar oder so.
Mal gucken, wie die Daily Rewards ausfallen.
Hab ich dann 70 Shakatu Seals gesammelt aus den Daily Rewards, hier, da.
Morgen gibt's noch eins. Oh, die müssen wir gleich zusammen aufmachen.
Die hab ich auf dem Bersi schon liegen.
Morgen krieg ich noch mal 5 Shakatu Seals.
Dann hab ich 65, das heißt im Januar hab ich 70.
Dann kann ich mir mal eine Dande kaufen und dann hab ich easy Boss Gear.
Alles fertig, bis halt hier auf noch besseren Schmuck.
Alles fertig, komplett, ohne zu spielen eigentlich.
Das ist halt Glück.
Das kann man jetzt gar nicht mehr Glück nennen.
Also ich glaub in BDO hab ich irgendwie eh so ein Glücksbuff auf meinem Account.
Wir haben jetzt ja ein bisschen Naga-Crime gemacht die letzten Tage.
Auch 3 Seraph Necklaces und alles getroppt.
Easy.
Laka Streamer Friend carried. Ja, richtig.
Das ist, wir haben uns das Luck quasi aufgeteilt.
Der Fabian hat seinen Luck mitgebracht beim Enchanten und ich hab meinen Luck mitgebracht beim Items überhaupt erst bekommen.
Jetzt musst du nur richtig suchten wie Friesi. Nee, kann ich ja gar nicht.
Deswegen spiel ich, das ist auch, das finde ich echt gut an BDO.
Du hast schon deine Vorteile wenn du 24-7 suchtest.
Ist gar nicht die Frage.
Aber du wirst nicht total abgehängt.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so mega casual, dass du quasi, so wie Final Fantasy Online, also das 14er, war das 14?
Im Prinzip wurdest du dir ja künstlich verlangsamt deinen Procrust.
Selbst wenn du viel spielen wolltest hat dir nichts gebracht.
Aber hier bringt es dir was wenn du viel spielst.
Äh Moment, wo sind denn die Mops hin?
Da stellst einer rum.
Was soll denn das?
Aber du wirst auch nicht total abgehängt wenn du es halt casual-mäßig spielst wie ich.
Ich hab überhaupt keine Zeit 24-7 zu suchten, das klappt nicht.
Ich mein ich muss immerhin noch arbeiten gehen, 4 Tage in der Woche.
Plus mich um einen YouTube-Channel kümmern und da auch Content produzieren.
So und ab und zu will ich auch mal was anderes machen als das.
Und vielleicht auch noch was anderes als BDO spielen.
Dazu kommt, dass ich ja auch noch Overwatch spiele.
Also im Prinzip, im Prinzip, ich kann das Game gar nicht 24-7 suchten.
Und trotzdem funktioniert das ganz gut.
Also das haben sie wirklich nicht schlecht hingekriegt.
Da kann man nix sagen.
Bam.
Ja wie oft auf deinem YouTube-Channel kommt oft Content.
Guck mal nach, da kommt ziemlich viel.
Guck mal nach wie viele Videos dieses Monats gekommen sind.
Mehr konnte ich eigentlich kaum machen.
Da sieht man schon mal, wenn quasi schon mehr als so nicht drin ist.
Und ich hatte den ganzen Monat Urlaub.
Da kann man sich vorstellen wie das ist wenn ich nach 4 Tagen die Woche arbeiten gehe.
Da ist halt 24-7 suchten BDO nicht drinne.
Außerdem muss ich sagen ist BDO jetzt auch nicht das Spiel was ich wirklich 24-7 suchten will.
Arbeiten in 2K17.
Ja und weißt du was das Schlimme ist?
Wer hat's geschrieben?
Timbo, weißt du was das Schlimme ist?
Nicht nur Arbeit in 2K17, sondern auch Arbeit in 2K18.
Ich weiß gar nicht was ihr alle wollt gerade.
Ich hab bestimmt diesen Monats 10 Videos hochgeladen oder so.
Das ist im Vergleich so viel wie ich sonst gefühlt in einem halben Jahr oder so hochlade.
Moment was will der hier?
What?
Ist alles weg?
Oops.
Gehen wir die andere Rotation abgrinden.
Wie gesagt wir machen das Eno bis wir voll sind.
Wenn wir voll sind dann verkaufen wir das und wechseln für die Nacht den Spot.
Hab ich überhaupt noch Black Spirit Buff?
50% Scroll?
Nee.
Nee WBPD irgendwelchen Beef interessiert mich nicht.
Sollen sich alle anbiefen wenn sie da Bock drauf haben.
Ganzer Kindergarten da.
Also mich interessiert das so überhaupt nicht wenn sich da irgendwelche Leute beefen auf YouTube oder Twitch oder sonst was.
Manche Sachen finde ich ganz witzig ja.
Aber auch nur weil man die Streamer guckt.
Ansonsten wird es total egal wenn sie sich da irgendwie zoffen.
Flexinatus.
Ja manchmal dauert es halt ein bisschen länger.
Ich gebe ja auch zu der Twitch Name ist jetzt nicht sonderlich intuitiv mit mir in Verbindung zu bringen.
Das liegt aber einfach daran dass es nie geplant war eigentlich auf dem Account zu streamen.
Und ich dachte mir als ich mir dann überlegt habe hey du fängst doch an zu streamen behältst du den Account.
Weil das ist gar nicht so schlimm wenn es die Leute gar nicht direkt erkennen.
Weil die die es interessiert die finden das.
Vor allem ich habe es ja schon ein paar mal auf YouTube gesagt und so.
Und die die nur rum nerven wollen die haben nicht genug Energie zu gucken und die finden es nicht.
Nerven dann auch nicht.
Also eigentlich ist es ganz gut das ich ja anders heiße.
Oh das ist ja ein Boss ich sollte vielleicht mal hingucken.
Oder Boss Elite Viech halt.
Violent Viech.
Das ist grausam das Ding.
Ganz violent.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht was du da machen wolltest.
Du wolltest irgendeine VR Geschichte.
VR IKEA Einrichtung oder so wolltest du machen.
Ich kann dir da gerne helfen an programmieren.
Dann kann ich einen Vertrag machen vorher.
Wobei ich sagen muss ich würde wirklich mal gerne was für VR programmieren.
Einfach weil ich es noch nie gemacht habe.
Die anderen Seite ich habe von 3D Sachen relativ wenig Ahnung.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern wie schwer wir uns getan haben im Stream.
Als ich mit DirectX BDO aufnehmen wollte und in Mini Fenster zeichnen.
Das haben wir ja vor ein paar Monaten im Stream gemacht.
Da habe ich quasi versucht BDO aufzunehmen.
Das war das was OBS macht im Endeffekt.
Wollte ich mal nach programmieren und gucken.
Da haben wir uns richtig ein abgebrochen im Stream bis das funktioniert hat.
Auf was basiert VR überhaupt?
Das kommt drauf an was du dir für eine Brille kaufst.
Dann vermute ich mal dass es vom jeweiligen Hersteller irgendein Entwickler Kit gibt.
Egal ob du eine Oculus kaufst oder eine HTC Brille oder was auch immer.
Da wird es wahrscheinlich ein Entwickler Kit für geben.
Dass es dann mit der Hardware ganz besonders toll funktioniert.
Um die Spezialitäten der jeweiligen Hardware auszunutzen.
Ansonsten machst du das wahrscheinlich ganz normal, wie man das unter Windows für Games halt macht.
Oder du kannst es wahrscheinlich auch mit OpenGL machen.
Das ist ja dann letztendlich egal.
Wobei unter Windows Diag3D eindeutig zu bevorzugen ist.
Warum halten das Viech so viel aus?
Ich habe das Gefühl die sind früher schneller umgefallen.
Jetzt muss ich mir einen Back Attack machen.
Wenn das weiter in der Rate droppt muss ich sogar noch zum Auktionshaus den ganzen Krempel verkaufen.
Max hast du den neuen Helden Release von Jeff Kaplan im Stream gesehen?
Gab es da einen neuen Held?
Ich habe gesehen wie Jeff vor dem Ofen gesessen hat und nichts gemacht.
Ist Jeffs Ofen quasi der neue Held oder was?
Kannst du einen Clip schicken, ja?
Gibt es echt einen neuen Overwatch Held?
Hast du gar nicht die Gratis Mark doch?
Irgendwo habe ich die.
Ich habe noch nie eine Maid verwendet.
Da gibt es doch irgendwo eine Scroll die man einlösen muss.
Abgeholt haben wir sie.
Jetzt schmilzt er aber ganz schön den Impf zu.
So geil ist die XP jetzt auch nicht.
Aber bald ist Nacht, dann zünden wir wieder alle unsere Buffs die es gibt, dann geht es ab.
Also in der Nacht kriegen wir wieder easy 90% hin.
Und danach ist einfach nur noch grind bis zum Umfallen.
Guck mir den Link gleich an.
Du kannst mit grind nichts anfangen.
Das ist halt Geschmackssache.
Wobei ich finde grind gibt es halt in jedem MMO.
Und mir ist das lieber, oder ich sage mal so, was mir noch lieber wäre, wenn es Gruppengrind wäre.
Gruppengrind ist eigentlich das was ich in MMOs am besten finde.
Aber wenn man mal von anderen MMOs ausgeht, wenn du jetzt mal WoW anguckst, irgendwas oder Final Fantasy oder es ist im Prinzip egal was.
Da grindest du ja auch, da grindest du halt Quests bis zum Umfallen.
Und die Quests sind halt wenn man ehrlich ist auch nicht spannend.
In MMO Quests könnten wir auch innerhalb von 2 Stunden uns 100 Stück ausdenken.
So die Standard MMO Quests, die sind halt einfach dumm.
Sammle 10 Plumen, versorge keine Ahnung 50 Soldaten mit ihrem Abendessen, du grenzt halt rum, was auch immer.
Das ist halt auch grind, aber halt grind in anderer Form.
Am besten finde ich Gruppengrind, das macht mir in MMOs eigentlich am meisten Bock.
Und ich meine damit ist nicht Dungeon Finder Gruppengrind.
Dungeon Finder finde ich immer noch so eines der bescheuerten Ideen die sie jemals hatten in MMOs.
Aber das ist doch super monoton oder nicht?
Ja schon.
Es ist ja im Prinzip in Diablo auch, wenn du immer mit den gleichen Monster haust.
Aber das Kampfsystem in BDO ist, und ich spiele Wizard.
Wizard hat schon somit das einfachste was du machen kannst.
Du läufst den Gegner, drückst 3 Spells, den Gegner tot.
Das Kampfsystem in BDO macht es aber immer noch ganz interessant, auch wenn du das 4 Stunden am Stück machst.
Oder 6 Stunden am Stück.
Zu ab kein Ding.
Zumal man es ja auch ein bisschen weniger monoton machen kann als hier immer am gleichen Spot.
Manchmal wenn man mehrere Helden hat, kann man natürlich auch wechseln zwischendurch.
Ich wollte eben noch irgendwas sagen zu Dungeon Finder, genau.
Ich finde Dungeon Finder sind somit die blödeste Ideen die sie hatten bisher in MMOs.
Also seit wo mit diesem Mist angefangen hat.
Weil, Dungeon Finder, also eines der größten Komponenten die so ein MMO hat, ist ja neben diesem offensichtlichen, was du hier hast,
irgendwie Mops, Farmen, Items verbessern und sonst was, ist in MMOs wo es unterschiedliche Server gibt.
In BDO ist es jetzt halt mittlerweile ein großer Server, aber sag mal in MMOs wo es unterschiedliche Server gibt,
hast du ja auch irgendwo bei MMOs so eine soziale Komponente drin.
Also sprich du kennst halt die Leute die auf deinem Server spielen, du weißt wer ist ein guter Tank, wer ist ein guter Heiler, wer ist ein guter was auch immer, das weißt du halt.
So und diese ganze Komponente oder auch generell, du organisierst dich irgendwie in der Gilde oder sonst was.
Oder es gibt Spots wo sich die Leute treffen zum Leveln und so Sachen in der Richtung, das wird mit Dungeon Finder komplett rausgenommen.
Zu Gunsten dafür, dass man halt mal easy einloggen kann, 30 Minuten Simple Dungeon grindet und dann wieder ausloggt.
Nehmt es halt die komplette, so diesen kompletten sozialen Aspekt, den es früher in MMOs gegeben hat, weg, Dungeon Finder.
Deswegen finde ich Dungeon Finder kacke. Total bescheuerte Idee.
Begrönt wird das ganze natürlich dann noch und das geht ja meistens Hand in Hand von Dungeon Finder für Instanzen.
Also sprich instanziertes Dungeon Zeug zusammengewürfelt mit anderen Leuten von anderen Servern.
Dann hast du nämlich nicht nur die soziale Komponente von deinem Server aus dem MMO rausgenommen, sondern auch noch komplett verwürfelt mit anderen Leuten.
Also das heißt die Leute die du mit denen da zusammenspielst im Dungeon über den Dungeon Finder, die siehst du danach wahrscheinlich nie wieder, weil die von irgendeinem anderen Server kommen.
Das heißt du kannst es erstens auffüllen wie die Axt im Wald und zweitens erzeugt es auch überhaupt kein Gefühl, man spielt zusammen.
Ist einfach kacke Dungeon Finder.
So und da bin ich froh, dass sowas hier nicht gibt.
Hier gibt es auch keine Instanzen.
Bei BDO würde ich halt sagen, warum es das alles nicht gibt, liegt einmal daran, weil sie es nicht wollen.
Und ich glaube auch, weil sie es nicht können.
Also technischer Seite sieht man halt an BDO oftmals, dass da sehr viel mit heißer Nadel gestrickt ist.
Und es ist natürlich einfacher einfach eine große Welt zu machen und da Leute drin rumrennen zu lassen, als eine instanzierte große Welt zu machen.
Easy Catch, Re-Bash.
So wenn ich die Mops hier tot habe, guckst du mir den Link gleich mal an.
Steam oder Standalone Version, ich würde sagen ist egal.
Aber vielleicht haben wir hier irgendwelche Pros im Chat, die sagen können, was besser ist.
Weil im Prinzip, wenn du mit Steam anfängst, darfst du auf den Steam Servern spielen zum Einstieg.
Und wenn du mit der Standalone Version anfängst, darfst du auf den Einsteigerservern der Standalone anfangen.
Also macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied.
Ja, der Chef verarscht irgendwie Leute im Stream, wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder?
Also wenn das das ist, dann habe ich das gesehen.
Das ist das, woran er dann auch erzählt, dass die Kekse nicht echt sind und die Milch hier ewig rumsteht und sowas.
Dann habe ich das gesehen schon.
Chef soll mal anstatt die Leute zu verarschen sein Game besser machen.
Was gibt es denn bei Steam für BDO-Versionen?
Weil wir haben ja gestern mal ein bisschen gerechnet und festgestellt, die Advanced Version oder wie das heißt,
lohnt sich von den Inhalten her, wenn man es ein bisschen spielt.
Mit zweimal Value Packs, Inventar Erweiterungen und sowas.
Gibt es die über Steam auch.
Ja, aber testen kann vorher definitiv nicht schaden, wie gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben hat.
Testen kann man auch ohne irgendwelche Sachen sich zu kaufen.
Also man kann ein Spiel allgemein spielen, ohne sich was zu kaufen, aber manche Sachen sind halt sehr sinnvoll.
Inventar Erweiterungen, Storage Erweiterungen, Pads und sowas.
Das erleichtert das Leben schon ungemein.
Was stört mich an Overwatch?
Das vor allem, was mich an Overwatch stört, ist das verkackte Ranking-System.
Aber da will ich jetzt nicht wieder von anfangen, weil erstens reg ich mich dann wieder auf.
Und zweitens erzähle ich das jeden Stream.
So und neben dem verkackten Ranking-System regt mich auch auf, dass es so ewig dauert, bis sich was tut in dem Game.
Du kannst doch nicht die Leute drei Monate irgendeinen Crap spielen lassen und nicht mit ihnen kommunizieren.
Muss man sich doch nicht wundern, wenn da keiner mal Bock drauf hat.
Weißt du, wenn Blizzard wenigstens sagen würde, ja Leute, wir haben jetzt mal hier analysiert, so und so viele Pickrate von dem Held ist uns zu hoch.
Wir schauen gerade, was wir tun können.
Das wird voll und ganz reichen, das wird die Spieler auch schon mal glücklich machen.
Die wissen, hey Blizzard hat es mitgekriegt, alles gut.
Aber Blizzard sagt einfach gar nichts.
Das ist halt ab und zu irgendein Developer-Update, was dir auch nicht wirklich viel weiterbringt.
Und am besten war immer noch der, ich habe vergessen, wie der heißt, der Overwatch-League-Obermacher.
Der hat sich ja in so ein paar Videos und Podcasts in letzter Zeit rumgetrieben und Overwatch League Promote und ein paar Sachen dazu erzählt.
Und am besten war es, er hat auch so eine Ask Me Anything und sowas auf Reddit gemacht.
Und da waren wirklich interessante Fragen dabei, so nach dem Motto, ja wie ist es denn jetzt eigentlich?
Ist es Pros wirklich nicht erlaubt, andere Spiele zu streamen und sowas?
Ich meine, das ist für Pros, wenn man sich jemanden anguckt wie Seagull oder sowas.
Ist es schon wichtig zu wissen, darf ich nur Overwatch streamen oder darf ich nicht, weißt du?
Und es gab halt auf die ganzen interessanten Fragen mal wieder keine richtige Antwort.
Da kam dann immer so diese Standard-Antwort.
Boah, das ist ja toll, dass ihr diese Frage stellt.
Wir freuen uns, dass ihr so aktiv seid und euch so sehr mit dem Spiel beschäftigt.
Und wir sind gerade in engen Diskussionen mit den Spielern, wie wir das handhaben.
Das ist so eine Antwort, die ganze die ja im Endeffekt auch sparen, weißt du?
Da sagt ihr halt gar nichts.
Und am besten war, wo jemand gefragt hat, ich weiß nicht mehr um was es genau ging.
Es lief aber darauf raus, so nach dem Motto, also irgendein Sonderfall, so nach dem Motto,
wenn jetzt zwei Leute den Paylord gleich weit pushen, blablabla.
Also quasi sowas, wo es eine Regel für geben müsste.
Und dann lief es darauf raus, so nach dem Motto, ja okay, woher weiß man denn,
wie das denn gehandhabt wird in der Overwatch League?
Da meinte der Typ also, ja dafür gibt es das Overwatch Regelbuch.
Und antworten die Leute dann so drauf, ja okay, das ist ja cool, da könnte man ja nachgucken.
Wo ist denn das Overwatch Regelbuch? Wo kann man sich das angucken?
Ja, das liegt hier neben mir. Das bringt es dir halt auch nicht.
Ich meine, es ist schon interessant zu wissen, wie denn die Regeln bei einem Event sind.
Also auch für Zuschauer ist das interessant.
Ich meine, du kannst dir doch in anderen Sportarten auch die Regeln angucken.
Ja, man soll nicht nur einen Held spielen, genau, das ist auch so ein Kritikpunkt,
den ich an der ganzen Sache habe. Auf der einen Seite wird erzählt,
man soll nicht nur einen Held spielen, allerdings, und ich sehe das genauso,
man sollte nicht nur einen Held spielen, weil ich meine, Grandmaster ist quasi Großmeister,
das heißt nicht Mercy-Links-Klicker. Aber auf der anderen Seite wird quasi Switchen nicht belohnt
und vor allem Crewplay nicht gefördert oder Teamplay nicht gefördert.
Null? Du hast so eine komische Dynamic Queue für alle und das war's.
Gibt es ein ordentliches Guilden, Clan, Community-System oder wie immer man das nennen mag
und dementsprechend auch eine Rangliste dafür, wird das um ein Vielfaches mehr motivieren.
Mir geht es gar nicht darum, dass es keine Helden gibt, die man nicht zusammen spielen kann.
Ich meinte, vom Game an sich wird es nicht gefördert, dass Leute sich jetzt zum Beispiel
zu Gruppen zusammenschließen und sagen, wir wollen jetzt zusammenspielen und uns verbessern.
Das Einzige, was es gibt, ist nach dem Spiel dieses Wollt ihr im Team spielen.
Das ist auch das Einzige.
Überlegt euch mal, wie geil das in Overwatch wäre, wenn es in-game gefördert wird,
dass du, wie auch immer man das nennt, Clan-System, Community-System,
es ist eigentlich vollkommen egal, Gruppensystem, wie auch immer,
wenn du deine eigene Community, deinen eigenen Clan aufmachen könntest,
mit festen Leuten und quasi diesen Clan aufleveln.
Aufleveln in Form von, du spielst halt gegen andere 6 Decks.
Das wird das Ranking viel einfacher machen, das wäre auch deutlich motivierender,
weil du halt immer mit den ähnlichen Leuten spielst.
Ich meine, das ist utopisch für ein Amateur-Team, dass man, also ich meine mit Amateur-Team
wirklich Amateure, Leute, die halt auch nicht unbedingt jeden Tag 5 Stunden spielen,
dass du da immer die gleichen 6 Leute hast.
Deswegen wäre es ja gerade gut, wenn es so ein System gibt,
wo du halt sowas wie Communities oder Clans machen kannst.
Und diese Community bzw. diesen Clan, wo du dann sagst, ja, hast du 10 Leute drin,
hast du halt quasi eine Gruppe aus 10 Leuten,
und machst dann halt einen 6 Deck abends draus, oder wenn du halt genug Leute on dal hast
und spielst zusammen und den ratest du halt als Einheit, fertig.
Dann kannst du das raten wie ein One-on-One.
Und das wird so viel mehr motivieren.
Overwatch ist ein Game, das macht eigentlich nur Bock, wenn du es im Team spielst.
Und so richtig Teamplay gibt es einfach in der SoliQ-Rangliste nicht.
Das Höchste der Gefühle ist mal, dass du irgendwie eine Hanzo-Saria-Kombi machst oder sowas.
Also ich finde es am sinnvollsten, wenn es eine richtige SoloQ gebe und eine 6 Deck TeamQ.
Und nicht, wo man sich einfach anmelden kann random mit einem 6 Deck,
sondern halt mit einem Community- oder Clan-System dahinter.
Das wäre richtig geil und das würde mit Sicherheit auch motivieren.
Guck mal, wie geil das wäre.
Ich meine, du musst ja dann nicht dieses Grandmaster-Diamond-Sonstwassystem beibehalten.
Aber wenn du dann quasi dein Clan, GM-Clan ist oder sowas, das wäre mega cool.
Das würde auch motivieren, die Leute zusammen zu spielen und sich zusammen zu verbessern.
Das ist ja das, was in Overwatch Spaß macht.
So, wir reiten mal Richtung Wüste, dass wir gleich Dings nach Naga Cry machen können.
Spiel doch einfach zu 6. Ich sehe da ein Problem.
Hast du mal 6 Deck gespielt? Das lohnt sich null.
Und es ist auch nicht wirklich motivierend, so mit dem System aktuell.
Und das Geile ist halt, man könnte so viel machen.
Wenn du jetzt 6 Decks spielst, hast du erstens Q-Time der absoluten Hölle
und pro Sieg kriegst du dann 2 SR. Yeah.
Deswegen bin ich immer noch für reine Solo-Q und für eine Clan-Q oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Ah, der Stream ruckelt wieder, sehe ich. Yeah, Telekom, nice.
Das macht ihr gut, Telekom.
Ob ich das abfacke, dass es immer laggt?
Wie, das ist nicht Sinn, das Sache.
Ranking spielen, ohne im Ranking aufsteigen zu können, ist nicht Sinn, das Sache.
Nee, dann verstehe ich Ranking wahrscheinlich falsch.
Wenn du zusammenspielst und dich zusammen verbessert, dann solltest du auch zusammen im Rang aufstreigen,
was der Sinn eines Ranking-Systems ist.
Ja genau, das ist das Problem.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass du mit Solo-Leuten gematcht wirst.
Deswegen fände ich eine reine, es ist vor allem, wäre es auch viel einfacher, wenn du quasi eine Team-Q hast,
also mit Team-Q meine ich 6-Stack und wenn du auf der einen Seite deine Solo-Q,
die kann man ja meinetwegen beibehalten, wobei ich es schöner finden würde,
wenn du eine richtige, vollständige Solo-Q hättest.
Und wenn du auf der einen Seite deine Solo-Q hättest, auf der anderen Seite hast du deine Team-Q,
deine 6-Stack-Q, dass das Rating für diese Teams wäre viel, viel einfacher.
Alter Telekom, kriegt ihr euch mal bald ein, das Ruckeln ist doch nicht normal, ey.
Ich sehe es auch, ich habe total viele Frametrops hier beim Upload.
Man sieht ja auch, bei mir ist hier nichts Rendering-Lag, das ist einfach weil der Upload rumspackt.
Das Todes.
Ohne Kacke ey.
So hat es doch die letzten Tage auch nicht rumgeruckelt, oder Leute?
Gefühlt ist es heute ganz extrem.
Richtig.
Oh das kann ich nicht ausspielen.
I'm so uncreative, lul.
Ich finde, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum Blizzart sich nicht einfach an anderen Games orientieren kann.
Ich meine, LoL hat mittlerweile auch eine Rollen-Q drinne, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert, aber man sieht, es funktioniert.
Spiele wie Dota haben auch eine Solo-Q und eine Team-Q.
Also man könnte sich vieles von anderen Spielen abgucken, wo es funktioniert.
Und in MOBA, was 5 gegen 5 ist oder 6 gegen 6, sollte jetzt vom Ranking her eigentlich nicht viel Unterschied sein,
also intern, wie das mathematisch funktioniert als Overwatch.
Und du hast noch einen Vorteil, wenn du Solo-Q machst, hast du natürlich einfacher die Leute zu matchen,
aber worauf ich raus will, wenn du eine Team-Q machst, ist es ziemlich einfach eben die Teams zu raten.
Du musst ja da nicht Spieler 1, Spieler 2, Spieler 3, Spieler 4, Spieler 5, 6 raten.
Du ratest dann Team A und Team B.
Wenn Team B gewinnt, war Team B besser, bekommt Team B und nicht die Spieler, sondern Team B,
also quasi die Gaming-Community oder der Clan, bekommt dann halt Punkt.
Und was man dann noch machen könnte, wo man mal sieht, es gibt halt mega viele Sachen, die man machen könnte.
Und Sachen, die fallen ja nicht nur mir ein, die fallen total vielen Leuten ein.
Ich finde es halt auch schade, dass da Blizzard nichts dazu sagt.
Du könntest dann auch sowas wie automatisch generierte Turniere machen.
Du könntest ohne Probleme dann sagen, okay, nachdem es jetzt ja hier Clans, was auch immer gibt,
könntest du automatisch generierte Turniere am Wochenende machen, wo du sagst, hey,
gibt es doch in StarCraft glaube ich auch mittlerweile, oder was, StarCraft? Ich weiß nicht.
Aber es gibt einige Games, wo das gibt, da hast du automatisch generierte Turniere, musst du dich anmelden
und da könntest du dann sogar Diamond-Turniere machen.
So, jetzt mal die ganzen Scramble-Cellen.
Sag mal Leute, habt ihr wirklich den Eindruck, oder lag es heute mehr als sonst?
Es ruckelt heute mehr als die letzten Tage, ne?
Und ist das überhaupt ein Marketplace? Oh fuck, Moment, gibt es hier überhaupt einen Marketplace?
Hier gibt es keinen, oder?
Der nächste Marketplace ist in Altinova.
Dann lege ich es mal hier in Vault rein, hier sollte es halt schon ein bisschen Platz haben.
Wird später verkauft. Easy Money, easy life.
Der Golden Dagger wird noch verkauft.
Nochmal easy 5 Millionen.
Ich gucke gleich, Chat.
Ja, parieren, zack.
Golden Dagger.
Jetzt haben wir wieder ordentlich Money. Easy Money, easy life haben wir hier.
Okay, sind wir eigentlich ready für Naga Cryant im Kreis.
So, ich muss mal Chat lesen, ich habe ein paar Sachen hier nicht mitbekommen jetzt.
Problem wäre dann, wenn man nicht immer diese gleichen 6 Leute hat.
Naja, es ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein großes Problem ist.
Weil ich meine, du kannst ja, deswegen meine ich ja, du kannst so etwas wie Clan Community machen, wo du halt 10 Leute drinne hast.
Weil es halt als Gelegenheit bzw. Amateur Spieler schwierig ist, immer die gleichen 6 Leute zu kriegen.
Aber selbst wenn es immer die gleichen 6 Leute wären, fände ich auch nicht schlecht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du halt nicht immer mit den gleichen 6 Leuten spielst, wäre ja auch nicht so schlimm.
Es wird dann halt die Gruppe geratet.
Und ja, du könntest natürlich dann einen viel besseren Spieler in den Clan oder in die Gruppe holen, dann würdest du halt steigen damit.
Okay, ich meine, die Gruppe spielt ja dann auch besser.
Das würde dann beispielsweise auch dazu führen, dass man so Sachen wie Triple Tank ordentlich im Rank spielen kann.
Was halt schwierig ist, ohne ordentliches Teamplay und ohne Support, auf die du dich verlassen kannst.
Und Reinhards, die meinen, sie müssen flanken oder was auch immer.
Das geht halt nur, wenn du mit einem gewissen Maß an Teamplay da ran gehst, was es halt so im Rank nicht gibt.
Und ein gewisses Maß an Teamplay kann es in diesem aktuellen Rank auch gar nicht geben.
Weil es ganz entscheidend und wichtig dafür ist, dass man die Spieler kennt, mit denen man spielt.
Dass man weiß, wie sie in speziellen Situationen reagieren und was sie machen.
Das weißt du halt von irgendwie dem Typ, mit dem du noch nie gespielt hast im Rank nicht.
Oder selbst wenn du mit dem öfters spielst, weißt du das nicht.
Nein, die Spieler sind höchstens mit schuld.
Ich bin da mein, diese Sache mit den Spielern ist schuld, es ist genauso wie diese ganze Toxic-Geschichte.
Blizzard ist dafür verantwortlich bzw. es ist egal, ob es jetzt Blizzard ist oder der Hersteller ist dafür verantwortlich,
die Rahmenbedingungen so zu stecken, dass es sich gut entwickeln kann.
Ja, dass die Spieler manchmal ein bisschen über die Stränge schlagen.
Dass die Leute auch mal ordentlich toxik sind, sieht man auch in anderen MMOs, MOBAs, was auch immer.
Aber die Rahmenbedingungen müssen vorhanden sein.
Und wenn die nicht vorhanden sind, wie beispielsweise das Reporting-System in Overwatch,
das teilweise in sich widersprüchlich ist, sind die Rahmenbedingungen einfach nicht da.
Zum Beispiel was ich meine mit das... Leute, ich gebe zu, es hat mit BDO jetzt überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Wenn ihr was zu BDO wissen wollt vom best ausgerüsteten, größten BDO-Noop, könnt ihr gerne fragen.
Ich beantworte es dann auch.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Fuck.
Mit was habe ich jetzt angefangen?
Ja, genau, das Reporting-System.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel totalen Widerspruch im Reporting-System.
Zum Beispiel, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher aus dem Kopf, welche Kategorie das ist.
Ich glaube, entweder ist es Griefing oder Teamplay. Ich glaube, es ist Teamplay.
Bei Teamplay steht drinnen, wenn jemand offensichtlich nicht das Objective spielen möchte,
dann ist das ein Reporting-Grund.
So.
Wenn jemand allerdings einen nicht optimalen Held pickt, ist das kein Reporting-Grund.
Was ich übrigens auch so sehe, eine nicht optimale Held ist selbstverständlich nicht automatisch ein Reporting-Grund.
Also nur weil jetzt jemand gut mit Hanzo ist und Hanzo mal pickt, heißt es nicht, dass man den automatisch bannen muss.
Aber es gibt offensichtliche Picks, die quasi gleichzusetzen sind mit, möchte nicht das Objective spielen.
Zum Beispiel auf Hanamura, Attack, Torbjorn. Das geht einfach nicht.
Das ist faktisch nicht das Objective spielen.
Und solange du quasi schon ein Reporting-System hast, wo quasi absolut unklar ist, was Sache ist,
das meine ich mit die Rahmenbedingungen stimmen einfach nicht.
Bloß das, was ich am Anfang gemeint habe mit Patches, die teilweise Monate dauern,
die keinen Spaß machen, zu spielen, gegen sie zu spielen, mit ihnen zu spielen.
Ja, Black Reaper, das Problem kann es natürlich geben.
Also wenn sich rausstellen sollte, es funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Versuch, das Spiel besser zu machen.
Und ich glaube, in Overwatch und LoL kann man, denke ich, was Teamplay anbelangt, ziemlich gut vergleichen.
Wobei ich halt denke, wenn man das ordentlich umsetzen würde, dürfte eine Team-Q die größte Motivation sein, die es gibt.
Weil ich meine, ich habe ja den Unterschied am eigenen Leib erfahren, wie das ist, in organisiertem Team zu spielen
und in der Solo-Q bzw. in dieser Dynamic-Q.
Es ist einfach ein riesen Unterschied, wie du zusammenspielst.
Und Overwatch, was Overwatch ausmacht, ist gerade ja auch mit das Teamplay.
Overwatch hat zwar viele Helden, die unterschiedlich anspruchsvoll zu spielen sind,
aber bis auf wenige Ausnahmen, also sowas wie Tracer, Genji, Ana und sowas, sind die meisten Helden jetzt relativ simpel zu lernen.
Die meisten, nicht alle.
Also das richtige Skill-Cap, was es nach oben treibt in Overwatch, ist Teamplay.
Teamplay, was in Ranked Solo stattfindet.
Und was extrem motivierend ist, wenn man eben mit festen Leuten spielt und geile Aktionen reißt,
die man alleine nicht reißen konnte, weil man eben sich blind versteht.
Das ist geil, das macht übelst Bock.
Und Blizzard sagt ja auch selbst, Overwatch ist eigentlich ein Spiel,
was man am besten mit Kollegen, was auch immer, mit Freunden, sonst wie zusammen im Team spielt.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, dass gerade sich das nicht widerspiegelt im Spiel.
Heute bei 95%, heute bei 100%, easy rekt.
Übrigens schreit mich mal wieder an, wenn Buff-Food dran ist.
Ich glaube als Nächstes ist wieder Mediamiel dran.
Und ich brauche Black Spirit.
Exp.
Wat? Hab ich keine Energie mehr? Ich hab keine Energie mehr.
Kann mir gar keine Black Spirit Expo'en.
Sag mal Leute, hab ich das Gefühl, ich hab schon dreimal gefragt,
wahrscheinlich habt ihr auch schon drauf geantwortet, ich hab's bloß nicht gesehen.
Das ist heute mehr ruckelt im Stream und mehr leckt als sonst.
Also das würde ja dafür sprechen, dass die Telekom halt wieder irgendwie komische Dinger macht.
Ich muss gleich nochmal meine BDO-Stats gucken.
Na jetzt, jetzt hab ich seit ein paar Minuten dürfte es nicht mehr ruckeln, oder?
Jetzt hab ich nämlich keine Dropped Frames mehr und Upload alles grün.
Aber es müsste jetzt eigentlich seit ein paar Minuten nicht mehr geruckelt haben.
Gestern hat's gefühlt gar nicht geruckelt.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist total tagesabhängig.
Ja, Akkimo Processor.
Und ich behaupte mal jeder, der auch ein bisschen nur versucht hat Overwatch ernsthaft zu spielen.
Und mit ernsthaft meine ich jetzt gar nicht, dass man versucht irgendwelche Cups, Turniere, sonst was zu gewinnen,
sondern einfach mal versucht, quasi mit definierten Rollen im Team, mit den gleichen Leuten,
sich einzuspielen und mal ein paar Sachen zu probieren.
Oder mal auszuprobieren, die halt nur klappen, wenn man im Team spielt.
Es kann auch sowas Simples sein wie einen Boost mit der Maywall oder sowas.
Dann sieht man, was es für ein geiles Gefühl ist, wenn man zum Beispiel, was in meiner Zeit lang voll im Trend war,
sich mit der May Icewall bei Eichenwalde über den ersten Chalkpoint rüberliftet.
Das ist einfach nice.
Hast du noch ultra high quality auf BDO aktiviert?
Der Sebaro.
Der Sebaro, ja, da hat er Recht.
Klar, das habe ich doch gestern angemacht.
So.
Ist er müde, durch das Spiel zu gucken?
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Der Naga-Kreisel-Krind ist wahrscheinlich nicht so das Spannendste für Leute zuzugucken, die nicht BDO spielen.
Aber das Schöne am Kampfsystem von BDO ist, das macht Spaß.
Ich hätte das ja am Anfang auch nicht für möglich gehalten.
Schalte die Energie... Moment, es gibt eine Energiesparfunktion in dem Spiel?
Moment.
Unten sagst du.
Wo genau?
Wo ist das? Wo ist die Energiesparfunktion?
Ist das das neue Code? Ja, Fantasy Warfare.
Ich bin zu blöd, ich finde das nicht.
Graphic Card Low Power Mode oder so heißt.
Äh.
Graphic Card Low Power... Wurscht.
Dieses Optionsmenü ist so geil in dem Game. Siehst nix.
So, hier ist es schon mal nicht.
Optima... Optimization.
Hier.
Okay.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, das lag wahrscheinlich nicht am Game oder so, ne?
Das es geruckelt hat.
Es war Telekom Upload.
Ich mein, wir haben Overwatch mit den gleichen Settings gestreamt und 300 FPS.
Da war am Anschlag der Rechner und es hat nicht geruckelt.
Code Fantasy Warfare.
Wo wir da gerade dabei sind, das wäre wirklich ein Szenario, was ich mir gut vorstellen könnte, ne?
Das wäre einfach mal was Neues.
Das müsste kein Call of Duty sein.
Hat jemand damals, wann waren das? 2006 rum?
Wie hieß es? Dark Messiah of Might and Magic gespielt in Multiplayer?
Das war quasi ein klassenbasierter Fantasy Shooter.
So wie Zauberer, Bogenschützer, Nahkämpfer.
Ich glaub sogar Stelzer.
Das hat übertrieben Bock gemacht, das Game, der Multiplayer.
Bis dann der Hersteller nach ein paar Monaten gesagt hat, oh Mist, der Multiplayer ist ja voll erfolgreich.
Ne, den wollen wir jetzt nicht weiter supporten, das kostet uns zu viel Arbeit, wir patchen ihn raus.
Oder machen die Server aus oder sowas, richtig dahingeblieben.
Max, bist du eigentlich in deiner Firma Ausbilder für den Physi oder bildet ein Kollege von dir aus?
Also ich hab kein Ausbilderzettel.
Aber die meiste Zeit oder so großzweiter Zeit sind die Azubis bei mir.
Der letzte jetzt nicht, aber davor die meisten schon.
Und das könnte ich mir wirklich als geiles Szenario, aber ein bisschen frischeres Szenario für einen Shooter vorstellen,
wenn das in irgendeinem Fantasy Setting wäre. Oder was ich noch cooler fänden würde,
wenn man schon ein bestehendes Fantasy Setting nimmt.
Es muss ja nicht immer Herr der Ringe sein.
Aber das erste, was mir ein bisschen düsterer einfallen würde, wäre sowas wie Warhammer.
Es muss ja nichts Neues sein und es muss auch nicht immer Herr der Ringe sein.
Und wenn man noch weniger Fantasy Elemente haben will,
dann holt man sich für 50 Billiarden die Game of Thrones Lizenz für Games und macht einen Shooter draus, easy.
Ey man irgendwo muss Activation und EA noch mit der Kohle hin.
Da soll man einen Game of Thrones Shooter machen.
Aber wir sind hier so voll. Piss dich Alde.
Ist das Setting wirklich so relevant?
Teilweise, weil du kannst manche Sachen einfach sinnvoller machen in einem Fantasy Setting,
anstatt in einem Real Life Setting.
Ich mein Bogenschütze in einem Fantasy Setting ist schon ein bisschen einfacher zu machen als so ein krasser Bogenstelzer.
Oder ein Zauberer ist in einem Fantasy Setting einfacher zu machen als in irgendeinem Real Life Setting.
Doch ich habe Game of Thrones gekuckt, allerdings nur bis Season 3.
Und danach habe ich mir nur die Zusammenfassung nach jeder Season auf YouTube angeguckt.
Und ich habe es nur bis Season 3 geguckt, weil, und das ist für viele der Grund warum ich die Game of Thrones geil finden,
weil mir irgendwann einfach zu viel gelaber und zu wenig passiert ist.
In Game of Thrones wird immer so unglaublich viel gelabert.
Vielleicht ist es ja in Originalsprache besser, aber ich habe es auf Deutsch geguckt.
Es wird so viel gelabert und das meistert am Ende überhaupt keine Auswirkungen auf irgendwas.
Und es passiert nichts, gefühlt eine Folge lang passiert dann was.
Warum sind hier so viele Leute?
Die erste Staffel fand ich cool, das war aber was neues. Die zweite Staffel fand ich auch noch nice.
Aber irgendwie ist mir dann einfach zu wenig passiert.
Und danach, ich habe mir jetzt immer die Zusammenfassung angeguckt von Game of Thrones,
es hat sich die letzten paar Staffeln schon gebessert, quasi als die auch mehr Budget hatten dann.
Ich muss mal den Channel wechseln.
Hier ist zu viel los, kurz bevor die Nacht anfängt. Hier ist nicht so crowded, da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Die letzte Staffel lohnt auf jeden Fall, ja ich gucke mir immer Highlight Videos an.
Die letzte Staffel hat ein paar coole Sachen gehabt.
Moment, da ist ja schon der nächste Typ da am Start.
So wir machen jetzt unseren Daily Exp an.
Daily Exp auf, Moment da oben.
So jetzt werden wir erstmal hier alle Nagas massakrieren.
Läufst du immer nur im Kreis und tötest die gleichen Gegner, fast, fast.
Der Kreis sieht manchmal ein bisschen anders aus, aber im Prinzip ist das so.
Der Grind ist halt real.
Vorhin war ich schon an einem anderen Spot, gestern war ich mit dem Fabian zusammen auch noch weiter in der Wüste.
Aber ich finde so XP mäßig und vor allem wie leicht man die Mops bashen kann, ist das hier ein echt guter Spot.
Wie viele Leute da hinten sind, da muss ich jetzt woanders hin.
Oh da ist ein Boss, da will ich nicht hin.
Klingt spannend.
Es ist spannender als es aussieht.
Wobei mir Grinding ja auch nicht, also mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so viel ausmacht.
Vor allem mit dem Kampfsystem von BDO macht es mir echt Spaß.
Lohnt sich nochmal anzufangen.
Nachdem du das Game ja schon gespielt hast, weißt du ja ungefähr wie es ist.
Da hat sich jetzt nicht allzu viel dran geändert.
Es ist jetzt viel einfacher zu leveln, bis zu 60.
Und du kriegst halt auch mit den Daily Rewards und so viele Sachen, ist früher schwieriger waren dran zu kommen.
Also die legen schon Wert darauf, dass neue Leute oder Wiedereinsteiger aufschließen können.
Als Wiedereinsteiger darfst du auch auf Channels drauf wo es mehr XP gibt, dass du noch schneller leveln kannst.
Und nachdem du es schon gekauft hast, denke ich schadet es sich nicht das Game nochmal anzugucken.
Ich glaube ich hab mich verlaufen. Moment wo bin ich dann?
Nee, passt.
Sebaroi das geht ja, aber die Gegner hier sind zu schnell tot.
Und die stehen auch schon ganz gut auf dem Haufen.
Noccy hab ich noch nie gespielt.
Wenn das das ist was du mir geschickt hast, dann ist es doch der Chef der einfach nur blödes Zeugs erzählt.
Dass die Kekse nicht echt sind und sonst was.
Oder kommt da noch mehr?
Ich warte bei neuen Overwatcher bis es ein Intro Video gibt.
Wo man dann auch sich ungefähr vorstellen kann was der Held macht.
Ich suche gerade nach einem 54er Crying Spot.
Kennst du dich da aus? Also auskennen ist zu viel gesagt.
Aber ich kann dir sagen wo wir gelevelt haben.
Und das sah ganz gut aus.
Einmal weiß ich nicht ob man mit 54 hier schon hin kann oder wahrscheinlich noch nicht.
Entweder da oder da oder da.
Oder wenn das gar nicht geht dann kannst du zum Catfish Spot gehen.
Wo ist der Catfish Spot? Da haben wir nämlich gelevelt damals zusammen.
Das weiß ich noch. Weiß nicht wo der Catfish Spot ist.
Hier, da. Der ist auch gut.
Gibt dick Exp und Geld.
Die ist ja schon wieder so voll. Meine Fresse.
Ich hab meinen Exp-Buff gezündet. Ich kann jetzt hier nicht so lange rumfackeln.
Meinst du Catfish ausreichend für 54? Ganz ehrlich ich kenne keinen anderen Spot.
Ich weiß mein Gear sieht relativ gut aus aber ich bin auch loop in dem Game.
Aber Leveln geht schnell also bis 56 kriegst du easy hin.
Wir gehen jetzt anders. Wir machen das jetzt vorbei.
Wo laufe ich hin? WTF? Wir machen jetzt die Runde da hinten.
Wir gehen jetzt hier vorbei und dann nach hinten wieder.
Guck mal ob da irgendwo frei ist wo man kreiseln kann.
Ap ist bei 112. Da müsstest du das 1 ganz gut packen schon.
Ach nee, nee sorry falscher Name. Vergiss es.
Was ist das da?
Kannst du mal das Karteninterface erklären warum es diese Striche zwischen den Spots gibt?
Du meinst diese weißen Bögen oder?
Das ist dass du
Ich weiß nicht ob ich ein Note habe wo ich dir das zeigen kann.
Aber du kannst ja Notes aufleveln. Mit Energie kannst du ja spezielle Notes verbessern.
Und du musst dafür alle Notes auf dem Weg haben.
Also du musst quasi auf alle Notes auf dem Weg Punkte investieren.
Und dass du halt siehst wie der Weg ist. Wie du diesen Note erreichen kannst. Dafür sind die Striche da.
Also dass du jetzt hier irgendwas investieren kannst. Guck hier sieht man es. Musst du erstmal den investieren. Du musst hier was investieren.
Du siehst welchen Weg du quasi ausbauen musst um zum jeweiligen Note zu kommen sind die Striche da.
Versuch das gleich nochmal.
So hier habe ich quasi schon Contribution Points rein gehauen.
Und da sieht man ja das ist quasi von hier ist jetzt Gold geworden. Jetzt dürfte ich quasi da auch Punkte reinstecken.
Ich dürfte hier keine Punkte reinstecken ohne da nicht Punkte reingesteckt zu haben.
Du investierst in Notes um dort Arbeiter zu platzieren und für dich Sachen abbauen zu lassen.
Oh fuck. Das ist ein Boss da will ich jetzt nicht hin. Warum ist hier so voll. Die sollen sich mal alle. Die sollen sich verpissen.
Du kannst an Notes kannst du Arbeiter für dich Material abbauen lassen.
Wie voll es hier ist ich hätte doch den Server nochmal wechseln sollen.
Sag mal the fuck.
Warum ist es hier so voll. Hallo Yoshi.
Aufwisser luftig.
Ich hoffe hier ist jetzt ein bisschen weniger los hoffentlich.
Moment ganz weiter hinten ging es weiter.
Hatte die Erklärung was gebracht auf der Map jetzt.
Also ich muss sagen mit diesem Workout Note System bis auf die paar Punkte die wir da ausgebaut haben bei mir kenne ich mich auch nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Es gibt halt wohl ein paar Nodes die sich richtig lohnen weil da Material abgebaut wird was es sonst nirgendswo gibt.
Aber es gibt zum Beispiel richtig gute Spots.
Oder wichtig Nodes weil dort unten dieses Trace Trace auf Dingsbums Zeugs abgebaut wird.
Das muss wohl alles der besten Note sein die man so haben kann.
Willst du dich zu Silvester nicht zu kippen ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Aber eher nicht.
Eher nicht und wenn nicht dann mache ich Silvester streben.
Scheiß auf real life.
Das hat jetzt auch der Fabian sagen können oder.
WPD welches Bier trinkst du am liebsten ich trinke eigentlich gar nicht gerne Bier.
Also ordentlich.
Hier ist zu wenig Schloss an Mops.
Das mit easy mit easy 90 in der Nacht war wohl ein bisschen sehr optimistisch geschätzt.
Zu wenig Mops da.
Da ist schon wieder die nächsten Leute am Start.
Ich wechsle jetzt noch mal den Channel.
Wie ist es eigentlich dazu gekommen dass du wieder BDO spielst weil ich mit Fabian wieder MMO spielen will.
Spielst du eigentlich noch mit der Zowie Maus ja mit der Zowie EC2A.
Beste Maus die ich je hatte was mir an der gut gefällt ist dass es einfach simpel ist.
Ich hatte ja vorher Logitech G502 das war auch an sich also von den Features her steckt die Zowie Maus locker in die Tasche.
Also Feature mäßig war die war die G502 das beste was ich je hatte aber die war mir einfach zu schwer.
Das was ich bei der Zowie gut finde die kann nichts im Endeffekt.
Die hat zwei Tasten neben dran ein Mausrad und links und rechts Maustaste fertig mehr hat die nicht.
Die kann nichts.
Aber was sie kann kann sie gut und sie ist leicht und liegt gut in der Hand.
Sie baro kann ich machen ja.
Hier ist ein bisschen mehr als an Mops da.
Übrigens ruckte das Game gerade das liegt nicht an Telekom.
Sieckte ein Video.
Yoshi ich trinke auch kaum was.
Also wirklich wenig.
Eigentlich nichts und wenn es was Alkoholisches sein muss dann am liebsten Whisky.
Und davon trinkt man ja auch nicht viel.
Also davon trinkt man vor allem wenn es halt was Gescheites ist das kostet halt auch ein paar Euro.
Dann haut man sich davon jetzt ja auch nicht die halbe Flasche rein und ein kleines bisschen.
Das.
Hier sind schon viele Mops.
Wie viel hast du eigentlich für die CPU bezahlt.
Hab keine Übersicht was der eigentlich normalerweise kostet ohne den ganzen Aufpreis wegen Verfügbarkeit.
Mittlerweile ist er verfügbar.
Der 8700K mittlerweile kriegsten.
Ich habe ein bisschen mehr bezahlt als 399 bisschen mehr.
Also mit Versand irgendwie 420 oder so.
Ich habe aber halt ich habe drei Shops preordert.
Und hatte Glück dass ich einen der ersten gekriegt habe.
Ich habe sie jetzt ja schon zwei Monate oder so in dem Dreh ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Müssen wir mal gucken was ich das Video hochgeladen habe.
Okay also die 880 packen wir.
Ups nicht hängen bleiben Wuppler.
Mein hast du schon von dem neuen.
Im O-Projekt gehört das sieht voll nice aus.
Was von wem.
Project TL.
Was ist Project TL.
Wann kriegst du uns ab.
Ich habe mich nicht darum gekümmert bis jetzt.
Noch gar nicht darum gekümmert.
Das sollte glaube ich immer als neues Lineage werden.
Das ist ja wenn einer schon schlecht schon schlimm findet.
Dann ist das für ihn aber gar nichts.
Aber ich bin mal neuen MMOs immer ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Da gab es doch ich weiß nicht mehr welches das war.
Aber irgendeiner irgendein MMO was 2018 rauskommt.
Hat ja auch vor ein paar Monaten so einen Trailer gemacht.
Der ein bisschen für Aufruhr gesorgt hat.
Wo sie erzählt haben so dynamisches Event System.
Und bestes hier bestes da und bla bla bla bla.
Eigentlich will ich mal abwarten.
Mal abwarten Jungs wenn das Game rauskommt.
Was da noch von der ganzen Sache übrig ist.
Was ihr euch da so ausgemalt habt.
Übrigens habe ich euch schon das neueste erzählt.
Ich habe gestern Anruf gekriegt von dem Typ.
Der mein Klo eingebaut hat.
So jetzt kommts jetzt kommts jetzt kommts.
Mein Klo kann unter seltenen Umständen anfangen zu brennen.
Hat er mir erzählt.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Der Klo kann quasi die Wohnung abfackeln.
In welchem Jahrtausend leben wir denn bitteschön.
Dass man Angst haben muss dass sein Klo die Wohnung abbrennt.
Ja.
Echt der Wahnsinn oder.
Also der Klo brennt nicht die Wohnung ab.
Sondern die Düsen was.
Die Düsen Spül.
Düsen Reinigungsflüssigkeit.
Ist anscheinend leicht entflammbar.
Und kann dazu führen.
Dass das Klo anfängt zu brennen.
Geil oder.
Was kannst du dagegen machen.
Es gibt eine Anleitung vom Hersteller.
Da sagt man soll die Flüssigkeit entfernen.
Und drauf scheißen wenn das Klo eine Warnung ausgibt.
Dass Flüssigkeit fehlt.
Und es wäre alles gut auch ohne Flüssigkeit.
Sobald sie eine neue.
Nicht so leicht entflammbare Flüssigkeit haben.
Kriegt man die als kostenloses Upgrade.
Das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen.
Jetzt muss man nicht nur Angst davor haben.
Dass sein Smartphone einem das Bein abfackelt.
Oder das Bein ankokelt in der Hose.
Mit dem Akku.
Sondern dass sein Klo anfängt zu brennen.
Das ist schon hart.
Das ist echt hart.
Und der Hersteller meinte noch.
Man sollte am besten jedes mal den Klo ausschalten.
Das sehe ich aber nicht ein.
Aber das steht auch nur als Empfehlung da.
Also es reicht wohl wenn man die Flüssigkeit raus macht.
Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Mein Klo quasi ein und aus zu schalten.
Jedes mal bevor ich drauf gehe.
Weil ich meine dafür habe ich ja so ein Klo.
Dass ich die Funktionen benutzen kann.
Und nicht dass ich jedes mal einschalten muss.
Und dann warten muss bis es gebootet ist oder sowas.
Also ehrlich.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das sind, das sind wahre First World Problems Leute.
Es wird ja immer so auf Spaß unter alles geschrieben.
So nach dem Motto.
Von dem man denkt es ist nicht wichtig.
First World Problems.
Aber Leute.
Das sind die wahren.
Der Inbegriff von First World Problems.
Was ich euch gerade erzählt habe.
Und wer hier jetzt neu ist und sich fragt.
Was labert der eigentlich für ein Scheiß.
Ihr könnt euch ja bei YouTube mein Klo Review Video angucken.
Da sieht man das im Detail was das für ein Klo ist.
Beste Investitioner.
Geno QZ.
Du kannst auf YouTube kannst du mal ein Klo Review gucken.
Oder wollen wir uns das nach der Nacht on Stream nochmal angucken zusammen.
Oh es ist nach der Nacht on Stream zusammen angucken.
Mittlerweile kann ich auch ein bisschen mehr dazu sagen.
Weil ich hab eh nur die Hälfte.
Die Hälfte gezeigt im Video.
Weil ich damals gar nicht wusste.
Dass es den noch mehr Knöpfe hat.
Immer doch.
Okay sobald die Nacht vorbei ist.
Im Video gucken wir uns.
Gucken wir uns mein Klo Video an zusammen.
Dann reakte ich quasi zu meinen eigenen Videos.
Das ist ja auch voll im Trend zurzeit.
Max reacted.
Zu seinen eigenen Videos zu seinen eigenen alten Videos reacten.
Das ist zurzeit voll angesagt auf YouTube.
Machen wir jetzt auch mal.
Quasi Winning Team Joiner.
Ich war letztens mal bei Onge auf dem Channel wieder.
Hab festgestellt jedes zweite Video reakte der nur noch auf irgendwas.
Scheint echt angesagt zu sein zurzeit zu reacten.
Noch mehr als sonst.
Aber das ausgereicht er das da macht verstehe ich nicht.
Weil ich verbinde react Videos ja in der Regel so ziemlich mit so low effort Content irgendwo.
Und er hat ja früher Sachen gemacht wo man richtig gesehen hat.
Dass er viel Zeit und Mühe reingesteckt hat.
Jetzt reactet er.
Aber ich mein warum nicht wenn es den Leuten gefällt.
Auf YouTube geht anscheinend react auch einfacher.
Aber YouTube Deutschland.
Es ist eh quasi alles alles verloren.
Es gibt einen Trend den ich richtig gut finde auf YouTube als ernst gemeint.
Und zwar ist das im englischsprachigen Raum in Deutschland teilweise auch mittlerweile.
Ist es dass sich so Science Channels durchsetzen also welche die auch wirklich auch ordentlichen Content produzieren.
Sei es jetzt ich guck das halt ganz gerne so sei es irgendwie mit mit Physik beschäftigen Mathe beschäftigen.
Oder irgendwie das Universum schwarze Löcher sonst was in der Richtung.
Und wo auch Leute dabei sind die Ahnung haben wovon sie reden.
Die es nicht einfach nur so Basswörtermäßig machen und dann irgendwie Sachen erzählen von Wikipedia wie manche Fakten Channels.
Ja das ist auch so ein großer Schwachsinn.
Ich suche mir irgendwo eine Seite wo was steht und liest das dann vor sondern auch wirklich ordentlicher Content.
Und das hat relativ viele Views zurecht.
Also finde ich so ein kleiner Trend auf YouTube dass sich auch mal ganz gutes etabliert.
Oh, mein Info ist voll. Es geht nicht es ist Nacht mein Info darf jetzt nicht voll sein.
Okay wir schmeißen mal ein bisschen was weg nicht viel irgendwie 400 oder so bis zum Ende der Nacht reicht.
Reicht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber ich gucke schon seit es YouTube gibt gucke ich gerne irgendwelche Science Channels vor allem wo es um irgendwelche Weltraumstellens geht.
Das finde ich echt interessant was da mittlerweile alles gibt.
Und es ist halt geil was man mittlerweile alles feststellen kann wenn auch teilweise nur indirekt.
Ich muss sich mal vorstellen man kann mittlerweile Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen aus was sich quasi die Atmosphäre anderer Planeten zusammensetzt.
Die weiß ich wie viele Lichtjahre weg sind.
Das ist schon voll abgedreht oder es geht es geht zurzeit nur für Planeten mit einer gewissen Größe also irgendwie so Jupiter mäßig.
Aber muss ich das mal vorstellen da ist irgendwo am Arsch der Welt im Universum Kreis da ein Planet um irgendeine Sonne oder um irgendeinen Stern.
Und wenn er da vorbei fliegt können wir das analysieren und darauf Rückschlüsse ziehen aus was das besteht.
Das ist das ist so abgedreht dass das funktioniert.
Es ist gelackt.
Ich habe ein pure forest breath was ist das ist es selten was.
Irgendwas fürs Forst.
Denkst du es gibt Aliens.
Fangen da jetzt am besten an.
Also es ist die Frage was man als Aliens sieht.
Also sprich was auf unserem Niveau oder weiter technologisch oder ob schon reicht wenn irgendwo ein bisschen was rum klippert.
Also wenn man sich überlegt wie viel wie viel Planeten wir in den letzten Jahren oder wie viel Planeten in den letzten Jahren entdeckt wurden.
Wie viele Planeten in den letzten Jahren entdeckt wurden.
Die wahrscheinlich ich meine die sind ja immer ein bisschen weiter weg.
Da gewesen ist noch keiner die wahrscheinlich nicht so nah und nicht so weit von ihrem jeweiligen Stern weg sind.
Also wo es potenziell flüssiges Wasser geben könnte.
Und in Anbetracht der Tatsache wie groß allein schon das Universum ist was wir sehen können.
Die Frage ist ja auch wie geht es danach weiter wahrscheinlich einfach genauso noch mehr noch mehr Universum halt bloß von uns nicht zu sehen.
Wobei sich dann natürlich die Frage stellt.
Wenn wir jetzt ja sagen okay wir haben schon so und so viele Planeten gefunden die theoretisch leben haben könnten.
Also sprich es könnte eventuell flüssiges Wasser geben es ist nicht zu warm ist nicht zu kalt.
Das ist eine große Preisfrage wo es dann auch fast schon ein bisschen philosophisch wird und wo keiner so richtig aktuelle Antwort drauf hat.
So was wollte ich jetzt mal ich wollte Zeug verkaufen.
Das Universum.
Das Universum breitet sich schneller wie Licht aus keine Ahnung.
Also am Anfang muss es sich ja definitiv schneller wie Licht ausgebreitet haben.
Was ja auch in Ordnung ist.
Weil sich Lichtgeschwindigkeit quasi nur auf das Licht im Raum bezieht.
Und nicht auf die Ausdehnung des Raums quasi selbst.
Aber wie das aktuell ist keine Ahnung.
Welches Note-Level Mob-Level hat Knowledge hast du bei Nagas?
Also Note-Level habe ich nichts gelevelt ich habe auch keine Energie gerade und Knowledge muss ich mal nachgucken.
Also ich habe es zumindest nicht irgendwie auf S oder so einfach random was es so gegeben hat.
Habe ich eigentlich wieder genug Energie um Black Spirit Axe zu kaufen?
Nope.
Kryptoker den kannst du verkaufen.
Du kannst mit dem goldenen Deck ja eh das ist Sell-Item.
Aber die 5 Millionen würde ich natürlich nicht im Inventar behalten.
Ne nicht in einem Tag in zwei Tagen.
4 Seraphs übelst Glock gehabt.
Also soweit ich in einem YouTube-Video gelernt habe Patrick.
Wo wir dabei sind dass ich den Trend gut finde dass sich solche Channels ganz gut entwickeln.
Widersprich es sich nicht dass das Universum sich schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit ausdehnen könnte.
Es kann sich nur innerhalb des Universums nicht schneller als Licht bewegen.
Weil es also heißen würde du könntest nie von der einen Seite zur anderen Seite fliegen.
Du würdest nämlich nie ankommen.
Wenn es sich schneller ausbreiten würde.
Nein hier wollen wir nicht runter.
Aber wirklich Fragen dazu beantworten kann ich nicht.
Weil ich habe davon außer YouTube Videos gucken auch keinen Plan.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das nicht noch zur Zeit im Raum der Spekulation liegt.
Man vermute das ja.
Also wir können es definitiv nicht.
Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist überall gleich.
Nein das ist Schwachsinn.
Im jeweiligen Medium was du betrachtest ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer gleich.
Also wenn du dir Licht im Wasser anguckst ist das immer gleich schnell.
Und wenn du dir Licht anguckst ist das im Vakuum immer gleich schnell.
Und es ist egal ob das ein Hightech Laser ist oder die Aldi Taschen Lampe.
Da fliegen halt irgendwelche Photonen rum.
Und die fliegen halt mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist nur davon abhängig in Wasser.
Also in Wasser ist es langsamer als in der Luft.
Deswegen ist Glasfaser nicht so schnell wie wenn du es in der Luft übertragen würdest.
Aber wir kriegen in Deutschland eh nicht flächendeckend Glasfaser deswegen ist es egal.
Irgendjemand hat gefragt was ich in Außerirdischen fragen würde wenn ich ihn treffe.
Also ich denke je nachdem wer das fragt gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche Ansätze.
Aber eine Sache die mich wirklich interessieren würde bei einer Außerirdischen Zivilisation.
Die müssen es ja weit gebracht haben. Ich meine die haben es immerhin geschafft irgendwie von ihrem Planet weg zu kommen.
Und sind so weit rum gekommen dass sie es geschafft haben mich zu treffen wo auch immer das dann stattfindet.
Mich würde eigentlich interessieren wie sie es geschafft haben also wie es ihre Zivilisation geschafft hat so an einem Strand zu ziehen um das zu bewerkstelligen.
Das würde mich interessieren.
Weil das sehe ich ja bei uns auch so als eines der größten Probleme.
Wir können in der Regel nur an einem Strang ziehen wenn uns jemand so sinnbildlich gesprochen das Messer an den Hals hält.
Ansonsten machen wir uns lieber gegenseitig Blatt.
Also mal angenommen es kommt jetzt irgendwie die Meldung hier wir müssen alle sterben weil Asteroid einschlägt in zwei Jahren.
Da könntet ihr mal sehen wie sehr es die Menschheit schafft würde an einem Strang zu ziehen.
Das würden wir hinkriegen weil wenn wir es nicht hinkriegen sind wir alle am Arsch.
Und am Arsch zu sein setzt unglaubliche Motivationsschübe frei.
Aber sobald wir es geschafft hätten diese Gefahr abzuwenden würden wir uns wieder die Köpfe gegenseitig einschlagen.
Deswegen würde ich mich bei wenn ich irgendwie den Alien was fragen könnte würde ich mich fragen wie die es geschafft haben dass sie alle an einem Strang ziehen und sich nicht gegenseitig Blatt machen.
Ich meine man könnte das ganze noch viel weiter spinnen das ist ja schon halber Philosophierungs Stream.
Man könnte ja quasi sagen wenn alle wenn die gesamte Menschheit an einem Strang ziehen würde dann bräuchtest du ja auch kein oder ich fange mal anders an.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt was die Ausgaben sind die man hat ist ist Security Militär und sonst war es in der Richtung ja immer relativ hoch.
Wenn man es quasi schaffen würde an einem Strang zu ziehen könnte man das ja weiter spinnen und sagen hey dann bräuchte man ja auch gar kein Militär mehr.
Weil du müsstest dich nicht verteidigen oder sonst was.
Du könntest das Geld dann quasi für bessere Sachen investieren.
Leider ist die Welt halt nicht so und nachdem es immer noch genug gestörte gibt brauchst du halt doch wieder welche die aufpassen dass wenn was passiert dass du halt noch dem was entgegen zu setzen hast.
Weil Corion ja genau also wenn wir den plus Willis schicken dann wollen sie mit uns wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun haben.
Ich finde wir sollten ihn Marcel Skorpion schicken oder oder sowas.
So ein bisschen weißt du so kultureller Austausch der Jugend zwischen den Aliens und uns.
Und ich war jetzt gar nicht mal irgendwie schlecht oder so.
Also ich habe gegen Marcel nix.
Ich kenne ja auch nicht wirklich.
Von den ganzen Typen auf YouTube die so da bei jüngeren Leuten angesagt sind glaube ich wäre der wirklich noch einer der besseren dafür.
Um ihn zu den Alien Jugendlichen zu schicken zum kulturellen Austausch.
Wir sollten davon absehen Herr Tutorial oder oder Bibi oder so dahin zu schicken dann schicken wir lieber Marcel hin.
Oder wie heißt die eine die Merkel Interview tat die dann irgendwie gemeint hat Ja das war jetzt mein erstes Interview.
Obwohl er die Merkel so gesagt hat Ja und was machen sie sonst so Selbstdarstellung oder wie.
Wer war das ich kannte die gar nicht mehr mehr ist das gewesen.
Wenn ich nicht lief Leute.
Irgend ein YouTube Grill.
Wenn ihr Leute kenn ich da war ich wieder wer das ist.
Eine Frau ich weiß auch nicht wer.
Fast 90 Jahre direkt.
Gleich kann ich wieder Black Spirit X kaufen.
Wer ist da ist okay Nein sagt mir gar nichts.
Wenn du reist du reist natürlich nicht schneller als wenn es so was wie ein Wurmloch gibt reist du natürlich durch den Wurm bist du nicht schneller als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs.
Du legst da die Strecke auch gar nicht zurück.
Du bist dann einfach woanders.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn bei einem der Witz hinter einem Wurmloch.
Du bist dann woanders ohne dass du quasi die normale Strecke von hier nach da gelaufen bist.
Du bist auch nicht schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs.
Die hat 1,1 Millionen Abos okay keine Ahnung wie gesagt ich kenne mich auf YouTube Deutschland sehr rudimentär noch aus.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn bei einem der Witz hinter einem Wurmloch.
Das ist doch mal hier heute ein Stream.
So philosophische Sachen und dann auch noch das Universum Wurmlöcher und Planeten Alter.
Wo selber hier wirklich oft Fitsch oder was.
Ne du bewegst dich auch nicht dreidimensional schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Du bist einfach hier dann gehst du durchs Wurmloch durch dann bist du woanders.
So und bis wir dich dann sehen können dauert es halt bis das Licht von dir weil du bist jetzt woanders wieder bei uns ist.
Und je nachdem wie weit du weg bist dann kann das auch noch weiter dauern.
Ich habe letztens bei Spacetime war das glaube ich ein Video über Wurmlöcher geguckt.
Du bist nicht schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs.
Weil du legst ja gar nicht so viel so viel Weg zurück im Endeffekt.
Aber ob es das alles so gibt und ob wir jemals da irgendwie in dieser Richtung was finden werden oder gar selbst irgendwie sowas das.
Mal nicht.
Es gab ein Experiment wo wir gerade mal schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit sind.
Es gab ein Experiment das war glaube ich in Italien.
Oder ich glaube es wurde irgendwie von der Schweiz nach Italien über die Alten oder so irgendwelche Sachen geschickt.
Und die sind dort wenn sie alles auf die Uhr geschaut haben schneller angekommen als sie dürften wenn sie sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen.
Im Nachhinein hat sich aber rausgestellt die Uhren gingen falsch.
Vielleicht soll ich mich mal entmuten.
Die Uhren gingen nicht falsch in der Schweiz die Uhren in Italien gingen falsch.
Ich ziemlich sicher war das in Italien wo sie das empfangen haben.
Kann ich noch dran erinnern dass da irgendwas in Italien war.
Da haben sie sich falsch gemessen.
Das war zwischen Ciano und Italien genau und die Uhren in Italien waren falsch.
Also wenn ich heute 60 dann morgen easy 60.
Was 93 du hast glaube ich verkocht 90 ziemlich genau 90.
Nein.
5.000 voller habe ich voll ja stimmt seit gestern
geht ab moin sire sire 2000
was macht eine komische streichs an meinen mobs hier
was macht er an meinen mobs so geht es nicht
hier oder wir leben wirklich in der matrix kann er alles sein und irgendwann kommt
aus erwählte und best alles
easy da dann quasi hex an iel
warum sprintest du nicht zu faul mit schiff zu drücken
also sani san du kannst nach aktuellem kenntnisstand nichts schneller was
heißt aktuell im kenntnisstand ja du kannst aktuell im kenntnisstand nichts
schneller beschleunigen als lichtgeschwindigkeit und selbst die
wirst du nicht erreichen sondern vielleicht nur 99. ganz viel 999 sollte
es möglich sein ist nicht so dass es nicht nach aktuellem stand nicht möglich
ist es würde unsere aktuellen verständnis
vollkommen widersprechen
das heißt das ist im prinzip einfach eine spekulation und fantasy ja wenn man
sich das überlegt was wäre wenn in dem fall
also du könntest theoretisch in die zukunft reisen wenn du schnell genug
unterwegs wärst allerdings kommt man immer zurück ob sie das dann bringt ist
wieder was anderes jetzt alles weg sollten so abhauen
okay machen wir jetzt anders wir gehen jetzt wieder dahinten an an die eine
dune und basteln alle die mobs
stellen wir vor du reist in die zukunft es gibt keine menschen mehr ja wäre
schon scheiße und du kommst nie wieder zurück
eine zeit für dich ist es kein unterschied deswegen ist ja auch so dass
man so reise in die zukunft ist ja ist ja dann blöder blöder ausdruck dafür
eigentlich machen die schwuppe bis da einmal nur schnell genug sein
zeit für dich bleibt gleich
beziehungsweise für dich vergeht halt die sache drumherum schneller
ja war ich weiß auch nicht was heute ist btf
okay hier ist hier hier waren wir jetzt
ja aber wie wir auf die ganze sache eigentlich gekommen sind ich finde es
gut dass youtube channels die sich mit so was beschäftigen zur zeit so ein
bisschen in boom haben zumindest im englisch sprach moment wunderschön
zumindest im englischsprachigen raum und ein bisschen in deutschland auch ist ja
gar nichts mehr an mobs ane die sind einfach nur ausgefadet
wie gesagt außer youtube videos dazu habe ich dann auch keinen weiteren
hintergrund eigentlich wollte ich sagen ich finde es gut dass solche channels
erfolgreich sind
jetzt habe ich den twitch bildungs krieg ausgelöst das ist überhaupt schon auf
twitch ja über sachen wie wurmlöcher wurmlöcher zeit rein sonnensystem was
auch immer diskutiert mit hallo wo sind wir hier gelandet das ist twitch das ist
copy pest copy pasta spam pock champ lull spam keine ahnung wie mit mir
spammort backer if band keine ahnung aber nicht so was jetzt ruckelt das game wieder da los
ich habe mir gestern am sushi bestellt könnte man gleich noch mal bestellen
er wird übelst bock rauf gestern haben wir krabben rolls gehabt heute für die krebsfleisch
rolls nehmen
dass er rollt rollt
max punsch das wird nur das wird nur ein also man denkt es wird eintönig wirds
aber nicht weil das kampfsystem recht unterhaltsam ist und außerdem sind die
mobs hier halt absolut trash können halt nichts ich mach zwei spell zu sind
dauern es gibt auch ein bisschen anspruchsvollere mobs aber die geben
gute ex
Ist das nicht in allen Cryant Gebieten so?
Ne, es gibt Gebiete, die sind besser mit der Gruppe, also sind die Mops für einen alleine
vielleicht nicht unbesiegbar, aber nicht effektiv, wenn man zu lang braucht, oder es gibt auch
Gebiete, da musst du mit Gruppe hin, aber ich sag's nochmal, ich bin Noob in dem Game,
der best ausgerüstete Noob, und das ohne, dass ich einen Account gekauft hätte, ist
mein Account, einfach nur RNG Glück, Moment, warum ist unser Info schon wieder voll?
WTF, wir waren ja erst abgeben, okay, ich sprinte jetzt auch mal, okay, man hat ja gerade
im Chat gemeint, ich würde nicht sprinten, das Trigger, jetzt wird gesprintet, und teleportiert
dabei, ja deswegen stream ich das ja auch gerne, weil man nebenbei Chat lesen und über
irgendwie um die Welt labern, und dabei schon im Kreis grinden, oh es ist 17.59 Uhr, Telekom
schlägt gleich zu, wenn wir Pech haben, hoffen wir mal, dass die Telekom heute nicht zuschlägt,
gestern hat sie zugeschlagen, wie hier, ja so war das gemeint Marv, so war das gemeint,
über Gott und die Welt hatten wir das ja mal im Weihnachtstream schon, das reicht,
nicht?
Warum denn Telekom?
Weil ich zwischen 17.00 Uhr und 19.30 öfters mal DSL-Synchronisierung verliere, weil weiß
nur die Telekom warum, aber sie wissen es nicht, weil sie Kacke sind, ihre Sachen nicht
im Griff haben, whoa, da fuck, was war das gerade für ein Ruckler, alter, ich hab mich
beamed
Ach so warum telekom als provider weil sie die einzigen sind die mir diese bandbreite hier anbieten können
Also ich habe bei der telekom vdsl 100 das heißt ich habe 100 down und 40 ab davor hatte ich unity media
150 down und
und 5 oder 6 ab und 5 ich glaube 5 ab 5 m bit ab hatte ich das war das war schon zum streamen
Eigentlich zu wenig und zum uploaden auf youtube da wo ich eigentlich hauptsächlich aktiv bin
War es halt auch nervig dass teilweise halt eine halbe stunde oder so gewartet bei einem bisschen größeren video
Jetzt kann ich es in richtig richtig guter guter quali
1440 p 60 fps kann ich die videos rendern und auf youtube hochladen innerhalb von 15 20 minuten mit 40 mbit upload
Und ich wäre auch gar nicht zur telekom gegangen hätte unity media bei mir warum sind jetzt alle leute nachts waren die noch nicht da
Ich wäre auch bei unity media geblieben also ich bin ja noch bei unity media der vertrag läuft ja noch
Aber das wird gekündigt
Ich wäre auch bei unity media geblieben wenn die irgendwie eine sinnvolle alternative anzubieten hätten haben sie aber nicht was ich für
ultra fail halte ehrlich gesagt heute bin ich hier überhaupt
Die schicken mir immer werbung nach dem motto
Hier ist es zeit zu upgraden bla bla bla und habe ich mal nachgeguckt was die haben
Die haben jetzt 400 mbit down
Nice brauche eigentlich brauche man nicht wirklich mit 10 mbit ab und das ist ein
Verhältnis das sehe ich nicht ein
Vor allem ist der upgrade für mich als content creator
Jetzt wo bin ich denn hier überhaupt
Von 5 auf 10 ist halt naja von 10 auf 40 im upload das macht sich richtig bemerkbar
Richtig bemerkbar
So und 400 runter brauche ich nicht
Ich kann eher mit 100 runter statt 150 leben und dafür 40 statt 5 ab
So und früher hatte unity media noch so eine option dass du quasi sagen konntest
Ich möchte noch mehr upload haben dann dann hätte ich quasi so was machen können wie
400 runter und 20 hoch das hätte ich mir auch noch gefallen dass ich gesagt ok 400 runter ist nice 20 hoch ist auch eine
Gute verbesserung von 5 aber gibt es nicht schwer mit den neuen tarifen also scheiß auf unity media
Und wieder telekom
Mit den ja genau obito so ist es ja auch mit den mit den ich will übrigens zurück zur stadt fällt mir gerade ein
mit den
400 down kann man besser werbung machen
Und
Das ist es
Und der gag ist ja eigentlich bei 400 runter und 10 ab ich gehe mal davon aus
Dass es diese 10 ab auch nur gibt weil du sie rechnerisch brauchst um 400 down ordentlich aus
überhaupt ausnutzen zu können
Müssen man müsste das mal nachrechnen man müsste das mal nachrechnen
Wie viel upload man braucht um 400 down ordentlich verwenden zu können müssen wir mal nachrechnen
Rechnen also hängt davon hängt eigentlich von zwei sachen ab oder
So wir waren zwar ganz simpel ich muss jetzt ja nicht alles
im detail technisch erklären aber es ist ja so wenn ihr was
Wenn ihr was bekommt beziehungsweise wenn ihr was schickt schickt euch die andere seite oder ihr der anderen seite
in der regel eine bestätigung dass es angekommen ist
Man kann das auch mit einem paket machen für mehrere paketen die man bekommen hat aber irgendwann muss man eine bestätigung schicken weil sonst macht die andere seite nicht weiter
Und deswegen braucht man ein mindestmaß an upload um überhaupt den download ordentlich
ausführen zu können
Also sprich rein download ohne upload geht nicht
Funktion ist weil du keine bestätigung verschicken kannst du kannst dagegen stelle nicht sagen habe bekommen
Müssten wir mal ausrechnen ich gehe mal davon aus diese 10 m bit ab hast du auch nur dass du überhaupt ordentlich downloaden kannst
Sonst hätten die wahrscheinlich auch nur eingegeben oder so wenn es gehen würde
Musik ist gerade ein bisschen nervig die die die die die die
So wald
Die ganze kreppel weg
Ja krypto ka ich wollte es jetzt nicht komplizierter machen
Als es sein muss und so ziemlich alles im internet ist tcp
So was man so normal macht
Jetzt mal von games oder vielleicht eventuell in streams oder so mal außen vor
Aber selbst da ist es nicht so einfach
Aber auch in
Ich hab mir, also das ist nicht übermäßig viel, aber ich hab mir ein paar Sachen geholt.
Ähm, ich muss mir grad mal überlegen, was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Äh, Goldbein getauscht, bla, repariert.
Nein, ich hab mal alles gemacht, kommen wir wieder zurück.
Ähm, ich hab mir Pets gekauft, ich hab mir, äh, Inventarplätze, Storageplätze und Gewichtserweiterungen
gekauft.
Und ich hab mir ein paar Artisan Memories zum Enchanten gekauft.
Also ich hab jetzt keine tausenden Euro ausgegeben oder so, aber auch nicht komplett free to
play oder halt buy to play, sondern ein bisschen was hab ich schon reingesteckt.
Ähm, mein CSGO Hype, das ist ja schon Jahre her, ich hab ja CSGO vor zwei Jahren noch
so intensiv gespielt, das lag daran, äh, weil wir das vorhin von Overwatch hatten,
dass es nur Spaß macht in Gruppe, CS finde ich auch so.
Richtig Spaß macht es eigentlich bloß, wenn du mit, äh, in der Gruppe spielst.
Und irgendwie haben wir da nicht mal zusammen gespielt.
Und mir gingen die Hacker auf den Sack.
CS ist halt ein Game, das dauert eine Runde auch mal ein bisschen, bis das vorbei ist.
Aber wenn du dann irgendwelche Hacks aus am Start hast, das ist super nervig.
Und ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwie sowas wie, oh da ist besser wie mich, da muss hacken,
sondern ganz extrem offensichtliche Dinger.
Wo hast du die Rüstung her?
Wenn ich dir das erzähle, I'm Dazidizzi, sprich mal das aus, wenn ich dir das erzähle,
dann lass mich aus, sagst du, ha, RNG carried, kacknoob.
Ich kann dir mal zu jedem Item erzählen, wo ich das her hab, dann greifst du dir noch
mehr am Kopf.
Was ich für ein Glück hab bei meiner Playtime.
Warte mal, ich mach die Fische erstmal platt hier.
Also, off wizard, move ditch, Jais Helm gesniped aus dem AHA, den hab ich nicht an, der liegt
in Velia irgendwo im Wald rum, da ist er, Jais Helm, Jais Helm haben wir gesniped aus
dem Auktionshaus, G-Spirit Armor hab ich aus einer Daily Reward Kiste gekriegt, übelst
Glück, übelst Glück gehabt, es hat kaum einer was rausgekriegt, es haben alle Leute,
die Box war verbackt, es haben alle Leute nur Red Nose rausgekriegt und weil die Box
verbackt war, gab es noch eine zweite Box und aus dieser Box haben wieder 95% nur Red
Nose Armor rausgekriegt und ich hab Tree Spirit Armor rausgezogen, easy, so, das haben
wir gecraftet, Biggs haben wir gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus, on stream glaub ich, Kutum
haben wir gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus, Zaka hab ich gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus
und jetzt kommt der Hit, Mask and Shoes hab ich aus der zweiten, in der zweiten Woche
der Weekly Quest selbst gezogen, so und im Januar hol ich mir da noch meine Danda ab
mit Daily Reward Siegeln und dann bin ich komplett equipped, GG Eats, ich hab ja überhaupt
keine Playtime so richtig, das ist halt RNG Luck ohne Ende und ich wusste das gar nicht
zu schätzen, so als ich die ersten paar Items gekriegt hab, hab ich mir gesagt, ja Eats,
du weißt gar nicht was die alle haben, so schwer ist das doch gar nicht, aber mittlerweile
ist mir klar was für ein Glück gehabt hab, hat das hier eine Level Beschränkung, nein,
das gibt es nicht, ja The Freaks, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich hab das ja schon lange ne, ich
hab jetzt ja wieder irgendwie 3-4 Monate nicht gespielt oder so, das einzige was neu hinzugekommen
ist jetzt seit ich wieder angefangen hab, quasi die letzte diese Woche so ist aus den
Daily Rewards, ich hab halt immer eingeloggt und Daily Rewards geholt, haben wir halt noch
hier Crash und Guardian Ring enchantet, das ist das einzige was dazu gekommen ist und
ich hab halt hier Schmuck gefarmt, der ist halt wirklich gut, dieser Drop Schmuck, aber
das ging auch schnell, das kann man auch empfehlen zu farmen, das ist echt guter Schmuck im Set,
easy zu bekommen, 5er Set, mein 3er Set gibt Leben, 5er Set gibt Genauigkeit plus 20 und
die Stats von den Dingern sind auch ganz gut, also die Dinger sollte man sich schon farmen
und es ist easy selbst zu farmen, dauert nicht lang, also dauert auch in BDO Zeit nicht
lang, da grindest du jeden Spot ein paar Stunden, dann hast du den Kram, brauchst du 3-4 Stunden
oder so für oder wenn es schlecht läuft vielleicht mal 2 Tage, geht das Leveln immer so schnell,
die haben das angepasst vor ein paar Patches, also wo ich zuletzt gespielt hab ging das Leveln
bis 60 noch viel langsamer und ich habe 50% oder 55% zu meiner 60 noch auf dem alten Patchstand
gemacht wo es langsamer ging und das ging wirklich viel langsamer, bis 56 Leveln ist
überhaupt kein Ding und bis 58 Leveln ist eigentlich kein Ding, der Fabian meinte mal
wenn man eine Ahnung von dem Game hat Levelste auf 58 in einem Tag mittlerweile, ein Tag beim
Fabian kann halt auch mal 20 Stunden haben, aber es geht schnell mittlerweile, aber die
Schmuckteile farmen ist empfehlenswert, es geht einfach und hat gute Stats und kann man
lange behalten bis man besseren Schmuck hat, weil die meisten Leute, da wird es wahrscheinlich
so sein wie ich, die haben als erstes hier halt eher Rüstungsteile, Offhand, Mainhand,
Awakening Waffe und sowas als Boss Teile und Schmuck vor allem, Enchanted Schmuck kommt
dann eigentlich als letztes, deswegen ist es besonders gut wenn man sich die Dinger farmt.
Na jetzt doch mal dem Frisur seinen Aufruf gefolgt, meinst du mir die Ohr spielen, naja
der Fabian ist ja auch der einzige Grund warum ich das Spiel spiele, also warum ich überhaupt
angefangen habe damit, wir haben ja früher, wir haben schon sau viele MMOs zusammen gespielt
und wir haben halt mal wieder einfach eins gebraucht wo man jetzt, wo man halt zusammen
spielen kann, nachdem er ja kein Condor spielt und kein Battlefield oder so und Overwatch
will er ja auch nicht weil er BDO spielen muss, bleibt ja nur übrig dass ich BDO spiele
und ohne den Fabian wäre meine Sachen auch noch gar nicht so gut Enchanted, er hat halt
übelst Game Knowledge was das anbelangt, WTF wie skruggelt das Game, aber es ist halt BDO
und ich hab halt rein gelackt mit den Items, aber Glück gehört in BDO einfach dabei.
Wo haben die sich denn jetzt geheilt, was soll denn das hier, wollen die mich rollen
oder was, easy, heut läufts aber, 2 golden Dagger, 1 Seraph Necklace schon, das geht
ab, easy money easy life, ich muss jetzt gleich mal was futtern, nicht dass es wieder so läuft
wie vor 2 Tagen wo ich das seit 18 Uhr erzählt habe, ich muss jetzt was essen und dann irgendwann
um 21 Uhr mal was geholt habe, ja wenn man das so spielt wie der Fabian hat man neben
BDO wirklich keine Zeit für andere Spiele, aber man kann das auch ziemlich casual mäßig
spielen wie ich, ja, wie gesagt ich spiele ja nicht viel, ich hab auch nicht viel Playtime,
ich hatte halt übelst RNG Luck, ja das stimmt, aber die machen ja auch viel für das man
nicht total den Anschluss verliert, also BDO kann man als Hardcore Game spielen und auch
als nebenbei MMO, ist eigentlich so eins der größten Stärken von dem Game und vor allem
ist es halt auch sehr vielfältig wie man es spielen kann, manchmal muss man einfach
auch mal Glück haben, gleich 91, also ich würde sagen wenn wir jetzt weiter grinden
bis zur nächsten Nacht, dann könnte das heute noch was werden mit 60, wenn man von Battlefield
oder CS kommt hat man hier halt echt wenig Durchblick, man hat generell wenig Durchblick
wenn man BDO anfängt, BDO ist relativ komplex was man alles machen kann und hat viele Sachen
die man machen kann und die Erklärungen in-Game bringen einen so wirklich weiter, also man
wird zwangsläufig wenn man einsteigt ein bisschen Zeit mit Guide lesen, Guide gucken
und so verbringen, wie gesagt ich blicke bei vielen Aspekten von BDO ja auch nicht durch,
im Prinzip was ich kann ist mit meinem Wizard im Kreis laufen und drei Spells machen und
Mops killen, aber das reicht erstmal, ich habe auch noch einiges von der Weltkarte nicht
aufgedeckt, hier, da, ja, mein Worker System ist noch nicht richtig ausgebaut und die
Fusion Points Energie hier noch nicht richtig hochgelevelt, spielt ihr demnächst mal zusammen,
gestern Abend haben wir zusammen gespielt, am Wochenende gehe ich mal von aus, ja, das
ist ja eines der Gründe warum ich überhaupt BDO spiele, dass wir wieder zusammen immer
so groß spielen können, wenn du nicht gerade Ultra-IL-Stalls machen musst und keine Zeit
mehr hat, ja, eigentlich keine Spieler hier, ich habe gerade das Wasser Grill beschworen,
ich will nicht das Wasser Grill, ich will den Feuer Typ, hier sind definitiv noch andere
Spieler, gehe ich wieder zurück, so ich werde jetzt gleich mal Afk-Klo danach was zu essen
holen, also ich denke ich bin so in 5 Minuten wieder da, erstmal die Mops hier killen, ich
würde sagen ich logg um, ich logg um auf den Bersi, nicht dass ich hier AFK jetzt irgendwie
noch gekillt werde von irgendwelchen Mops, so ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, so ich logg
mal auf den Bersi um und wo habe ich hier mal einen schönen Text, Afk, so ich bin
in 2-3 Minuten wieder am Start, was sagst du zur Lemoria Rüstung, ist das das aus dem
neuen Elfengebiet, kein Schwimmer von, so wähliger Aussicht, habt ihr einen schönen
Musikvorschlag für die Zeit wo ich Afk bin den ich anmachen kann, lass mal gucken was
haben wir hier schon, weiß was wir machen, mach mal den hier, Afk, so ich bin jetzt schon
auf dem Bersi um, ich logg um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, was sagst du zur Lemoria
Rüstung, ich logg um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich
logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um,
ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi
um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den
Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den
Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf
den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal auf den Bersi um, ich logg mal
Essen bin als ich den mal so fünf Minuten oder so
Brauche ich jetzt, ne nicht social eating ich mute mich wenn ich futter weil dass ich ich habe selbst ich mag selbst keine Essensgeräusche
Also wie gesagt ich bin da ich esse noch was wenn irgendwas interessantes im Chat steht sage ich auch was
Ja wo bin ich Mr. Unlocker bin ich
Weil gerade jemand was wegen der Musik über Halo im Chat geschrieben hat glaubt das Problem von Halo aktuell ist einfach
noch nicht mal so sehr dass der Entwickler gewechselt hat sondern dass die Xbox One eine Scheiß Plattform ist
Mal gucken wie das beim nächsten Halo wird ob das auch auf dem PC rauskommt sie haben ja gesagt quasi
Xbox Exclusive willst du dir so richtig geben? Schauen wir mal
Ich meine Crossplay kannst du nicht wirklich machen zwischen Konsole und PC
Aber ein richtig geiles Halo auf dem PC richtig Support und so ich glaube das könnte der Reihe wirklich neuen Hype geben
Weil eins muss man sagen so ranking eSport technisch war Halo der beste Titel den es hier auf der Konsole gegeben hat fand ich
Aber ein richtig geiles Halo auf dem PC richtig Support und so ich glaube das kann der Reihe wirklich neuen Hype geben
Ich hab ja ganz was vergessen.
Ich hab ja vorhin gefragt, ob wir uns, als ich das erzählt hab, dass ich ne Warnung vom Hersteller gekriegt hab, dass mein Klo anfangen kann zu brennen.
Hab ich dann gesagt, hier, wer sich interessiert dafür, was für ein Klo ist, weil ein paar gefragt haben, ähm, guckt euch das YouTube Video an.
Und da haben wir gesagt, wir gucken es uns zusammen an. Das können wir doch jetzt machen, während ich esse.
Ich, ich reakte mal zu meinem, zu meinem eigenen YouTube Klo Video.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Moment.
Ich reakte.
Ähm, Fenster, Fenster, Window Capture.
Firefox.
So.
Jetzt kommt's.
Da ist es.
Fucks Klo Review. Moment, ich mache die Musik aus.
Lul.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist es natürlich jetzt tatsächlich soweit, dass ich ohne Scheiß ein Video von meinem Klo mache.
Ich meine, ihr wisst ja, das ist kein normales Klo, das ist ein Special Klo mit Special Funktionen.
Ähm, wir fangen mal vielleicht bei der einfachsten Sache ab.
Ich meine, Deckel hat eine Absenkautomatik, das haben aber mittlerweile echt viele, das ist nichts besonderes mehr, das knallt halt nicht mehr so.
Easy hat jeder, jeder, das ist überhaupt nichts erwähnenswertes.
Nein, easy ist das.
Hallo Rhi Rollens.
Äh, was geht?
Wir gucken uns grad, ich reakte zu alten Videos.
Wir gucken uns grad das Video von meinem Klo an.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, mir geht das schon fast ein bisschen langsam.
Ja, das heißt, ich helfe das immer ein bisschen nach dann.
Ähm, was er noch hat, ist eine echt geile Beschichtung innen drin.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, aus was das Ding genau besteht.
Das Ding ist jetzt 2 Monate und so in Benutzung, aber außer die Wasserperlen, die man da drauf sieht, es bleibt nichts hängen.
Gar nichts.
Das ist halt echt geil.
Es muss kaum sauber machen, das Ding.
Das ist aber echt geil.
Ich musste noch nie ein Klo so wenig putzen wie den.
Muss gar nichts machen, das ist echt geiles Ding.
Ähm, spül's einfach mit Wassertube, das geht alles ab.
Also die haben da irgendwie eine echt geile Beschichtung in dem Klo.
Also für Leute, die nicht gerne Klo sauber machen, ist das auf jeden Fall eine super Geschichte.
Aber was das eigentlich richtig special macht, ist dieses silberne Ding, was man da hinten dran sieht.
Und ich werd euch das auch gleich demonstrieren.
Lauter?
Müssen wir's lauter machen?
Moment.
Kann ich's machen.
Was das eigentlich richtig special macht, ist dieses silberne Ding, was man da hinten dran sieht.
Jetzt besser, ne?
Und ich werd euch das auch gleich demonstrieren, wie das alles funktioniert.
Da muss man ein bisschen tricksen.
In diesem silbernen Ding eingelassen ist einmal ein Föhn.
Ähm, so eine Düse.
Hab mich den Arsch mit abspülen lassen.
Die Düse kann auch ein bisschen weiter rausfahren.
Dann kann ich die Mädels auch noch an anderen Stellen abspülen lassen.
Und es hat, ähm, so eine Absaugetechnik.
Das heißt, es springt dann auch noch.
Also man zieht das dann ab.
Ähm, das ist aber, ey, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das ist übelst geil.
Ich hatte das ja damals neu.
Jetzt ist es ja schon zwei oder drei Jahre alt.
Diese, dieser Ventilator da dran, der quasi den ganzen Kram nach außen bläst, ja?
Das ist die beste Erfindung.
Du sitzt da drauf und es ist nichts einfach.
Wie man das Ding bedient, entweder bedient man das Ding hier über die Knöpfe nehmen, ja?
Und man sieht schon, das ist ein bisschen doof.
Da muss man hier, muss man hier drum herumgreifen und alles.
Jetzt Achtung, jetzt mit Special.
Ich mach hier auf, bam, mit Fernbedienung drin, ja?
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Also so ein Klo mit Fernbedienung.
Sachen gibt's, oder?
Ähm, wir gehen jetzt mal da ein bisschen...
Warte mal, ein altes iPhone.
Übrigens, hier unten, ne?
Ich, ich, ich hab das überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Man kann das hier unten ausklappen noch.
Und da unten drunter sind noch mal so viele Knöpfe als hier drauf.
Da kann man Temperatur einstellen.
Ähm, Winkel einstellen.
Ähm, alles mögliche an den Knöpfen da unten, die sieht man gar nicht.
Die zeig ich gar nicht.
Also, was man hier drauf sieht, ist...
Einmal war hier oben natürlich so eine Anzeige.
Also, passt alles.
Sieht man, sieht man alles Mögliche.
Gucken, das Licht ist ein bisschen scheiße.
Man sieht wenig, das spiegelt sich mein iPhone.
Wenn ich glaub, so sieht man das ganz gut.
Ähm, Wasserstrahl weniger, Wasserstrahl stärker, Wasserstrahl an.
Föhnart, Abzug an.
Ähm, Damenspülung an.
Absaug, ähm, Intensität hier unten drunter.
Da kann man eben den Wasserstrahl noch einstellen.
Man kann es auch irgendwie heizen lassen.
Heizen kann man mit den Knöpfen hier unten drunter.
Man kann das hier unten runterklappen.
Da ist da noch ein Knopf drauf, wie es heizen soll.
Ausgeschaltet, eingeschaltet, wenn man drauf sitzt oder immer an.
Funktioniert.
Aber gut, ähm, soweit die Fernbedienung.
Jetzt wollen natürlich alle wissen, wie das Ganze aussieht.
So, nachdem ich jetzt keinen Bock hab, meinen Bart einzusauen mit dem Wasserstrahl.
Und es funktioniert ja auch gar nicht.
Ja, also ich hab's gesehen, ich hab da drauf geklickt, es passiert nichts.
Man muss das Ganze jetzt ein bisschen faken.
Und ich hab das vorher mal ausprobiert, das klappt.
Es ist, ähm, bei dem Klo wird mitgeliefert so ein Testding.
Ist schon geil, ne? Dass da so was dabei ist.
Das kann man dann hier draufsetzen.
Sieht dann so aus, dann haben wir den Deckel drunter.
Dass das Ganze auch so ist, dass das Ganze hält.
Zeit hab ich immer noch.
So, nun, müssen wir mal schauen, wie wir das jetzt hier halbwegs, ähm, gescheit machen.
Weil man muss das Ganze hier neben hin halten.
Da ist nämlich irgendwie eine Lichtschranke oder sonst was drinne.
Ohne das funktioniert's nicht.
Aber jetzt...
Guck mal, guck mal, was man hier sieht.
Damals, damals hatte ich noch eine Decke vorm Fenster hängen, weil der Roller noch kaputt war.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das jetzt hier mal an.
Jetzt hier, da ist es.
Bäm!
Zack.
In your arsch.
So, dann machen wir das aus.
Und dann sollte eigentlich jetzt gleich der Föhn angehen.
Man sieht's hier unten rechts, der Föhn ist an.
Föhn.
Kannst Föhn, Föhn mal drücken.
Föhn geht nicht.
Föhn nicht.
Ach, ich bin weggegangen.
Ich bin aus der Lichtschranke rausgegangen.
Okay, das ist blöd.
Dann müssen wir das noch mal kurz spülen.
Und diesmal bleiben wir über der Lichtschranke drüber.
So, machen aus.
Und jetzt sollte der Föhn eigentlich gleich angehen.
Ja, mach Spülaction.
Jetzt geht das.
Jetzt wird geföhnt, ja.
Da sieht man den Mauch.
Da föhnt's vor sich hin.
Ähm, dann machen wir den Föhn jetzt noch mal kurz aus.
Man sieht hier, man hat ja auch so einen Absaug.
Das ist so asiatisch.
Naja, die Asiaten wissen dann was Gutes.
Ihr hört's.
Dann stinkt es nicht im Bad.
Sehr praktische Geschichte.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache.
Es muss jeder selbst wissen, ob, um das...
Das Wert ist letztendlich so viel Geld für die Geschichte auszugeben.
Das ist ein...
Wie heißt das Ding noch mal?
Genau, das ist ein Jeberit Aqua Clean 8000 plus, glaube ich.
Das ist so wirklich das Premium-Modell, was die haben.
Hier gibt's von denen nicht.
Ach, stimmt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was es gekostet hat.
Immer noch.
2.500 Euro oder sowas.
Also schon ziemlich teuer.
Muss jeder wirklich selbst wissen, ob das was für ihn ist.
Aber ich finde, das ist ein sehr...
Ich glaube, das stimmt auch gar nicht, was ich erzählt habe.
Ich glaube, das Ding hat ziemlich glatt 3K gekostet.
Angenehme Geschichte.
Das ist wirklich eine Sache, die ist richtig cool.
Und kann man sich überlegen.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht eines der Top-Sachen,
die ich mehr anschaffen müsste,
wenn andere Sachen noch irgendwie fehlen würden.
So, jetzt habt ihr auch mal den Klo gesehen.
Er ist auch gar nicht so ultra groß.
Also das geht schon.
Er hat halt ganz normale Größe.
Hier oben ist ja noch die Spüle dazu.
Sieht auch immer das Ding normal aus, ja.
Also man kann das Ding wie einen stinknormalen Klo benutzen,
ohne da jetzt auch...
Na, mach Witz, Max.
Oder wenn das irgendein Guest nicht ist,
dann haben wir die noch mal.
Ich glaube, die Gäste finden das gerade geil.
Jetzt habt ihr auch mal den Klo gesehen.
Wird uns gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Ja, so.
Und wie wir darauf gekommen sind,
für alle, die sich jetzt denken,
what the fuck, was will er denn hier von uns?
Mir hat heute der Hersteller, gestern,
gestern, ja,
hat mich der Hersteller angerufen,
dass das Klo brennen kann.
Das Klo kann sich entzünden.
Weil der Düsenreiniger da drinne ist,
zu leicht entflammbar ist.
Na, geil, oder?
So, jetzt hab ich das angeguckt.
Ich hab gesagt, ich esse nebenbei,
aber ich hab jetzt noch kaum was gegessen.
Also, ich futter mal weiter.
Garten stellt als nächstes.
Nee, nee, wir machen jetzt hier
kein Maxi Reactive zu seinen Videos.
Schaust du die Grand Tour?
Nee.
So, Automobilzeug und Autosport
und so ist nix für mich.
Hanf-Wandt?
Nein.
Ich hab noch keine 60 gepackt.
Ich hab jetzt, glaub ich, 91%
und muss grad was futtern.
Was es gibt?
Na, nachdem es gestern
richtig geile Sushi gab,
mir kurz überlegt hab, ob ich heute
noch mal ne Runde Sushi bestellen soll.
Also, quasi anstatt Krabben-Rolls
heute dann Krebsfleisch-Rolls.
Äh, Schwachsinn.
Anstatt Garnelen-Rolls,
Krebsfleisch-Rolls heute
hab ich mir jetzt einfach
Salami-Brötchen gemacht.
Also nix Tolles.
Hast jetzt doch wieder Bock
auf BDO. Jo.
Hab ich wieder.
Äh, Mr. Anlocker,
ich glaube, es gibt ne
P4P-Rangliste
oder sowas.
Und ja, Voodoo Cloud, ich hab in dem Game
auch schon Kohle ausgegeben.
Jetzt zwar keine Tausender oder so,
aber auch schon ein oder anderen Euro
für Inventarplätze, Storage, Pets.
Bisschen
Artisans Memories.
Bist du wirklich eine Katze? Nein,
ich bin ein Keks.
Das sollten aber mittlerweile alle mitbekommen haben.
Bringen die Pets auch Boni?
Ja.
Ähm.
Also,
erst mal das Wichtigste an Pets ist,
dass sie für dich Loot aufheben.
Komm mal grad mal Pets füttern.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Äh, Common Sense, ja, genau,
das ist das Game, wo der Fabian im Video was erzählt hat.
Ähm,
das ist das Wichtigste.
Äh, Common Sense,
ja, genau, das ist das Game,
wo der Fabian im Video was erzählt hat.
Ähm,
dass sie für dich Loot aufheben ist das Wichtigste.
Umso höheres Tier die haben und Level,
umso schneller machen sie das.
Ähm,
man kann mittlerweile fünf Pets draußen haben
und
die Pets haben aber auch noch Zusatzfähigkeiten.
Also, der Igel hat zum Beispiel,
dass du mehr Fisch-XP kriegst,
also für die Klassen Fischer,
Fisch-Craft-Leute unter uns.
Und, ähm,
dass du ein bisschen mehr
Life-Skill-X kriegst und sowas.
Und halt das hier, das ist, wo manche sagen,
das wäre quasi Pay to Win.
Dass du mehr Zeug sammelst,
wenn du den Igel draußen hast.
So, die Katze,
also quasi Katz-FPS plus In-Game,
Hals ja auch genauso.
Hat, äh, Koch-XP,
Life-XP,
und das ist das beste Gathering-Level.
Ich Glück gehabt.
Der China-Farmer DesertFox,
der hat auch Gathering-Level,
also auch wieder schön RNG-Luck gehabt.
RNG-Streamhund
hat, ähm,
naja,
geht so.
Und der Pinguin hat auch jetzt
nichts so Tolles,
aber, wenn man AFK
fischt, ist der ganz gut.
Da fischt man schneller,
wenn man AFK ist.
Aber es sammeln alle Loot ein.
Als Anfänger sollte man
sich da erst die Igel holen. Nee, nicht unbedingt.
Der Igel,
den gibt es nur Pay to Win,
also den gibt es nur, den gibt es nur im Shop,
über, in so einem Paket.
Das, was in dem Paket drin ist,
an sich ist auch so ganz gut,
ähm, du kannst den Igel
aber halt nicht upgraden.
Also wenn du zwei Pets
von einer Art zusammenverkuppelst,
quasi, weiß gar nicht,
ging hier irgendwo über das Menü,
dann kriegst du da
ein neues Tier raus,
was eine Chance hat,
quasi ein höheres Tier
zu sein, also ein höheres,
höheres Level standardmäßig
zu haben, eine höhere
Stufe quasi zu haben,
und andere Fähigkeiten.
Du kannst danach auswählen, was du für
Fähigkeiten du quasi von Mutter, Vater behalten
willst und wie es aussehen soll und sowas.
Aber Pets sind
äh, ziemlich Pay to Win in dem Game.
Also du kannst
die jetzt zwar über den Marketplace kaufen, wenn da mal
einer was reinsetzt, aber ansonsten halt
über den Shop.
Ja und Tier ist definitiv nicht egal,
weil es gerade irgendjemand geschrieben hat,
im Chat definitiv nicht. Ich war
in Pillar mit dem Friseur,
jeder vier Pets draußen.
Er damals mit seinen vier Tier 3 Pets
und ich mit meinen vier Tier 1 Pets,
seine Pets haben quasi fast,
haben viel mehr gelootet als meins.
Viel viel mehr.
Und jetzt
dürfte es ziemlich ausgeglichen sein.
So, ich muss jetzt aber endlich mal fertig essen,
dass ich weiter kreiten kann.
Ups.
Nervudo Cloud, so schlimm ist das nicht.
Also, du kannst
in BDO verdammt viel Geld ausgeben.
Aber wenn du dir so die
so diese,
wie nennt man das so, Quality of Life Sachen
kaufst, quasi Pets,
Inventarplätze, Storageplätze und so,
gibste
Value Packs, da gibst du halt mal irgendwie so
30, 40 Euro aus.
Oder sag mal so,
sag mal mal du gibst Vollpreis aus,
sag mal so 60 Euro,
dann hast du eigentlich alles, was du brauchst
erstmal.
Und mehr cashen kannst du immer.
Nervudo Cloud,
du musst dir nichts kaufen.
Also, du kannst dir keine
Instant Level, Instant Gear
oder sowas kaufen.
Aber, das
meiste kriegst du auch in Game so.
Aber so Sachen wie Storage,
Erweiterungen und Inventarplätze und sowas
ist schon sinnvoll.
Oder Pets,
Pets kriegst du theoretisch aus dem Marketplace
auch, aber doch relativ selten.
Manchmal sind in den Rewards Pets dabei,
aber wenn man das ernsthaft spielt,
wird man relativ schnell merken,
was einen nervt
und sich dann dort noch ein bisschen,
bisschen was kaufen.
Aber wie gesagt, man muss,
also das ist extrem teuer,
es stimmt nicht.
Der Fabian hat ja letztens irgendwie ein Video erzählt,
ich gebe jeden Monat 100 Euro
für BDO aus, erstens glaube ich nicht,
dass ich das nicht kann.
Und man muss
jeden Monat definitiv keine 100 Euro
für BDO ausgeben.
Das ist vollkommener Blödsinn.
Brauch man nicht.
Das Zeug verschwindet ja nicht.
Und wie ist 240 Hertz Monitor so?
Ja, gut, Patrick.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, doch.
Ich kann es mir vorstellen, dass er das macht.
Ja, schon.
Also,
ja,
Und zum Einstieg,
nur angucken willst, wo du klaut, brauchst du gar nichts.
Wenn du eine Weile gespielt hast,
wird dir dann schon feststellen, dass es dir auf den Keks geht zu looten oder
dass dein Inventar zu klein ist.
Worauf ich in-game warte, ich versuche eigentlich mein Abendessen zu futtern die ganze Zeit
und dann weiter mein Wizard zu leveln.
Aber ich kann schon mal wieder umlocken, ich bin eigentlich fertig.
Was ist 144Hz Lightboost?
Also, mit Lightboost ist gemeint,
dass dein Monitor, die Hintergrundschritte,
ausschalten kann, also an- und ausschalten kann.
Ganz kurz natürlich nur, ja.
Hoffentlich sind die ganzen Typen hier weg von eben.
Bam!
Jo, da warte ich drauf, Patrick.
4K, 145Hz Schießung.
So, das war's für heute.
Das wird das erste Mal seit Jahren, dass ich wieder einen neuen Monitor hole.
Moment, da sind wieder Leute.
Könnt ihr mich nicht einfach mal hier in Ruhe grinden lassen?
Statt meine Mops zu killen,
könnt ihr mich nicht einfach mal hier in Ruhe grinden lassen?
statt meine Mops zu killen.
Weil ihr seht, wenn man von oben mit einem Satellit draufgucken würde,
würde da Max stehen auf den Mops.
Die stehen quasi in Max-Formation.
Deswegen sind das meine Mops.
Bei welchem Bufffood sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich wieder?
Exp, ne? Sind wir Exp.
Jetzt weißt du, warum du nie Wizard spielst?
Naja, ich benutze von dem Wizard ja auch gerade drei Spells nur.
So unmobil ist Wizard gar nicht.
Der Teleport ist ganz gut.
Und du hast halt diesen Speed und damit läufst du auch relativ schnell.
Also es geht.
Ich wüsste es halt nur machen.
Das Ding könnte ich auch mal machen.
Ich glaube, ich auch Movement Speed.
Max, du spielst BDO?
Ja, spiel BDO, weil der Friseur BDO spielt.
Und wir endlich mal wieder ein MMO brauchen,
wo wir zusammen spielen können.
Der Fabian ist ja quasi mittlerweile Deutschlands größter BDO-Stremer.
Kann das sein, dass ich falsch laufe gerade?
Ne, ne, ne, passt alles.
Also übrigens noch mal zu dem Monitor,
wann der nächstes Jahr rauskommt, ne?
Oder hoffentlich, der sollte eigentlich schon dieses Jahr rauskommen.
Also 144Hz.
Und also 144Hz, HDR, G-Sync, 4K.
Das Ding ist übertrieben teuer.
Und ich gedenke auch nicht,
4K 144Hz zu spielen.
Höchstens halt das Game gibt das her,
dann werde ich das auch machen.
Moment, ist schon wieder alles weg.
Leute, könnt ihr nicht mal abhauen?
Ihr soll meine Mops in Ruhe lassen.
Sondern mein Plan ist, Desktop in 4K
und Spiele in Auflösung so niedrig,
dass ich 144Hz packe.
Äh, Mr. Unlocker, den gleichen Bildschirm habe ich auch.
Dann kannst du Light Boost machen mit.
Funktioniert.
Gibt es ein extra Programm für?
Kann man machen.
Das einzige Problem bei Light Boost ist,
umso aggressiver du das stellst,
umso dunkler wird dein Bildschirm.
Was mich ziemlich nervt.
Also ich habe noch keinen deutschen Stream gesehen,
der mehr Zuschauer hat als der von Fabian.
Also der, der auch auf Deutsch streamt.
Bei Light Boost wird eigentlich nur die Hintergrundbeleuchtung abgeschaltet.
Also je nach Monitor können das auch welche,
wo es nicht dran steht.
Also dein BenQ kann das.
Wie gesagt ist der gleiche, den habe ich auch, Mr. Unlocker.
Aber letztendlich ist ja auch egal, wer da jetzt der größte ist.
Dann sagen wir halt,
dass alle glücklich sind, einer der größten in Deutschland.
Sind hier oben schon wieder Respawned?
Nee.
Das sah nämlich so aus,
weil da kann ich meine normale Rotation beibehalten.
Nee, fuck.
Nicht Respawned.
So X-Trunk.
Ja, jetzt fahren wir hier einmal hier oben durch.
Auch wizard, kletter mal rauf.
Wird das Internet langsamer,
wenn ich den Laptop an den Monitor anschließe
oder kommt mir das nur so vor?
Also was du für einen Monitor an deinen Laptop anschließt,
hat für deine Internetanbindung überhaupt keine Auswirkung.
Was soll das auch miteinander zu tun haben?
Also ich glaube, die 60 heute wird echt knapp.
Da müsste ich ja bis 4 Uhr nachts oder so grinden.
Gucken wir mal, wie viel mehr XP nach der nächsten Nacht haben.
Dauert ja noch ein bisschen.
Also bis zur nächsten Nacht hoffe ich, haben wir 93.
Meint er das geht?
Patrick, du machst Basi grind.
Ich dachte Basi lohnt sich XP-mäßig nicht.
Oder machst du für den Gürtel?
Ja, ich glaube, das meint er sogar ernst.
Hat er gestern gesagt, er spielt wieder.
Gibt es auch Bosser oder Dungeons? Gibt es, ja.
Allerdings nicht so in klassischer Form,
Dungeon-Finder und mit Gruppe in Raid.
Es gibt Bosse, das sind halt World-Bosse.
Die spawnen einmal pro Server, gleichzeitig auf jedem Server.
Das heißt, da ist es immer sehr voll.
Also wirklich immer Steve voll.
Da ruckelt es auch bei mir.
Selbst auf dem neuen Rechner jetzt.
Dungeons gibt es auch.
Allerdings auch nicht instanziert.
Wo ist eigentlich mein Pet?
Max, kannst du mal dein Gear zeigen?
Ich habe meine Awakening-Waffe noch gelb gemacht.
Mit so einem Stein.
Die hat jetzt 3 AP mehr als auf dem Bild.
Das war es aber.
Ansonsten ist das genauso, wie es da steht.
Wie snipen man denn was vom Marketplace?
Du setzt eine Notification, wann das Item reinkommt.
Das kannst du beim Marketplace-Händler machen.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, kann man Notifications auch hier setzen?
Ja.
Nice.
Moment.
Das kann ich nicht.
Unregister.
Na super, jetzt habe ich Blackstone-Powder-Register.
Ganz toll.
Beste.
Das war das aller sinnvollste jetzt ever.
Jetzt muss ich zum Marketplace das wieder rückgängig machen.
Okay, anscheinend kann man nur sich anmelden, aber nicht wieder wegmachen.
Kann man nicht Unregister hier drüber machen?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Na geil.
Okay.
Dann nicht.
Du setzt dich da rein, dass du eine Nachricht kriegst, wenn das Item ins Marketplace kommt.
Da ploppt dann unten rechts so ein Fenster auf.
Da steht dann drin, dass das Item jetzt reingesetzt wurde.
Das bedeutet, innerhalb der nächsten 10-15 Minuten erscheint dann das Item drinnen und
dann kannst du darauf beaten.
Also beaten.
Du kannst quasi draufklicken, wie ich will es haben.
Und wenn du Glück hast, kriegst du es.
Und wenn derjenige, der es kriegt, sich nicht rechtzeitig abholt, dann ist es free for all.
Hat schon wer Mini-Elefanten?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Die wo ich lese ist eine Quest in der Wüste, aber kein Schimmer.
Was, wenn das Fenster aufhaut, klick auf abbrechen?
Ah, cool.
Schön zu wissen.
Oh, das Corp Fragment, das ist echt Glück.
Da hast du gefühlt 80 Leute, oder 800 Leute, die wie verrückt ihre linke Maustasse spammen.
Linke Maustasse und Enter-Spam machen.
Das ist echt, das ist richtig Glück.
Sind Quests auch Cryton?
Also ich finde schon, dass man Quests machen auch als eine Form des Crytons sehen könnte.
Wenn ich mir das in anderen MMOs angucke, wo du quasi vom ersten Level bis zu Max Level
durch die Gebiete rennst und Blümchen sammelst und Dinger machst, finde ich, ist es schon
sehr ähnlich zu Cryton.
Wobei, nee, ich glaube, ich hab deine Frage voll falsch verstanden.
Du meinst, ob Quests in BDO quasi Grinding-Quests sind?
Gibt es unterschiedliche.
Es gibt Story-Quests, es gibt Töte 500 Nagas-Quests, im Prinzip so wie in eigentlich jedem MMO.
In allen möglichen Quests.
Aber die Quests sind so wie in jedem MMO.
Nur, dass es sich hier insofern mehr lohnt, Quests zu machen, also auch wenn du jetzt
sagen wir mal 61 bist, lohnt es sich eventuell halt in den Low-Level-Gebieten die Quests zu
machen, weil du kriegst fürs Beenden der Quests Contribution Points.
Und mit Contribution Points kannst du dann deine Nodes, kannst du in Nodes investieren,
in Trading-Cards oder in Pferdewagen oder in was auch immer.
Das heißt, Contribution Points braucht man, ich hab viel zu wenig.
Muss ich mich erstmal nach Valencia durchquesten?
Nee, nicht unbedingt.
Ich finde einmal die Haupt-Quests machen schadet nichts.
Das ist halt langweilig wie Saune, die Main-Quests.
Ich finde die BDO-Story fand ich auch echt langweilig.
Ich hab's ja nicht, also gut, ich muss sagen, ich hab's auch nicht richtig gelesen, aber
das was ich so mitgekriegt hab aus diesen Cutscenes und dem was die NPCs so erzählt
haben, war die Story echt mega langweilig.
Aber schadet nichts die Main-Quests einmal zu machen.
Dann sieht dann Black Spirit cooler aus danach und du kriegst auch ein paar Items, die, naja,
braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Manche Sachen sehen ganz gut.
Ich glaub du kriegst ein paar Black Spirit Crystals unterwegs, die ganz nett sind.
Wenn ihr die Haupt-Story dann quasi durch habt, sieht euer Black Spirit so aus.
Oder nicht, also kurz vor durch sieht er dann so aus.
Was hat's eigentlich mit dem House-Fame-Aufsicht?
So ganz durchgestiegen bin ich auch nicht, aber umso mehr High-Level-Charaktere du auf
deinem Account hast und ich weiß nicht ob Equipment auch mit reinspielt, bekommst du
täglich Geld.
Dafür, weil du halt so krass fame bist.
So und ich hab im Prinzip ja nur nen Bersi auf 56 und den Wizard hier auf fast 60 und
ich krieg jetzt 350.000 Gold am Tag.
Das ist zwar nicht viel, aber wenn man das so macht wie ich, ich spiele ja nicht wirklich
viel, wie gesagt ich war jetzt drei Monate inaktiv, aber man trotzdem täglich einloggt
kriegt man täglich die Reward-Einlog-Belohnung plus halt den House-Found.
Wobei ich frag mich gerade ob man den House-Found nicht auch kriegt, weil man nicht einloggt,
keine Ahnung.
Und dann sag mal so nach drei Monaten macht es täglich 350.000 auch aus.
Das war nicht viel, aber ein bisschen.
Wenn man durch ist sieht er wieder aus wie am Anfang, ja ich hab die Main-Quests noch
nicht ganz fertig, mir fehlen noch drei Steps.
Also ich war jetzt irgendwie, ich hab die erste Belohnung, die ersten paar Ringe als
Belohnung gekriegt und war noch beim König, hab abgegeben und hab festgestellt danach
gehts ja noch weiter.
Also das ist wohl aber eine Main-Quest, die ist nach der, ist wohl erst reingepatcht worden.
Also die richtige Main-Quest ist, hab ich fertig.
Cancel, das ist nice, dass man einfach abbrechen kann.
THX, wer auch immer mir das erzählt hat eben, solange ich da keine Benachrichtigung mehr
habe.
33 Millionen nach drei Monaten, ja das ist nicht schlecht, ich mein du machst ja nichts
dafür.
Ich finde die Standard-Steuerung ist okay, ich glaub eine der Sachen die ich umgestellt
hab ist das Auto-Run auf mittlerer Maustaste ist, also wenn ich Auto-Run machen will drück
ich die mittlere Maustaste und dann rennt er halt los.
Ansonsten überlege ich grad was ich umgestellt hab, ja genau ich hab, ich hab Awakening-Waffe
und normalen Waffewechsel hab ich auf zweiter Maustaste unten und mein Speed-Waff hab ich
auf der ersten Maustaste und auf C hab ich Freeze, was ich zwar habe und geiler Spell
ist, ich aber nie verwende.
Ach wir müssen uns ja noch die Daily-Reward-Box angucken, oh das müssen wir machen, da ist
halt geiles Item drin, das müssen wir uns jetzt schnell angucken.
Was benutzt du für Grafik-Settings, Texturen hoch, Grafikqualität low?
Ich hab's gestern hier im Streamer gespielt auf ultra-high-Settings und hier super-highend-Mode
improved alles, das sieht schon deutlich besser aus, lief auch ganz gut, aber mir ist es wichtiger
dass das quasi 144 FPS hat.
So Daily-Reward-Box, heute gab's für mich nämlich hier eine Boss-Ring, wobei ne eine
halt Rare-Ring-Box, da gucken wir jetzt mal rein was da drin ist, es gibt zur Auswahl
Ogre-Ring, Tankwärts und Layton Powerstone, ich hoffe es ist ein Ogre-Ring drin.
So, guck mal was drin ist, so Random-Lehr-Tasten-Hit, der Freund tut das nicht immer, ah fast Ogre-Ring,
allerdings das Teil ist auch genug wert, wo ist es denn?
Da, ist auch 80mWert, ist auch okay, leider kein Ogre-Ring drin, weil wenn da ein Ogre-Ring
drin gewesen wäre, hätten wir probieren können den zu enchanten, ich hab nämlich noch einen
zweiten, hätten wir gucken können ob das funktioniert, aber Pech gehabt.
Charakter-Namen, die werde ich nie spielen die anderen Charaktere, meine anderen Helden
sind rein für Fails-Deck, das ist der Negativ-Karma-Wizard zum Items-Down-Craden und das hier sind
noch Chars die ich angelegt hab zum Fails-Deck sammeln.
Ich will nicht das Wasser Grill, ich will den Feuertipp, werde ich eh nicht spielen,
ich spiele Wizard und vielleicht Bersi, aber irgendwann, fertig, außerdem kann ich mir
immer noch einen neuen Char machen.
Kann man den Wizard in verschiedene Richtungen skillen?
Ja und Nee, die normalen Skills gibt es verschiedene Sachen, also hast hier Erde,
Dinger, Feuerball, Luft, Geduld, Splitzkram, aber bei den Awakening Skills, die man hauptsächlich
verwendet bis zum Rework, gibt es beim Wizard hauptsächlich Feuereis und Wasser, also Feuer
und Wasserspels und nachdem es hier auch nicht viele Spels gibt und alle ganz gut sind, gibt
es da nicht viele Skillmöglichkeiten.
Die normalen Spells werden angeblich überarbeitet, bin ich mal gespannt was da rauskommt, weil
aktuell ist es halt so, seitdem es die Awakening Waffen gibt, benutzt halt kaum einer noch,
außer die krassen PvP Wizards, die halt so das letzte rausholen wollen, also bei normalen
Leveln benutzt halt keiner mehr die normalen Spells so richtig.
Oh langsam entschmüht ey, was ist Awakening, Awakening ist die, kriegst du mit 56, mit 56
kriegst du für diesen Waffenslot hier in der Mitte kriegst du eine neue Waffe und nur
mit dieser neuen Waffe kannst du die neuen Skills verwenden, ab Level 56, also das hat
man schnell, 56 geht mega schnell zu Level mittlerweile, machst du Awakening Quest, die
geht auch relativ fix und dann kannst du die neuen Skills specken, die neuen Skills brauchen
aber relativ viele Skillpunkte, das heißt man muss halt ordentlich grinden danach, aber
man muss die ja eh, weil mit 56 alleine kommst du ja in nicht weit.
Hast du Anti-Elasing an oder aus, wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung, aber ich guck mal, ich gucke
mal, an, na was sagst du Wizard Nerv, ich hab mir noch gar nichts angeguckt, hast du
Link, was wird denn genervt, wenn Wizard zu krass genervt wird mache ich mir OP Dark
Knight, komm doch das gleiche raus, kann ich auch mit zwei Spells alles own, oder Striker,
oder Striker, was genau wird denn genervt beim Wizard, oder was soll genervt werden,
oder gibt es noch gar nichts Konkretes und sie haben bloß gesagt, wir schauen uns den
Wizard mal an, weil das sind so Aussagen, die treffen ja Entwickler laufend, oder irgendwelche
Marketingleute.
Soll ich Witcher auf GOG oder Steam kaufen, wobei soll ich das wissen wo du das besser
kaufen sollst, kannst du ja auf GOG kaufen, dann gibt es kein DRM oder sonst was.
Jetzt kann ich dir nicht sagen, wo du das besser kaufen sollst, also ich find's aber
nicht schlecht, wenn man GOG unterstützt, zumal das Spiel in DRM frei auf GOG ist, warum
nicht.
was instant instant dann auf jail also jail ist ja das da
instant dann die gegner werden instant gestand wenn sie da drin stehen das wäre noch das
wäre noch mehr op als vorher hat mal range ist das hier muss wir mal durchlesen hast du
mal link dazu oder steht
ach so ja mal abwarten mal abwarten ich meine erzählen ja immer generell zählen alle egal
welches einmal bitte immer viel erzählen für den tag langes
ach meinst du das hier knockdown da gut die range von dem ding ist ja auch mega groß
das ist doch der knockdown oder genau ja das aufstampfen ja die range von dem ding ist
auch übertrieben groß guck mal ich kann hier stehen im endeffekt und dann noch die fast
beide packs mit 60 ist heute noch drin ich weiß nicht es könnte eng werden es könnte
echt eng werden aber ich meine wir sind locker 93 bis 94 wir sind 94 bis nacht das könnte
echt noch was werden das könnte echt noch was werden muss einfach nur ausdauernd genug
kreisel kreit machen ne genau ich habe ja mit 60 erst die erweiterung ist richtig ja ist
auch eine der gründe warum ich jetzt 60 mache weil sie alle spells auf also alle spellerweiterung
auf 60 runter gesetzt haben früher hat ja wissen teilweise noch mit hat glaube ich
den letzten spell mit 62 gekriegt was ich vollkommen utopisch war übrigens heute war
der letzte tag der overwatch season und ich glaube 31 oder 1 geht die neue season los
da werde ich placements machen auf jeden fall hier und dann mal gucken wie sehr mich
das game wieder tiltet ob ich weitermache oder nicht aber ich habe nicht mehr gespielt
außer das letzte mal hier vor zwei tagen oder so im stream ging mir viel zu sehr auf
den sack wieder das game kreinlich lieber abdo im kreis easy kreisel kreit eigentlich
müsste ich youtube videos machen anstatt kreisel kreit letzte kam am 24 oder fünf
tage ja und ich habe sogar noch eins ich müsste eigentlich nur hochladen ja du kannst
overwatch quickplay spielen wenn du dich aufregen willst zum monitor testen zockst du noch csgo
und musik so gute frage wusste hinter kommt musik da ist er der war vorhin ausgemacht als
wir uns das klo video angeschaut haben
also wenn du damit meinst ob ich es entchanted habe oder aus dem market place gekauft habe
aus dem market place habe ich sie nicht also nicht auf 3 gekauft allerdings habe ich sie
auch nicht selbst entchanted sondern der fabian also der friseur hat sie für mich entchanted
und das ohne account sharing ich habe damals sogar extra den bdo community manager gefragt
ob das ok ist wenn wir das streamen wenn ich mich einlogger mit meinem account auf seinem
rechner und erstreamt also sind wir echt auf nummer sicher gegangen damals dass da jetzt
keiner ankommt von wegen account sharing wir haben den account nicht geschert also die
zugangsdaten das ist das worum es denen hauptsächlich geht dass keiner irgendwie passwörter weiter
gibt und dann sich aufregt warum sein account weg ist
und ich muss sagen ich war überrascht wie einfach es war einen kakao community manager
zu kontaktieren hast du bei anderen games oftmals mehr probleme
gibt es irgendeine klasse die keine skills braucht also einfach drauf hauen striker
k
fünf
So, ganze Sellen, zack, guck mal wie viel Kohle wir schon wieder gefarmt haben die
letzten paar Tage.
Und im Vergleich zu den anderen Powersuchtern haben wir ja gar nicht so viel gespielt.
Dazu kommt, dass ich hier noch dieses ganze Zeug verkaufen kann, was ich hier noch im
Maul schliegen hab, sind auch noch mal 10, 15 Mille und wenn man die Seraph Necklace
noch verkauft, die 4, sind das noch mal 100 Mille oder so in dem Dreh.
Warte, wieviel ist so ein Seraph Necklace wert, guck mal ein kleines Mal, muss ich rappen?
Sekunde, nee, nein nicht ganz, 25, nein das ist nicht ganz eine Million, oder sei denn
man kriegt max preis für, dann ist es genau 100 Millionen für die 4.
Die Fame Sachen stacken sich, achso cool, das heißt man muss nicht 50.000 Mails einsammeln.
Doch, ich hab, als ich jetzt 3 Monate nicht gespielt hab, ich hab massig Mails mit Fame
Fond gehabt, Haus Fame Fond, muss ich gefühlte 5 Minuten dastehen und mir angucken, wie er
Post einsammelt.
Entsaltungskur auf Twitter am besten, natürlich nur wenn du irgendwie ein Anliegen hast, wofür
ein Community Manager zuständig ist, also jetzt nicht so nach dem Motto, was wie Hilfe
mein Charakter ist gestackt oder so, wenn du Fragen dazu hast zu deinem Stream oder irgendwie,
wenn du irgendeinen BDO Event organisieren willst, keine Ahnung, dafür sind ja Community
Manager da, nicht irgendwelche technischen Sachen zu fixen.
Man sollte die auch nicht mit irgendwas nerven, davon gibt es eh meistens schon zu wenig
und die haben schon genug zu tun.
Community Manager ist je nach Spiel ist das Dauerstress, vor allem flameen dich die ganze
Zeit irgendwelche Leute, als könntest du was dafür, ich mein klar du arbeitest bei
der Firma, aber du hast ja als Community Manager nicht wirklich nen Einfluss drauf auf Balancing
Entscheidungen zum Beispiel in nem Game, ich glaub ich hab noch nie so jemand gestressten
gesehen, wie den Call of Duty Community Manager auf der Gamescom, der war echt mitgenommen,
aber der hat es auch ernst genommen, also der hat es wirklich ernst genommen, hat es
Mühe gegeben, das hat man gemerkt, da kann man über Kot sagen, was man will, das sagt
nix über die einzelnen Leute aus, ob man das Spiel scheiße findet oder nicht, der hat
sich echt Mühe gegeben.
Und dann kommen die Leute und kopieren irgendwelche Pässe, lol, obbei da drüber ist, naja, das
ist ein anderes Thema, ups, äh, zack, zack und Feuerpad.
Auf was für ner Grafik spielst du jetzt eigentlich, äh, zeig ich dir, texture quality high, gibt's
halt sehr high, nein gibt's nicht, graphics quality low mit diesen Settings, einfach dass
ich schön 144 FPS hab, ich brauch das, und field of view hab ich jetzt auf, glaub, 60,
ich find's grad gar nicht, wo ist es denn, glaub 60, das hieß ja noch nicht auf vision
range oder zu 60, ja, and the ting goes krrrrra, papp papp papp papp papp papp papp papp papp
papp, naja, ich spiel auf low, jetzt hast du auch grad gesehen, ich spiel auf low, ich
hab so 1080 Ti und 8 700k, also sprich das beste was du aktuell für Gaming haben kannst,
und, wenn man das beste hat, muss ich überlegen, wenn man das beste hat was es aktuell für
Gaming gibt, und man BDO auf low spielt, dann kann man auch tatsächlich auf 144hz spielen,
Ansonsten ist BDO technisch jetzt ja noch nicht so ein Meisterwerk.
Es ist auf 60 gekappt, nein, es ist nicht auf 60 gekappt. Es ist nur auf, es ist nur, es hat V-Sync an und V-Sync
capped auf die Wiederholrate deines Monitors und wenn du einen 144-Hertz-Monitor dran hast, dann bei 144.
Und wahrscheinlich hast du nur einen 60-Hertz-Monitor dran, deswegen capped es bei dir auf 60. Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst auf Fullscreen stellen
und in deinem Grafikkartentreiber sagen, für das Game V-Sync aus.
Dann capped er auch nicht mehr bei 60.
Die Frage, ob man es dann natürlich viel mehr braucht, wenn man nur ein 60-Hertz-Monitor hat, haben wir dahingestellt, aber es funktioniert.
Du hast 144, das kann ich mir einschneiden. Dann kann ich mir das nicht erklären. Also ich weiß, das Game hat V-Sync an
und V-Sync ist immer gleich refresh rate des Monitors capped.
Ah, das sieht barussisch auch so.
Max, kennst du Swift, die Programmiersprache habt? Gerade war es lustig, auf Reddit dazu gelesen willst du hören.
Äh, kenn ich, das ist, das ist von, initiiert von Apple.
So irgendwann mal als Objective-C-Nachfolger gedacht.
Wobei der Kern halt bei Apple viele Sachen in Objective-C sind und auch weiter sein werden.
Was hast du denn denn Lust, fürs Gehört, erzähl.
Bam.
Pogans Alter.
Wo ist eigentlich der Fabian, frage ich mich gerade so. Da müsste doch schon daheim sein.
Dremo, hi. Ähm, ich bin mega vergesslich mittlerweile.
Wir haben uns letztens erst eine Liste angeguckt von Games die 2018 rauskommen und ich habe schon wieder alle vergessen.
Also was ich hoffe, also das einzige was mir aus dem Bauch raus einfällt von dem ich hoffe das es 2018 losgehen wird,
ist ob Camelot Unchained in die Beta-Phase gehen wird.
Da bin ich echt gespannt drauf. Vor allem weil ich da viel Kohle gebacked hab auf Kickstarter für.
Rein aus Nostalgiegründen für Dark an sich im Nachhinein betrachtet eigentlich viel zu viel und total dämlich, ja.
So viel für absolut ungewiss, aber gut, nein. Mehr gönnt sich ja sonst nichts.
Ansonsten weiß nicht. Müsste ich mal in mich gehen, ob wir da vielleicht wieder Games einfallen, die 2018 rauskommen.
Playstation-Spiele gibt es zwar Kohle. Also Last of Us 2, bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Wo ich allgemein gespannt drauf bin, ist wie sich die Switch, ich wollte gerade sagen die Wii, wie sich die Switch schlägt.
Nächstes Jahr. Nintendo hat ja große Verkaufsziele erzählt, ja, haben ja ganz groß erzählt wie viele Millionen sie verkaufen wollen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das klappt und vor allem was es für Games geben wird für die Switch.
Ob sich das wirklich gelohnt hat die Konsole zu kaufen.
Hast du eigentlich Immobilien? Also außer das Haus in dem wir wohnen hier? Nee.
Das gehört ja auch nicht mir.
Monster Hunter World, da bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf. Monster Hunter ist so eine Serie, habe ich nie großartig gespielt.
Aber Monster Hunter World soll sich explizit auch an Leute richten, die bisher mit der Game-Serie nichts zu tun hatten.
WBPD, das ist geil. Hat irgendjemand geschrieben, er hat einen Job gefunden oder er sucht einen Job als Swift-Programmierer und einer hat eine Stelle für Swift-Programmierer mit die 8 Jahre Berufserfahrung in der Programmiersprache Swift erfordern.
Man muss halt dazu wissen, Swift gibt es jetzt seit 3 Jahren.
Aber Investment-Tipps, wie gesagt, ich investiere ja nicht in Häuser, sondern in Luxus-Klos. Das ist die Zukunft, soll das so auch machen.
Damit kann man auch noch was anfangen, wenn alles den Bach runter geht.
Ah, Sibaro, das ist schön. Das ist nice. Also wenn die Switch bald geknackt ist, wäre das cool.
Und da muss ich jetzt noch dazu sagen, warum ich denke, dass das cool wäre.
Gar nicht mal, dass man da drauf irgendwelche gehackten Spiele spielen kann, dazu gehört ja noch ein bisschen mehr, ob das dann funktioniert, müssen wir mal gucken.
Und geschweige denn, dass ich irgendwelche Spiele spielen will, die Handvoll Spiele, die ich auf der Switch spielen würde, die würde ich mir auch kaufen.
Worauf ich mich freue ist, wenn die Switch geknackt ist, dass da drauf endlich mal ein bisschen mehr Software läuft.
Ich meine, die Switch kann nichts, außer, ich meine, das ist eine Konsole, die Spiele abspielt, kann die kann nichts.
Außer Spiele abspielen.
Was halt ein bisschen doof ist. Haben wir mal so einen Browser drauf, wo man was nachgucken kann.
Wäre schon ganz gut.
Dann die üblichen Sachen von Spotify und Netflix und Amazon Music und so.
Wobei das halt auch nicht auf einmal, nur weil es Homecrew gibt, auf der Switch laufen wird.
Muss man mal gucken, die sind da immer sehr erfinderisch.
Bringt das halt in so ein Klo denn wirklich. Hast du doch eben gesehen. Beste.
Was hat mich über, was mich davon überzeugt hat. Ich hab's ausprobiert und fand das geil.
Wir haben jetzt eh das komplette Haus hier, wurde ja quasi, also nicht neu gebaut, renoviert, komplett.
Also hier im ersten Stock, wo ich jetzt wohne, war ja mal ursprünglich quasi Küche und Wohnzimmer von Oma Opa.
Das heißt, da wurde eh alles neu gemacht.
Hab ich mir gedacht, ey, wenn wir jetzt schon oder wenn ich schon quasi ein neues Bad bezahlen muss,
dann was mit richtig geiler Dusche und richtig geilem Klo.
Das mit richtig geiler Dusche hat leider nicht funktioniert.
Wollte ich erst haben, ich wollte so eine Schnecken Dusche haben, falls ihr nicht wisst, was das ist.
Das ist quasi ebenerdig und sind halt gemauert, so halt wie so ein Schneckenhaus.
Also sprich, du kannst, Moment, wo bin ich jetzt hier hingelaufen? What?
Äh, ach so. Und du kannst quasi in die Dusche reinlaufen, ohne irgendwie aufmachen zu müssen und so.
Du gehst einfach in die Dusche rein, das duscht dich und läufst wieder raus.
So quasi alles ebenerdig und es saugt das Bad nicht ein und so.
Das hätte ich gerne gehabt, das war leider zu schwer für den ersten Stock.
Aber das nächste, was ich haben wollte, ist halt so ein geiles Klo.
Was mich davon überzeugt hat, ist halt, es ist saumäßig angenehm, es stinkt nichts, du musst es kaum sauber machen.
Ähm, es ist halt einfach, es sitzt sich bequem drauf.
So dürfte es jetzt, das klingt jetzt irgendwie als würde ich es in Werbung machen, aber es ist halt geil.
Also zwei Sachen, die sich wirklich gelohnt haben, da Kohle zu investieren,
ist aber unabhängig davon, guten Rechner zu kaufen und so, ja.
Also zwei, nennen wir es mal, Möbelstücke, die sich richtig gelohnt haben, da drin was zu investieren ist.
Einmal der Bürostuhl, den ich jetzt vor dem Rechner stehen habe und halte ihm das Klo.
Nö, du kannst ja den Strahl einstellen.
Ach stimmt, wir haben ja noch gar kein Stuhlkommando, können wir machen.
Können wir machen. Brauche ich aber erstmal Reflink.
Ohne Reflink geht hier nichts.
Sellout, Max Sellout.
Läuft auf dem Klo Spotify und Amazon Music.
Auf dem Klo natürlich nicht, ja, aber ich habe ein Tablet im Bad.
Darauf läuft Spotify und Amazon Music.
Und YouTube und Twitch.
Und das ist mittlerweile so schlimm, dass ich allen Ernstes unter der Dusche stehe
und durch die durchsichtige Wand von der Duschkabine mir Twitch angucke.
So geschnürt ist es mittlerweile schon, ja.
Ich habe das Tablet gegenüber von der Duschkabine, habe ich dann hingelegt auf halt so eine Kommode.
Hochkant und dann kann ich quasi aus, beim Duschen kann ich Twitch gucken.
Das ist richtig Next Level, oder Leute?
Das ist wirklich seinerzeit voraus.
Absolut Next Gen, Next Gen, Next Level.
Und das ist wirklich praktisch. Ihr wisst ja, ich gucke quasi gar kein Fernsehen.
Ich gucke im Prinzip halt nur Webzeuge. Wenn ich Filme gucken will, dann Amazon oder Netflix oder was auch immer.
Und ich gucke halt hauptsächlich Livestream und YouTube.
Und wenn irgendein, sagen wir jetzt, wenn Overwatch League läuft oder irgendein CS-Turnier oder irgendwas, was auch immer.
Musst halt trotzdem dich noch ab und zu mal duschen.
Ich habe einfach das Tablet und wird beim Duschen Twitch geguckt.
Das einzige, was mir jetzt noch fehlt, das Ganze wasserdicht, dass ich im Chat spammen kann unter der Dusche.
Ich Next Level.
Ja, wir schaffen, wir schaffen sogar noch mehr.
Ey, das wird heute was, Leute. Guck mal, es ist 19.45 Uhr.
Wir haben gleich 94 Prozent.
Und es sind noch vier Ingame-Stunden bis Nacht.
Und Nacht gibt es noch mal mehr XP.
Und dann haben wir wahrscheinlich auch noch Energie für 20 Prozent XP-Buff.
Das kriegen wir heute hin. 60 wird heute was. Also 60 ist in Reichweite, definitiv.
Ich könnte Pay2Win machen.
Ich könnte eine Golden Bell für den Channel kaufen, Pay2Win.
Wir gucken mal, wie viel Uhr es ist, wenn ich so bei 98 Prozent bin.
Dann mache ich vielleicht Pay2Win Golden Bell für den Channel.
Das stimmt, Alcorina, hast du schon recht.
Was, Max, in welcher Lohngruppe befindest du dich momentan?
Du meinst tarifvertragmäßig oder was?
Egal, was du genau meinst, ich weiß es nicht.
Und bevor das jetzt wieder für Verwirrung sorgt, ich weiß viele so simple Sachen nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viel ich im Jahr verdiene.
Es gibt Sachen, die, weiß nicht.
So Sachen, die jeder weiß, die weiß ich irgendwie nicht.
Genau wie ist das eben auch. Ich weiß es echt nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich jetzt durch die letzten Jahre YouTube habe ich ganz ordentlich auch was gespart.
Und das wirklich angenehme von zwei Einnahmequellen.
Also quasi, wie gesagt, ich gehe noch vier Tage die Woche arbeiten.
Plus halt die YouTube-Geschichte, weil ich da letztes Jahr nicht so viel mitgemacht habe.
Ich habe ja kaum was hochgeladen und war ja kaum aktiv.
Was einfach wirklich angenehm ist, wenn man zwei Einnahmequellen hat, man ist, man fühlt sich da unabhängiger.
Und man kann immer sagen, hey, wenn ich keinen Bock mehr auf das eine habe, mache ich das andere.
Und wenn ich keinen Bock auf das andere habe, mache ich das eine.
Was halt daraus resultiert ist. Du hast halt zwei Einnahmequellen, hast ein bisschen mehr Kohle.
Und im Prinzip kannst du dir einfach, wenn dir es danach ist, nach was auch immer es dir ist, kannst du dir dann holen.
Ich meine, klar, es gibt Sachen, die kann ich mir auch nicht holen.
Ich kann mir jetzt kein 200k Auto einfach so holen oder was auch immer.
Aber halt so die normalen Sachen.
Sei es jetzt Wäsche, Trockner oder neuen Fernseher oder was auch immer.
Das geht.
Und solange das geht und ich halt die Sachen nicht einzeln umdrehen muss, werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht wissen, wie viel ich im Jahr verdiene.
Ab wann hast du deinem Arbeitgeber gemeldet, dass du YouTuber bist? Das weiß der nicht.
Der weiß nicht, dass ich YouTuber bin.
Der weiß nur, dass ich eine eigene Firma habe.
Und ich quasi woanders arbeite, ohne eben Konkurrenz zu machen.
Dass ich YouTuber bin, weiß der nicht.
Also das wissen viele auf der Arbeit mittlerweile.
Ich meine, ich muss dir irgendwas erzählen, warum ich weniger arbeiten will und warum soll ich mir da irgendwas ausdenken.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe eine eigene Firma, ich mache kreative Videogestaltung, Videobearbeitung.
Das läuft halt mittlerweile ganz gut.
Irgendwie sowas habe ich erzählt, aber dass ich YouTube mache, wissen die nicht.
Ja, Sebaro habe ich und ich bin der einzige Mitarbeiter.
Deswegen meinte ich doch letztens, wo wir es irgendwie von Schulsystem und sowas hatten, dass ich schade finde, dass man den Leuten in der Schule nicht so grundlegende Sachen zeigt,
wie was muss man dann machen, um eine Firma zu künden.
Zu welchem Amt musst du, wie sieht dieser Bogen aus, den man ausfüllen muss.
Einfach, dass man das schon mal gesehen hat.
Es ist ja viel einfacher, als man denkt.
Man muss es bloß wissen.
Und auch diesen Bogen ausfüllen ist easy, weil man die Hälfte davon überhaupt nicht ausfüllen muss.
Es sei dann, du fährst zur See oder bist Förster, da musst du mehr ausfüllen.
Warum auch immer gerade diese zwei Sachen sind.
Mops abkratzen, please.
Was ist denn ein Pro-Tipp für Leute, die eventuell eine Firma gründen wollen?
Naja, nicht einfach gründen, sondern einen Anlass dazu haben.
Also einfach eine Firma bzw. ein Unternehmen anzumelden, weil man es machen will, hat ja auch keinen Sinn.
Man braucht schon eine Vorstellung, was man machen will.
Und viele Sachen kann man ja heutzutage auch, wenn es eher so eine Ein-Mann-Geschichte ist,
kannst du ja auch hobbymäßig anfangen.
Und wenn du dann merkst, es läuft ganz gut und du damit auch Geld verdienst, was du versteuern musst,
dann kannst du sagen, hey, jetzt legen wir los.
Ich glaube sogar Segel-Vlogs können gut funktionieren.
Ich glaube, die meisten Sachen können gut funktionieren, wenn die Rahmenbedingungen stimmen.
Also klar, es gibt so irgendwelche Nischen-Sachen, sowas, was ich Ameisen züchte oder keine Ahnung.
Wobei selbst, selbst, ich glaube, das meiste steht und fällt damit, dass man Sachen, wo andere Leute eben jetzt,
was andere Leute eben nicht täglich machen, dass man die interessant aufbereiten kann.
Und ich glaube, Segel-Vlogs könnte man übelst spannend machen.
Aber ihr wisst ja, Video-Editing ist jetzt nur auch nicht gerade unbedingt so mein Steckenpferd.
Meine Editing-Skills halten sich ja nur sehr in Grenzen.
Okay.
ähm
Was arbeitest du denn also ich habe eine ausbildung gemacht vor über zehn jahren jetzt
Als fachinformatiker systemintegration meiner firma bei der ich jetzt nicht mehr bin
Und
Danach habe ich eigentlich als linux admin weiter also das war quasi in den linux admin
laden wo ich gewesen bin am anfang
Deswegen kenne ich mich auch mit linux ganz gut aus und macht da öfters auch mal hier im stream was mit
Allerdings mittlerweile
Kümmer ich mich um unsere software reposts
Also sprich das darf man sich so vorstellen
Wenn eine änderung rein soll dann muss die ja irgendjemand programmieren
Der programmiert die dann und reicht die dann ein
Als als feature request quasi nicht als feature request als
Als wie nennt man das eigentlich
Als als pull request jetzt mit hier
Weil entweder mal heißt es merge request mal heißt pull request als pull request heißt es auf github
Steht dann drinnen so nach dem motto was ist denn für feature implementiert und was da was gemacht wurde blablabla
Dann gucke ich mir die änderungen an ich probiere das mal aus ob das alles so funktioniert weil ansonsten merkt man das meistens erst viel später
Wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert
Dann schnapp ich mir den typ und lasse mir erklären was er sich eigentlich gedacht hat
Oder es kann ja auch sein dass ich zwei änderungen widersprechen
Dass der eine in der anderen änderungen wieder sprechen
Dass der eine in der datei das eingetragen hat der andere das und dann passt nicht zueinander
Da muss ich mir so beide schnappen und sagen jungs werdet euch mal bitte einig was davon jetzt rein muss
Dann
Mache ich neu beta alpha version beta version release version
Hotfixes für die alten version also eigentlich versionsverwaltung
Also eigentlich versionsverwaltung
Presap just k4 just kai würde ich mal sagen just k4 just kai heißt es wahrscheinlich danke für die kohle
Twitch primes ab oder wie sagt es wie sagt das exklusiv immer primes ab
5 monats primes ab oder so ähnlich
Dumme frage was macht man als linux admin
Eigentlich den ganzen tag klar server einrichten aber das macht man doch nicht den ganzen tag was gehört da sonst noch dazu also
Das ist ein sehr weit gefasster begriff du kannst ja im prinzip fast alles machen server einrichten macht man eigentlich kaum
Man betreut eher server die da sind
Und das hängt halt ganz entscheidend davon ab in welchem laden man ist
Man kann sich entweder um datenbanken kümmern
Waren auch viele also quasi dann eben so richtung dba
Wenn du in irgendeinem hosting laden landest kümmerst du dich wahrscheinlich um irgendwelche webserver
Es ist ganz unterschiedlich was man da macht
Im prinzip kümmerst du dich um die systeme für die du zuständig bist
Ein ganz simples beispiel ist zum beispiel du löschst log dateien weil die platte voll wird
Das ist jetzt ein relativ simples beispiel
Aber sachen in dieser richtung machst du eigentlich du installierst nicht den ganzen tag neue server und wenn man den ganzen tag neue server installieren müsste
Dann hoffe ich dass der laden der eben das machen muss das nicht von hand machen
Beziehungsweise die linux admins dort nicht den ganzen tag selber von hand installieren da gibt es ja mittlerweile auch schöne automatisierungstools für
Machst du elde ab nein mach ich nicht
Du kannst auch einfach umlocken auf den anderen held, dann behältst du den xp buff der läuft der ist auf den held gebunden also sprich der läuft nicht aus wenn du umlockst
Der läuft der ist auf den held gebunden, also sprich der läuft nicht aus wenn du umlockst
Der läuft nicht aus wenn du umlockst
Die immer kommt ist wie du weißt nicht wie meine druckerpatrone wie man meine druckerpatrone wechselt warum weißt du das nicht ich denke du machst was mit computer
Es kommt ja immer du machst was mit computer das nur weil man was mit computer macht nicht automatisch heißt dass man weiß wie man die druckerpatrone wechselt bei
gerade dem modell was die oma hat aus dem kopf
Soweit reicht das bei vielen gar nicht
Du machst doch was mit computer
Oder was auch immer sehr beliebt ist und teilweise irgendwie kommt dann kommt dann einer an max mein windows startet nicht mehr oder irgendwie sowas
Oder was die sagen dann nicht mal mein windows startet nicht mehr die sagen max mein computer startet nicht mehr
Und dann bin ich mittlerweile relativ fein raus dann frage ich immer was hast du drauf
Ja halt die wissen dann gar nicht was ich meine ja halt ne
Ist halt halt mit was ausgeliefert wurde seitdem du was windows drauf ne keine ahnung von
Ist easy raus
Dann kommt einer wie ich denke du machst doch den ganzen tag sowas
Nein mach ich nicht
Mach ich nicht
Wenn ich den ganzen tag sowas machen müsste also windows notebooks fixen dann würde ich das garantiert nicht mehr machen
So wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
Genau was hast du denn für einen computer einen weißen ja so antworten kriegst du dann
Was steht denn da oben
Ja und dann gibt es tatsächlich leute die sagen dann ja ich hab da irgendwie
Keine ahnung bild von meinem enkel über monitor hängen ne ne so war das nicht gemeint
Aber glücklicherweise im support arbeiten hätte ich echt keinen bock drauf
Zum end user support da hätte ich echt keinen bock drauf
Wie lange hast du ungefähr für deinen gear gebraucht ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen aber nicht lange
Wie gesagt ich habe jetzt auch wieder drei monate nicht gespielt hat ja mehr oder weniger bis auf den ring alles schon
Paar wochen muss man den friseur fragen er weiß das oder müssen wir mal den farben fragen da hat das weiß das genauer
Paar wochen halt übelst übelst übelst random rng glück
Und ich habe ja vorher schon in versie gespielt und afk geangelt und sowas
Also ich hatte ein bisschen bisschen crafting material und in game gold allerdings jetzt auch keine keine milliarde oder so irgendwie
Keine ahnung 250 mille und masken schuhe und dim tree armor habe ich ja schon gezogen aus der box
Und der quest reward mit dem bersi noch als ich den mal gespielt habe
Also insgesamt keine ahnung zwei drei monate oder so mit enchanten und crying und allem
Also nicht spielzeit zwei drei monate sondern rl zeit mit normal spielen
Also nicht lange ist übelst glück deswegen sage ich doch ich bin der best gegierte noob in bdo
Nicht selber geappt appen lassen
Ich habe mich beim fabian eingeloggt mit meinem account und er hat für mich entchanted weil er einfach deutlich mehr game knowledge hat als ich
Leute wir werden wir haben 95 vor der nacht 60 ist greifbar
Ligeria noch viel mehr lag also das mega lag war ja masken schuss aus der quest belohnung
So dim tree armor aus der aus der daily oder aus der aus der reward box zu weiss ich wann das war
Ostern oder so kann ich immer war auch mega lag aber was fast noch übertriebener war ist natürlich
Den ganzen scheiß hier aus dem aha gesniped na ja aus dem aha gesniped habe ich jetzt nicht anlegt
Wl ja rum scheiß helmen aus dem aha gesniped big aus dem aha gesniped kutum aus dem aha gesniped zacker aus dem aha gesniped
Btf das einzige was ich bisher noch nicht gesniped habe ist meine dande aber die kann ich mir eh nächste
Nächste woche oder nächste nächsten 14 tage holen weil ich genug siegel habe easy life richtig easy life
60 ist greifbar heute sage es euch leute 60 ist drin vor allem wenn es gleich noch nacht ist
und es noch mal extra xp gibt
besser
Elegere und du hast glaube ich du hast glaube ich beim night vendor hast du glaube ich hast du kannst du
nicht einmal auf zurückhalten drücken und hast dann irgendwie 20 minuten zeit oder so noch ein bisschen
Kohle locker zu machen
so wir müssen jetzt gleich noch mal gut abgeben
bf fragen unterstützt du meine theorie system d wird mit wird was moment system d wird mitunter so gehasst
weil es den admins viel arbeit wegnimmt service dependencies werden automatisch glaube ich nicht
system d wird glaube ich gehasst weil es an vielen stellen bisschen magic ist und einige sachen
ersetzt dies ja schon gibt und quasi nach baut oder noch mal implementiert oder so
ich bin prinzipiell nicht gegen system d
warum man allerdings basis sind die also es gibt halt sachen die ich nicht so ganz verstehe
ehrlich gesagt warum braucht man ein netzwerk management modul und den eigenen dhcp und einen
dns wozu das gibt es auch schon tausendfach
was ist mit gnome gnome ist kacke
wer ist diese katze meine katze katze fps auch wenn sie nicht mehr lebt das trotzdem eine katze
gewesen welche distribution nutzt du beruflich ich nutze beruflich die kleider distribution
meinst du meinst jetzt auf den servan oder meinst du auf auf meinem arbeits notebook also
auf meinem arbeits notebook verwende ich das gleiche wie ich daheim auch verwende man
jaro mit i3 wm und auf den servan hauptsächlich red hat
und ich finde man jaro mit i3 ist die beste arbeitsumgebung die es gibt wenn man auf einen
nennen wir es mal tastatur fokussierten workflow steht also da wird nicht viel geklickt wird
die mehr oder weniger alles über tastatur bedient außer der browser
der parieren gibt es eine max fps gilde nein gibt es nicht sehe ich auch keinen sinn drin
ich bin in der gleichen gilde wie der frisör quasi schon seit ich spiele und mit den gilden
geschehen haben wir beide beide nicht viel zu tun wir sind im prinzip einfach ganz normale
member und auch da
ist ja eigentlich lange btf aus dem stellst du irgendeinen typ lang ja lassen wir den mal
normales bot ist hier unten da flitzt er der kleine wissert düster rum guck mal leute
wir haben vielleicht sogar 96 prozent bis zur nacht nach dauert er noch zwei in-game
stunden bis nacht vor welcher nacht ich rede da kommt man hier oben rechts ist ja urzeit
anzeige also in-game urzeit anzeige und ab 10 Uhr abends gilt das quasi als nacht nachts
machen die monster mehr schaden geben allerdings auch mehr exp das heißt nachts fangen alle
mal an zu kreiten die nicht eh schon kreiten wenn sie kreiten müssen
anzeigen
Das wäre toll was mit 60, ich hab's im Urin!
Na auf Wizard, glätt da hoch!
Weißt du, der Port hat sich über 20 Wände drüber, aber da kommt er nicht hoch.
Hallo Kios!
Äh, ich sollte vielleicht auf den Bildschirm gucken, dann würd ich auch, wo sind die Mops hin?
Dann würd ich vielleicht noch nicht gegen den Felsen rennen.
Deswegen mag ich Wizard grind, ich kann quasi permanent chat gucken und muss nabends immer
paar Spells drücken, easy clap in GG Eats.
Das einzige was ich besser finde zu seiner Prime Zeit war die Upload 2, aber das ist
ja nur schon lange drüber hinweg, aber alles in allem Pass of Exile ist das beste in der
Richtung.
Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, sind da glaub ich sogar Leute dabei, die an Diablo 2 dabei
gewesen sind.
Pass of Exile ist das was die Leute sich von Diablo 3 gewünscht haben und was grade witzig
ist, Pass of Exile war vor Diablo 3 raus und hat heute wahrscheinlich, ja ich weiß es
nicht, aber ich geh mal von aus sogar mehr Spieler, ich hoffe mal für Pass of Exile
viel viel mehr Spieler als Diablo 3, weil es einfach das deutlich bessere Game ist.
Für alle die auf sowas stehen, wenn man so auf Action RPG, Hack'n'Slay steht, man kommt
nicht an Pass of Exile vorbei, wenn man das als Multiplayer spielen will, Singleplayer
mags da vielleicht noch die ein oder anderen Sachen geben, die auch mal ganz nett sind,
aber langzeitmäßig Pass of Exile ist das beste.
Äh, was ist mit dem Bob los?
Spielst du ab und zu noch CSGO, vielleicht auch im Stream, nein, ich spiele kein CSGO
mehr.
Was ist denn das da, oh, das wollen wir nicht, dass es uns angreift, das wollen wir nicht,
dass es uns angreift, wir wollen nicht, dass es uns angreift, nein, wir wollen nicht, dass
es uns angreift, jetzt gehts wieder, muss ich mir aufmerken, da steht ein Boss rum,
mitten auf dem Feld, dass ich den nicht im Einfach des Gefechts jetzt hitte, weil ich
im Chat gucke und hier einfach geradeaus renne und Spells drücke, 97, Pass of Exile für
Anfänger ist auch gut, ich glaube du wirst kein aktuelles Hack'n'Slay finden, was so
vielfältig ist wie Pass of Exile und so gute Guides und alles hat, das ist das beste, es
ist auch das einzige was es gibt ehrlich gesagt, Diablo 3 ist der Witz, hat mit dem eigentlichen
Gedanke, wie es, naja wie das Diablo 2 etabliert hat, damals nichts mehr zu tun, Pass of Exile
ist finde ich das einzige was es überhaupt gibt und gleichzeitig auch noch das beste,
was es geben kann, es gibt eigentlich nichts woran du da groß merken kannst und an Pass
of Exile finde ich sieht man auch ganz gut, dass sich Qualität durchsetzt, Pass of Exile
kostet nichts, kann man kostenlos spielen, die Microtransactions die es gibt sind rein
kosmetisch und das einzige was man sich halt nach einer Weile kauft sind noch ein bisschen
mehr Truhenplatz und die Qualität setzt sich durch, das ist seit Release wurde das
Game kontinuierlich erweitert, immer weiter verbessert, immer neue Sachen hinzugefügt
und Fehler behoben und alles und Pass of Exile war am Anfang halt einfach nur da, wurde
ein bisschen gespielt und mittlerweile ist es hoffe ich mal auch finanziell ein riesen
Erfolg, aber für Spieler und wie viele das spielen definitiv, aber ich gehe mal davon
aus Pass of Exile lohnt sich finanziell für die Firma auch, weil da gab es ja erst letztens
wieder neuen Content und neuen Content produziert sich ja auch nicht einfach umsonst.
Was sagst du zur Preispolitik von Apple, ich mein Apple hat sogar gesagt, dass sie das
iPhone X extra teuer machen damit sich das nicht jeder leisten kann, die Preispolitik
von Apple ist halt teuer, ne also die Preispolitik, was soll ich dazu sagen, die Preispolitik
von Apple ist halt nicht unbedingt, dass es rein vom Geräte gerechtfertigt ist, dass
das Ding so viel kostet, aber die wollen halt in den Leuten das Gefühl auslösen sie haben
irgendwas exklusives was sie ja nicht haben, damit sich überlegt wie viele Leute ein iPhone
haben, ist ja Schwachsinn, ist nichts exklusives dran, exklusiv Geld für Apple ja, aber dadurch
dass es so teuer ist fühlen sich halt viele Apple Leute geil, wenn sie es sich gekauft
haben, warum auch immer, ich muss sagen ich finde iOS nicht schlecht, es ist halt teuer,
das kann man nicht wegdiskutieren die Apple Dinger, ich habe auch ein iPhone 6 übrigens,
also nicht so, dass ich es nicht ausprobieren würde, nicht benutzen würde und die Diskussion
die es da immer gibt, Android, Apple, ich meine, das ist eigentlich nichts was man großartig
diskutieren müsste, weil du kannst mit allem, also mit beiden Systemen das machen, alles
machen was nur der 0-15-Anwender machen will, wenn du mehr machen möchtest ist es mit Android
deutlich einfacher da in den Tiefen rum zu basteln und zu frickeln und du kannst auch
an viel mehr Sachen was ändern unter Android, was jetzt Betriebssystem mäßig ist, unter
iOS ist es halt so entweder du bist ein Apple Produkt, dann darfst du mehr als andere oder
darfst du es halt nicht, dafür ist iOS konsistenter und ich glaube das ist eigentlich auch nichts
wo man großartig drüber diskutieren muss, wenn ich mir schon angucke, ich habe mir
eine Android Tablet, ich habe ja meiner Mutter eine Android Tablet geschenkt zu Weihnachten
und wenn ich mir angucke, wie sehr Asus das Standard Android zugesaut hat mit ihrem eigenen
UI, ihrer eigenen Software, mit ihrer eigenen Software die halt nicht nur Apps sind, sondern
auch System-Sachen austauscht, also System-Settings, Bildschirme ausgetauscht haben und, wie nennt
sich das, nicht Desktop, die Startzeiten sind halt ver-Asusifiziert und sogar die Uhr braucht
mehr Platz, weil es die Asus-Uhr ist und nicht die Standard-Android-Uhr, die sie irgendwie
ausgeplandet haben und was auch immer, also das ist halt eklig, das geht halt so unter
iOS nicht, unter iOS bist du eine App und du darfst in deine App so ziemlich alles machen,
allerdings sonst nirgendswo was, das hat natürlich auch seine Nachteile, ich meine Filesystem-Zugriff
und sowas ist unter Android natürlich viel einfacher oder von einer Anwendung auf die
andere Anwendung zugreifen, das geht ja unter iOS nicht, also datalsystemmäßig, das funktioniert
nicht, das einzige was du unter iOS machen kannst ist, du kannst die eine Anwendung öffnen
und dann sagen, wenn es die Anwendung unterstützt, öffne diesen Inhalt von dir in einer anderen
Anwendung, also iOS ist alles in allem, finde ich, benutzerbedienungsmäßig deutlich konsistenter
als das Android ist, dafür kannst du einfach mit Android individueller was machen, das
finde ich sind auch so die größten zwei Unterschiede, für den 0815 Casual Noob, der das benutzt,
kannst du beides benutzen, macht einen überhaupt keinen Unterschied, wenn du nur Standards
Sachen machen willst, Software gibt es auch das meiste unter beiden Systemen, so wie Asus
dieses Tablet infiziert hat mit Asus Zeug, wäre halt unter iOS nicht möglich gewesen,
erstens mal gibt es keine iPhones von Asus, das ist schonmal das erste, aber selbst wenn
es das geben sollte, du kannst halt nicht viel machen, du hast halt das Betriebssystem,
das ist von Apple und bist du nicht in einer Anwendung von Apple, die eine Sonderrolle
hat, darfst du in deiner Anwendung machen was du willst und ansonsten hast du halt die Finger
vom Betriebssystem zu lassen bzw. hast du gar keinen Zugriff drauf, fertig, so muss
das auch sein, deswegen ist das halt relativ konsistent und dass das iPhone X jetzt so
teuer ist, das finde ich richtig beknackt, das war ja so die zweite Frage von dir, Eternal
Lit, ich hätte auch einen Custom Rom drauf gemacht, aber es gibt für das Asus Ding keinen,
ich habe jetzt halt einfach alles deinstalliert bzw. deaktiviert, bis auf die Sachen die halt
nicht zu deinstallieren oder zu deaktivieren gehen, ich habe euch auch letztens das Video
gezeigt von der Performance Optimierungs App, könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern, so
eine Scheiße kennt man normalerweise nur unter Windows als vorinstallierte Kacksoftware, aber
nein Asus liefert sowas halt mit aus, vorletzten Stream gezeigt und auf Twitter gepostet,
das meiste hast du wahrscheinlich gesehen, dieses komische Optimierungstool was da dabei
ist, was einfach nur dummes Zeug anzeigt, richtig Skamars die App einfach nur, das Stream
dürfte immer noch, ja und guck mal oben links hin, wir haben 96% bis Nacht.
Ja.
Ich muss jetzt mal ans Discord gucken, ob der Fabian irgendwas geschrieben hat oder so.
17 Uhr hat er was geschrieben, seitdem ist er afk.
Da kann er da nichts machen. Wenn der EL-Stels zu stark ist, kannst du dich nicht dagegen wehren.
So wie ich ihn kenne, wollte er nicht der EL-Stelsen. Wurde wahrscheinlich dazu gezwungen, bin ich jetzt hier gelandet.
Hier sind wieder keine Mobs. Ich gehe einfach wieder zurück. Der Spot da vorne war doch eigentlich ganz gut, da war kein Mensch.
Es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund, warum du unbedingt von Windows das Apple-Datei-System lesen musst und umgedreht.
Oder? Fällt jetzt da keiner ein. Höchstens doch, wenn du Dualboot machst. Ja, wenn du Dualboot machst, dann kannst du Probleme geben.
Was ich meine ist, wenn du jetzt irgendwelche Dateien freigeben willst bei dir im Netz, dann machst du das hier über das Netzwerk und nicht irgendwie, weil du Festsplatten umbaust oder so.
Na USB-Sticks, da nimmst du irgendwas, was beides lesen kann. Zuerst nimmst du da FAT oder XFAT oder was weiß ich.
Hast du eigentlich ein iPhone oder ein Android-Phone? Ich habe ein iPhone. Ich habe ein iPhone und drei Android-Tablets. Also ich habe da ganz guten Einblick, wie die unterschiedlichen Systeme sind.
Deswegen denke ich gar nicht auch genau das dazu sagen, was ich eben dazu gesagt habe, wo ich die Unterschiede sehe.
Boah, ich sitze den ganzen Tag hier schon vom Rechner und grinde. Oh, der Rücken weh. Muss man wieder anders hinhocken.
Nee, da gibt es nicht nur FAT32, nee, nee. Boy, ist bald der Abo-Button da. Nee, ich habe mich immer noch nicht darum gekümmert.
Wenn du mich abonnieren willst, kannst du mir fünf Euro donieren. Oder wäre das der Prime-Sub gewesen?
Ich lame immer so nach dem Motto, ich kümmere mich nicht um den Abo-Button, das hat für mich keine Priorität, blablabla.
Nur mal so gefragt an die Leute hier. Mal angenommen, ich hätte einen Abo-Button. Wer würde mir seinen Prime-Sub geben?
WTF? Okay, das sind ja doch ganz schön viele. Dann gibt es neben YouTube-Money demnächst ja auch noch Twitch-Money.
Was soll ich da machen? Soll ich mir noch ein Klo kaufen? Ja gut, wir haben ein zweites Bad, da muss auch noch eins rein.
WTF? Okay, Leute, ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich dachte nicht, dass es so viele sind.
Moment, ich blick gerade nicht durch, wo sind wir denn? Vielleicht sollte ich doch mal Twitch kontaktieren.
Vielleicht sollte ich doch mal Twitch kontaktieren. Ich habe jetzt echt nicht damit gerechnet, dass es so viele sind.
Ich meine, das ist schon geil.
Also wenn ich einen Sub-Button habe, dann gibt es natürlich auch eine Sub-Notification. Ich habe heute Morgen mit dem Tippy-Stream-Alert-Creator rumgespielt.
Das ist nicht nur so ein Vogel, der abgeht, wie ich jetzt gerade habe für Follow-Untonation, sondern mehr.
Jeder, der aufgepasst hat, oder die meisten, die aufgepasst haben, sollten mittlerweile eigentlich wissen, wie ich ausschaue.
Es gab ja schon genug Spiegelungen und vor allem Videos, wo ich mal im Hintergrund herumgelaufen bin und so.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe mir eh überlegt, ob ich nicht mal ein älteres Foto zeigen soll.
Ich meine, ich sehe immer noch im Prinzip so aus, plus dass ich jetzt einen Bart habe und 20 Kilo mehr wiege als auf dem Bild.
Weil es einfach so ein richtig schönes, schleimiges Foto ist. So von der Frisur, von dem Kehl in den Haaren.
Richtiges Business-Outfit. Fehlt eigentlich bloß noch der Anzug. Es ist nur Hemd auf dem Foto.
Aber was für eins. Da, wo du noch geschwommen bist, nee, das war schon danach das Foto. Die Zeit, wo ich noch viel geschwommen bin, da war ich strich in der Landschaft quasi.
Warum gehe ich eigentlich immer wieder zurück zu diesem Spot? Das Spot ist kacke, haben wir doch jetzt schon gesehen.
Und gleich ist Nacht. Da musste Hardcore-Grind gestartet werden. Sicher, dass du ein Foto mit entfüllst.
Das Foto kann ich zeigen. Aber das mache ich irgendwann mal, also jetzt nicht morgen oder so.
Das kann ich zeigen. Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt mittlerweile, ich sehe ja zwar noch so aus, allerdings ein paar Jahre älter und mit mehr grauen Haaren und Bart und so.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass auf Grundlage dieses Fotos dann Leute kommen und sagen in der Bahn, hey Max, bist du es?
Was ja immer noch der Hauptgrund ist, warum ich da keinen Bock drauf habe.
Ich habe keinen Bock drauf, dass ich morgens in der Bahn hocke um 6 und am Pennen bin oder sonst wo und mich irgendwie Leute erkennen oder so.
Oder wenn ich auf der Arbeit irgendwie Mittagessen bin mit ein paar Kollegen, da habe ich keinen Bock, dass dann irgendjemand kommt oder so.
Ich weiß ja gar nicht, was ich da sagen soll. Ich glaube nicht, dass es nervig wäre in dem Sinn.
Aber das wäre mir irgendwie peinlich, weil ich da nicht wüsste, was ich sagen soll.
Oh fuck, fuck, fuck. Max, was machst du da?
Ich habe gerade den Boss angegriffen. Alter, lull.
Du musst aufpassen. Ist der Boss weg?
Ja, wenn ich da mal Mittagessen irgendwie angesprochen werde, dann kriegen das auch noch mehr Leute mit, dass ich irgendwas im Internet videotechnisch mache als vielleicht Leute, von denen ich gar nicht will auf der Arbeit, dass sie es mitkriegen und so.
Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund. Wenn ich nicht arbeiten würde, wo ich nicht vorhabe aufzuhören, dann würde ich jetzt hier wahrscheinlich mit Facecam da hocken.
Von Bud Spencer. Klar, ganz so schlimm ist es nicht. Wobei, also ich meine, es gibt Schlimmeres, als zu sein wie Bud Spencer, oder?
Kannst du eine Maske in der Bart rein? Das ist auch überhaupt nicht auffällig, ne?
Warum liegt da Stroh? Warum hast du eine Maske an? Das ist dann der erste Witz, der kommt in der Bart.
Ein Wikinger Bart? Nein, eigentlich habe ich so den typischen Gordon Freeman Bart. Oder wie der Fabian mir mal erklärt hat, einen Schwulen Bart. Was ich nicht wusste.
Kappa Pride Bart.
So 96, 96, 2 vor Nacht ungefähr. Ich sage euch Leute, heute ist noch 60 drin. Kein Ding, heute ist noch 60 drin.
Wie geht es dem Fabian denn? Ich sage euch, da musste ich mal ganz schnell wegstellen. Als letztes Mal beim Fabian war, kamen schon gleich die ersten an den Start.
Hey Friseur, bist du es? Habe ich mich ganz unauffällig weggestellt um die Ecke. Ich frage mich halt, wenn es beim Fabian schon so ist.
Im Vergleich zu großen Channels ist es ja nicht viel, was er an Zuschauern hat und Leute, die ihn kennen. Also wenn jetzt mal da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir einfach mal Unge oder so. Der kann doch eigentlich gar nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen.
Ich frage mich, wie das sein muss.
Klatze habe ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht warum das einige denken. Beim Kaboom haben ja auch immer alle gedacht, er hat eine Klatze. Vielleicht sieht es in den Spiegelungen so aus oder so.
Jetzt ist Nacht. Jetzt sind alle Mops weg oder was? WTF?
Okay, hier muss ich aufpassen, hier ist der Boss wieder.
Der Grind ist real, ja. Der ist sehr real der Grind.
Oh, ich kann Black Spirit noch holen. Ich habe schon wieder Buff Food vergessen. Wo habe ich jetzt aufgehört? Buff Food, XP, ne?
So, Black Spirit, XP noch. Jetzt geht es ab.
Der hat keine Refuse gemacht. Der hat Guides gemacht.
Auf kleiner Visor bläht er da drüber.
Hast du einen Grund, Tommy, warum du Opera verwendest? Ich habe den Browser eigentlich verbannt von meinem Rechner, seit es an irgendwelche Chinesen verkauft wurde, das Ding.
Ich benutze jetzt Vivaldi von dem ehemaligen Opera-Chef.
Ja, hast recht. Hast recht, Mr. Unlocker. Ja, das war schon so ein bisschen Refuse-mäßig. Aber hauptsächlich hat der einen Guides gemacht.
Okay, Opera auf Android. Ja, da gibt es ja Vivaldi nicht.
Opera Mini habe ich auch auf dem iPhone drauf.
Okay. Interessant, wie gesagt, ich kenne nicht viele, die Opera verwenden. Was geht mit dem Wizard ab? Warum hat er sich jetzt gerade so nach vorne geworbt?
Desert-Naga-Combat-Monker-S ist da. Genau gesehen.
Da ist ein... Piss dich, Alde. Pass auf, die überholen wir jetzt.
Jetzt rennen wir einfach wieder zurück zum alten Spot. Gibt kein better Twitch-TV für Opera? Laufen da nicht die Chrome-Addons drauf?
Ah, schön viele Mobster hier. Fashion.
Easy Win.
Discord. Discord ist nicht der neueste Shit, aber ist schwer angesagt. Also TS, Skype und das ganze Zeug sind aus. Heutzutage verwendet man Discord. Also wenn man cool sein will, dann verwendet man Discord.
Wo wir gerade bei Chrome sind? Ich glaube, ich habe es schon 500 Mal gesagt, gefühlt. Weil ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wusste nicht, ob ihr schon wisst, so nach dem Motto.
Piss dich, Alde. Das Discord, also die Discord-Desktop-Anwendung, das ist quasi ein Chrome, bloß in einem eigenen Fenster.
In Chrome und Node.js im eigenen Fenster. Und dass deswegen Discord auch gleich mal 500 MB RAM braucht.
Aber Discord gleichzeitig die einzige Anwendung ist, von wo ich das okay finde. Genau, neu. Deswegen kann man auch CSS editieren in Discord.
Das ist einfach eine ganz normale JavaScript-Anwendung im Browser. Auch wenn man die lokale Desktop-Anwendung verwendet.
Die sollen sich bei Alde verpissen hier. Was ist hier los?
Ja, das heißt, wir spielen wieder Overwatch zur Season-Start.
Moment, sollten hier nicht eigentlich noch mehr Mops sein? Ach, da oben waren die Mops, genau.
Ich muss jetzt maximale XP ausnutzen hier nachts.
Ich lese gleich Chat.
Genau, Beatport. Genau deswegen finde ich es auch okay, dass Discord Elektronen-Anwendung ist.
Allerdings, für die 25. Notiz-App ist es Overkill.
Keiner möchte Cross-Plattform-Audio-Video selbst programmieren. Keiner.
Erstens weiß, was es schon gibt und zweitens, weil das scheiße ist.
Wo sind Mops? Ich brauche Mops. Unten sind Mops.
Ja, echt? Dann müssen wir wieder Overwatch spielen.
Season-Start. Season-Start ist ja glaube ich 31. oder war es der erste? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Zumindest die Placements machen wir. Danach gucken wir mal.
Ups, der ist fast rückständig da.
Wie voll es hier ist. Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich muss mich gerade auf Monster Cryen konzentrieren.
Die Nacht und den Black Spirit XP Boost will ich richtig ausnutzen.
Kommt mal wir haben schon 97. 97 gleich.
Wie gesagt, ich lese gleich den Rest.
Ja Tommy, demnächst programmieren wir was wieder im Stream. Und zwar einen Food-Timer für BDO.
Der anzeigt wann man welches Buff-Food nehmen muss. Weil ich mich immer wieder verdrücke.
Oh wie treff ich bin überladen, klar. Jetzt keine Zeit. Keine Zeit irgendwie abgeben zu gehen.
Keine Zeit.
Ich muss wegschmeißen. So jetzt haben wir wieder Platz.
Jetzt wird alles tot. So viele Leute hier. Ich brauche doch XP.
Oh fuck. Wieder den Boss gepult.
So hier dazwischen ist aber glaube ich keiner so richtig.
Zwischen den beiden Spots. Hier sind ja auch genug Mobs. Da kreisen wir einfach uns jetzt hier einen ab.
Ja gut, da habe ich jetzt schon seit ein paar Monaten nichts mehr gemacht. Aber das will ich auch noch fertig machen.
Vor allem muss ich in dem einen Comment mal diesen Int-Cast-Wahnsinn, den ich da aus Gag im Stream eingebaut habe, rausnehmen.
Wenn das hier irgendjemand sieht, denkt er noch ich meine das ernst.
Bam.
Bis dann Erx.
7.09, es geht ab. Kommt mal an die Nacht, die geht noch eine Weile.
Jetzt dreht er auf der Wubbler.
Jetzt dreht er Wubbler auf.
Hier unten dürfte jetzt wieder Respawn sein, oder?
Moment, wo sind wir lang gekommen? Piss dich, Alter.
60 Level ist Max, ne ne, Max Level gibt es nicht.
Also 62 ist erreichbar. Zwar mit Wahnsinns-Krind, aber erreichbar.
Alles da drüber braucht einfach zu lange.
Ich glaube in Korea ist der höchste 63 oder wie war das?
60 reicht.
So als erst mal als Ziel.
Dann kriegt man alle Spells, die man so braucht.
60 ist quasi das neue 50.
Moment, wir sind zu schnell, die Mops sind noch nicht wieder Respawn.
Hier, hier, Respawned jetzt.
Sind sie schon wieder.
Zu wenig Mops, zu viele Spieler, guckt euch das mal an.
Und es ist Nacht.
Da ist ja schon wieder der nächste Typ.
Naja, bei mir hängt kein Stream. Ich habe die Vorschau an, da hängt nichts.
Wie BDO manchmal ruckelt, ne.
Vielleicht ist hier oben der Spot frei.
Einmal Pat.
Ja, weil Korea das Gefühl habe ich auch, da sind auf einmal viel mehr Leute da als noch vor ein paar Stunden.
Da vorne ist schon wieder der nächste.
Hier ist auch alles weg.
Das ist halt BDO Max Punch.
Das ist halt BDO.
BDO läuft nicht gut.
BDO ist halt ziemlich kacke, von der technischen Seite aus, so Performance-mäßig.
Ich wechsle jetzt einfach Channel.
Wie findet ihr eigentlich das Bild von der Katze?
Was für ein Bild von der Katze gefällt euch besser?
Das aktuelle oder das, was wir gestern hatten, wo sie auf der Decke liegt?
Ich finde, das aktuelle sieht eher so Porträt-mäßig aus.
Das ist ja so Denker-Katze quasi.
Denker-Katze passt zu den Themen heute.
Ja, das stimmt.
Heute, was wir heute schon wieder alles für Zeug erzählt haben, von schwarzen Löchern zu ach, was weiß ich alles.
Welche Fragen man Außerirdischen stellen würde, war ja alles dabei.
Hier ist keiner.
Das ist halt das Schöne am Wizardcrime.
Du kannst dastehen, drückst drei Spells, alles tot, gehst zum nächsten Pack.
Keine Verrenkung, keine Tastenkombination.
Einfach Stelle stehen, Bam, Attack.
Und wenn noch was steht, den da und gut ist.
Schon wieder Loot wegschmeißen.
Das war besonders optimiert in der Casting-Animation jetzt.
Geht 144 Hertz mit einem Laptop ohne Display-Port über DVI.
Eventuell, wenn das der Notebook hat, Dual-Dingsbums-DVI oder wie das genau hieß.
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
HDMI geht glaube ich auch ab HDMI 2.
Spielst du auch PvP, dafür sind Zauberer immer schlecht.
Wizard ist in dem Game eine der besten PvP-Klassen.
Und das Geile ist, sowohl im Massen-PvP oder bei Belagerung, als auch tatsächlich im Duell.
Ich hab selbst halt für möglich gehalten, aber eine der letzten One-on-One-Turniere hat ein Wizard gewonnen.
Nein, Tommy, ich glaub, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Hab ich so das Gefühl.
Außer gibst du 300 Euro für Adapter oder so aus.
Also am besten ist, du hast Display-Port oder ich glaube, HDMI 2.
Mit HDMI 2 geht es auch.
Duellmäßig gibt es hier auch Ninja und so, die sollen wohl auch ziemlich gut sein.
Aber ich glaube, die OP-este One-on-One-Klasse zurzeit ist Valkyrie.
Was man so an offiziellen Forum liest oder auf Reddit besser gesagt.
Valkyrie müsste so zurzeit mit die OP-este One-on-One-Klasse sein, aber für sonst wenig zu gebrauchen.
Aber hier spricht jetzt nicht der Profi, sondern der Reddit-Leser und wie gesagt der best ausgerüstete Noob in BDO.
Und für 15 Minuten Bell, easy. Kann ich schon wieder wechseln?
Moment, ich kann doch nicht wieder wechseln.
Naja, egal. Pech gehabt.
Außerdem ist da wahrscheinlich eh voll. Da cry nicht lieber die Nacht hier noch in Ruhe.
Ist grad schön leer.
Achso, Sybaro, brauchst du gar kein HDMI 2?
Okay, aber HDMI 2 kannst du dann auf jeden Fall.
Wo sehe ich, was ich für HDMI habe, guck ins Handbuch von deiner Grafikkarte.
Oder beziehungsweise auf die Webseite vom Hersteller, wo es das halt gibt, die Details zu dem Laptop.
Würdest du den ganzen Cryen auch machen, wenn du jetzt nicht mit dem Chat labern kannst?
Also Chat labern macht es natürlich interessanter.
Aber ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch so machen, vielleicht jetzt nicht so übertrieben intensiv wie jetzt.
Aber im Allgemeinen muss es ja nicht oft machen. Ich crye jetzt bis 16 und dann ist gut.
Dann werde ich mir den Spot hier auch die nächsten zwei Monate immer angucken.
Machen wir das E60 das Beste.
Ich hoffe, ich habe überhaupt genug Skill Points, um dann alles auszuspecken.
Ganz eilig, dass ich keinen Pet habe.
Deswegen sterben die Mops nicht.
Hier ist schön leer, hier ist keine Sau.
Was willst du machen, wenn du in 60 bist, mit dem Fabian im neuen Gebiet rumstellst?
Und seinen Ranger ein bisschen Wizard carryen.
Wobei bald ist er ja OP mit einem der nächsten Patches, dann kann er mich wieder carryen.
Was machst du? Nach dem Cryen ist vor dem Cryen. Ich meine, das ist BDO.
Dass es in WoW ist, nach dem Raid, auch vor dem Raid.
Oder ich werde zum krassen Liveskiller und Angler.
Dann machen wir Anglestream.
Dann fahre ich dann oben aufs Meer, suche mir einen Fisch-Hotspot und angle.
Und ihr könnt bald zugucken.
Was bestimmt sehr spannend ist.
Wenn ich dann 5 Stunden Tasten drücke und Quicktime-Events mache.
Ey, das Geruckel von dem Game BDO, oh man.
Das liegt aber auch nicht an meinem Rechner, weil es sind immer die gleichen Stellen in dem Geruckel.
Das ist halt BDO.
100 Viewer, easy.
Schon die ganze Zeit in dem Dreh, ne?
Und das Geile ist, seitdem ich jetzt aktiver streame hier.
Hab ich quasi kontinuierlich Viewer, also Durchschnitt, ne?
Viewer, Zuwachs.
Und wir liegen jetzt eigentlich immer, und das ohne Ankündigung wohlgemerkt.
Und das ist das worum es mir ja geht.
Ich mache keine Ankündigung zurzeit auf Twitter oder YouTube oder sonst was.
Ich meine, mit Ankündigung früher hatten wir immer auch easy, 100, 130, 40, 50, je nachdem.
Aber ohne Ankündigung haben wir quasi jetzt fast so viel wie vorher mit Ankündigung.
Also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall aktiv zu streben.
Und ich werde mich jetzt auch mal um Subbutton kümmern, nachdem ich ja eben gerade erfahren habe,
dass sich da wirklich viele mitmachen würden, was ich gar nicht gedacht hätte.
Warum ich keine Ankündigung mache?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Fragt mich nicht so komplizierte Sachen.
Wahrscheinlich weil ich keine Leute hier haben will, die die ganze Zeit sagen,
oh, scheiß MMO, null, spiel mal Battlefield oder was auch immer.
Aber eigentlich sind ja meine Zuschauer nicht so schlimm.
Ja.
Vielleicht mache ich Ankündigungen zum Sylvester-Stream,
wo ganz No-Life-Leute können dann vorbeikommen.
War es mich unter den empfohlenen Kanälen empfunden?
Weil du sonst BDO guckst?
Oder das würde mich jetzt interessieren, was guckst du denn sonst so?
Wie kommt Twitch darauf, meinen Channel zu empfehlen?
Weil ich meine, die wissen ja nicht, dass du mich von YouTube kennst.
Oder kennst du mich gar nicht von YouTube.
Dann kannst du die Frage vergessen.
Das würde mich interessieren, wie sie das verknüpft haben.
98% Hype, jawoll.
Und es sind noch 2 Stunden In-Game-Nacht.
Oh, Buff-Food, fuck.
Leute, welches Buff-Food ist dran? Ich glaube das hier.
Das da, jawoll, richtig.
Easy-Clap, ich habe mal den richtigen Knopf gedrückt.
Meistens Final Fantasy XIV, okay.
Kann man das zur Zeit wieder spielen?
Also wir haben das ja auch lange gespielt, so 500-600 Stunden würde ich mal sagen.
Und was uns bei Final Fantasy XIV genervt hat, also mit uns meine ich jetzt den Friseur nicht.
Du machst Computer-Videos?
Auch, auch, ja.
Nee, ich dachte du bist hier über YouTube gekommen letztendlich.
Dann habe ich das, das ist ja noch geiler.
Dann funktioniert ja tatsächlich das Empfehlungssystem auf Twitch.
Im Vergleich zu YouTube.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen, Final Fantasy XIV, ja.
Das Problem, was wir mit Final Fantasy XIV hatten, ist, dass Progress wurde künstlich limitiert.
So nach dem Motto, ja, ihr könnt euch Ausrüstung kaufen für irgendwie die und die Kristalle.
Aber man konnte pro Woche nur so und so viel dieser Kristalle sammeln.
Und man hatte schlicht und ergreifend nichts zu tun.
Und das, obwohl wir nicht die High-End-Raider waren oder so in dem Game.
Was es ja so auch nicht wirklich gab.
Bis auf ein paar ultraschwere Herausforderungen für ein paar.
So normale, bisschen schwerere Raids gab es ja gar nicht.
Es gab so dieses GGEs Zeug, was jeder geschafft hat.
Oder halt damals noch Alexander, was so ultraschwer war.
Also nicht, nicht der normale, der Epic Raid oder wie das da hieß.
Deswegen haben wir dann gesagt, wir wollen mit Final Fantasy XIV auf.
Weil es keinen Sinn hatte.
Quasi Patch kommt raus.
Man hat nach ein paar Tagen alles und wartet dann wieder einen Monat auf nächsten Patch.
Das war blöd.
Warum geht es dann gerade?
Final Fantasy XIV.
Warum wir damit aufgehört haben?
Könntest du auch mal Spiele zeigen? Was meinst du?
Final Fantasy oder was?
Ne, da bin ich durch mit.
Die neue Erweiterung habe ich auch gar nicht gekauft.
Und ich habe auch gelesen, mit der neuen Erweiterung sollen wohl Andi 30-40% der Spieler aufgehört haben.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das offizielle Zahlen sind oder ob das so wieder übertriebenes Reddit-Gelaber ist.
Weiß ich nicht.
Oh fuck, Info ist voll.
Wie ich das ja anerkanne, oh fuck, Inventar ist voll so, als müsste man da viel machen.
Man drückt jetzt einfach zwei Knöpfe.
Dann hat man wieder bis zum Morgen zumindest genug Space.
Als wäre das jetzt sonderlich schwer gewesen.
Ja ja, trollt euch nur im Chat, ich kann das grad nicht 100% verfolgen.
Ich muss die letzte Stunde XP-Grind ausnutzen.
Alter BDO immer an der gleichen Stelle ruckelt, oh scheiße.
Piss dich Alde, geh weg.
Weiß gar nicht, ist es denn der Alde? Ja, ist es.
Alles weg, Speed an.
Weiter, nächster Spot.
Wieder zurück.
Komm, 99, 99 bevor die Nacht zu Ende ist, easy, 99 bevor die Nacht zu Ende ist.
Ja, Beatport, genau, die Maßen an Fan-Grills.
Ich sag dann, ich bin ein Wisser, darf ich dich verzaubern?
Meiner Meinung nach, das muss man RPG-mäßiger sagen.
Ich bin ein mächtiger Zauberer.
Darf ich euch verzaubern?
Dann guckt doch mal auf der Homepage vom Hersteller auf der Support-Seite von deinem Notebook-Modell nach.
Das haben die Hersteller noch alle mittlerweile auf ihrer Seite stehen.
Da gehst du in den Support-Bereich, gibst ein, was du für Notebook hast, da steht doch genau da, was das für technische Eigenschaften hat.
Das haben doch alle Hersteller mittlerweile.
Richtigen Endgame-Content gibt's in BDO nicht.
Was verstehst du an Endgame-Content?
Du kannst hier saumäßig viel machen.
Also Endgame-Content in Form von Gruppen-Rates mit Dungeon-Finder gibt es nicht, ne, das stimmt.
Braucht man aber auch nicht.
Theoretisch sollte jede Grafikkarte gleiche Anschlüsse haben.
Allerdings bei Notebooks weiß man das nie so genau, weil da oft mal so Special-Dinger drin stecken.
Also entweder so ein bisschen aufgebaut oder abgespeckte oder was auch immer für Versionen.
Also im Desktop-Bereich ist halt so, da ist vielleicht die Bestückung ein bisschen anders,
dass du dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dreimal HDMI statt zweimal HDMI oder sonst was hast.
Aber da machen sie im Prinzip auch das, was geht.
Also ich glaube nicht, wenn das geht, ein HDMI 2 zu verbauen, dass dann irgendein Hersteller noch sagt, nö, nö, nö, dann machen wir bloß 1-4.
Alter, was wollen die denn, das sind meine Mops.
Hör mal Awakening-Buff an.
Gleich die Nacht vorbei. Wir haben noch immer kein 990. Nacht vorbei.
Oh, ich hab jetzt so in einer scheiß Haltung die ganze Zeit da gesessen.
Ich muss mich jetzt mal irgendwie so halb hinlegen.
Da merkt man, manchmal merke ich, dass ich 33 bin.
Manchmal merke ich, früher konnte ich 10 Stunden vorm Rechner in scheiß Haltung sitzen
und grinden und leveln und campen und ach, keine Ahnung, alles.
Und heute tut man nach ein paar Stunden der Rücken weh, wenn ich scheiße sitze.
Ich bin jetzt auch noch gar nicht fertig, jetzten Tag.
Lothric spielt gerade fortnite, lasst ihn nur spielen wenn ihm das Spaß macht.
Langt ja dabei auch 20 Schweiber weg.